foreign
foreign
the public order emergency commission is
now in session is
good morning bonjour
so we have superintendent Abrams
if you could come forward please
okay are you ready to proceed yes
commissioner thank you okay so uh the
first up I believe is the uh Ottawa
Police Service
[Music]
good morning superintendent my name is
David mitchikoska I'm a lawyer for the
Ottawa Police Service how are you good
sir thank you
um one of the things you mentioned
yesterday and I believe it's also in
your notes as well
is that police actions in Ottawa you
indicated can have a provincial and a
national impact so there's a need for
the police to be measured and careful in
their approach to dealing with this the
protesters is that fair that is fair
and how the police treat the protesters
I take it from the time they arrive in
Ottawa to the time they leave will
therefore be expected to have an impact
both uh in Ottawa and nationally
I I that's what I believe yes and I
believe you said that once the Convoy
was on route to Ottawa and some people
had come from you know the uh the West
Coast far away there was no way that you
could just cause them to turn around and
go home without making their statement
in Ottawa somehow correct
I don't recall stating that but I think
I stated that they're committed in their
goal of attending Ottawa clearly because
they left their homes uh thousands of
kilometers away and their intent was to
attend Ottawa
and the practice of the police prior to
the freedom Convoy in previous protests
was to let groups come to town and
protest
even if uh it would cause significant
traffic disruption uh and inconvenience
to Residents as long as it was peaceful
and not engaging in criminality is that
fair I'm obviously not being a member of
the auto Police Service they dealt with
the majority of those protests in my
role was the Provincial Police I can't
say that I've
um had to do with that type of event but
in general terms I would agree
um when people exercise their Charter
rights there's certainly going to be
some disruptions to members of the
public while that's being done but
generally in most circumstances without
disruption is short-lived in my
experience right but if somebody says
I'm coming to protest for one day or I'm
coming to protest for three days but
it's going to be peaceful and there's no
criminality you let them protest fair
enough
there certainly would be lots of
planning that's what we talk about
pre-event planning trying to to speak to
the organizers come up to agreements to
make sure everybody's on the same page
I've not been involved in agreements
where we've allowed protests that lasted
multiple days and that's just been my
experience I haven't been involved in
that so I can't really speculate it or
answer whether whether I would approve
something like that or not eopp has
dealt with long-term protests as an
organization we have yes sorry as an
organization we have right you
personally have not and some of those
demonstrations went on for long periods
head injunctions that uh the longest
period I was involved in was the
three-week protest of the Thai Mega rail
ball gates in 2020.
um the Hendon reports as I recall and
indicated that the groups did uh espouse
uh peaceful protest although there were
concern about Fringe groups and lone
wolves is that right sounds accurate yes
and the reports from the plts prior to
the Convoy arriving in Ottawa had been
that they were peaceful and Cooperative
with police in other jurisdictions
that's why we're calling us and the
reports from Hendon did not indicate
honking horns or idling engines or
harassment or antisocial Behavior or
fireworks is that fair the only thing I
would say is there was some reports of
anti-social behavior in respect to
perhaps not dividing by mass mandates
within the province of Ontario but
outside of that I would agree with your
statement yes
and um blocking the access to the
Wellington Street or to a large chunk or
two chunks of downtown could have meant
that the trucks would go elsewhere you
said in the city
uh yes and that would mean though
potentially that the footprint could be
bigger and there could be more
disruption in residential neighborhoods
Fair
certainly it's a large city so wherever
the trucks are going to park there's
going to be disruption wherever they
tend to park for sure and because
peaceful protest is lawful and because
of the need to take a measured approach
the opp as I understand it is a huge
proponent of the use of plts
you're very much are yes they connect
with groups they get contacts they form
relationships correct
and in fact the opp plts here did have
their uh plts connect with the
protesters well prior to arrival correct
um yes I mean the Convoy organizers they
connected when they arrived within the
province of Ontario and those PLT
um
who were in contact with the protesters
were not I take it
telling them the message you better not
come to Ottawa you're not welcome right
they were trying to establish
relationships uh because they understood
it to be a peaceful protest correct many
times our plts will message what you
stated but also message the importance
of understanding the law sometimes
they'll educate them on the law and make
sure they understand you know when you
attend this is what the expectation is
this is what the laws will be in
relation to your behavior so many times
PLT will be part of that messaging to
make sure that all
participants are aware of their
responsibilities and expectations of
their behaviors and in fact consistent
with that role the plts assisted the
Convoy in arriving safely in Ottawa
I would agree just through conversation
that allowed more structured movement of
vehicles which which made things
ultimately safer I would agree with that
and I think you said you'd read the hand
in reports and you became involved if I
have that right on uh January 24th as
the opp strategic commander in charge of
policing
yes I became an institution commander in
charge of
aopps portion of the event which was
what we saw at that time as a traffic
event involving the the vehicles
traveling through our jurisdiction into
the city Ottawa and you set up an
Emergency Operations Center that
involved traffic Communications plts
correct and the plan focused on traffic
along the highways from the Convoy
correct and focused on the traffic and
also what impacts they may have in the
communities that they overnighted in
and the 400 series of Highways I believe
you said the opp has jurisdiction on
that's correct and that is the uh the
417 of course leads directly into Ottawa
downtown correct it's the Queens becomes
the Queensway
and what you and your team did as I
understand it was ensure that there was
a safe flow of traffic and that they
could arrive safely and you and your
team took steps to coordinate planning
of that with the Ottawa Police
that's correct
and so you um liaised uh with the deputy
chief Bell
yes and he was cooperative in your
interactions with him very much so we
agreed that our
our traffic inspectors would connect
with each other and they would do the
bulk of the work to do the coordination
and so uh you had an inspector I believe
her name was Don Ferguson and you had a
staff sergeant Lisa Nicholson coordinate
with the Ottawa Police
correct uh Lisa Nicholas was her last
name but they helped coordinate yes and
um inspector Ferguson we have a lot of
Fergusons in this case but inspector Don
Ferguson of the opp was the officer
assigned uh to be the representative of
the opp and then I understand she worked
with the Ops and others at the NCR CC
correct that's correct and she was there
as of January 25th so a few days before
the protesters arrived sounds awkward
and
um a staff sergeant
um uh Nicholson did you say Nicholas
Nicholas I'm sorry uh was placed at a
separate Ops uh Command Center outside
of uh
out with
the Ottawa Police is that correct yes I
believe staff sergeant Nicholas she kind
of moved between the two locations or
was kind of a traffic Hub that had MTO
cameras that staff sergeant Nicholas
would work with our MTO partners and our
police Partners at and she would also
make her way over to the ncrcc as well
so she kind of worked in both locations
and she assisted inspector Ferguson she
did inspector Ferguson relied on some
assistance from staff sergeant Nicholas
so she helped assist her in in different
ways and the opp worked with the Ops to
control
um Highway 17 and coming into Ottawa and
make sure that you didn't have blockades
on the highway that's correct
and um the
your team along with the Ops uh Team uh
ensured that wanted to make sure that
trucks didn't just abandon their
vehicles on the 417 on The Queensway in
downtown
Ottawa but that they safely got off and
were staged somewhere correctly and we
wanted obviously when we talk about
safety it's not just safety of the
Convoy participants it's the safety of
the motoring public or using the highway
and we didn't close the highway so the
highway was open to normal traffic so we
had to make sure that we were ensuring
the safety of the general motoring
public as well
um one of the things that I can turn up
the document if you need it but I think
you said this yesterday uh was you
talked about Chief slowly on the weekend
of the February uh fifth weekend the
fourth fifth wanting to and again I
think the following weekend as well
wanting to shut down all the 417 off
ramps do you call that do you recall
that
and inspector uh Ferguson as I
understand
um said in one of those emails we'll do
our best to help the convoys
to uh the identified exits
um but the opp is not going to
permanently close any 417 exits unless
there's an immediate threat to Public
Safety and there wasn't correct correct
and so the opp did not exercise its
power to close all the exits to downtown
uh as a result
correct and you instead controlled
access so that they could come in safely
correct and just so we're clear I
apologize if I misunderstood your
question
um the permanent shutdown that she
slowly spoke about and US selectively
picking off-ramps for the Convoy to come
in we're we're on separate dates right
um and uh but you did make clear that uh
and I believe she says it in her email
we will not permanently like close all
the exits unless there's an immediate
public safety risk and there isn't
correct certainly we wanted to not
disrupt the general motoring public as
much as little as possible that was the
idea so we would close ramps as needed
and then as soon as we could we would
reopen them so that the normal flow
traffic excuse me traffic could continue
sure and because if you close everything
it not only affects the Convoy but it
affects everyone else sure all of the
residents trucks that have legitimate
business downtown delivering goods and
supplies mode other motorists residents
who have a need to be in that downtown
core correct I would agree yes
and um we saw one of the Hendon reports
had pictures of some heavy equipment an
air compressor and an ATV
yes and you didn't receive any
instructions I take it to stop those
transports or to inspect them or to not
let them into the city did you I never
received instructions like that no
um and some of those uh and there were
only a couple of pieces of heavy
equipment that we saw correct correct
and some of those May well have come
into the city on a 400 series Highway
correct
um if we could please turn up OPP
0774 please
which are your I don't know if you have
the hard copy you do you do
um so it's your January 25th notes
yes and it is um page three e uh of 167
in the PDF
foreign
January 25th I apologize and you'll see
at 8 30
um uh
you request uh
someone uh with the Ministry of
Transport of Ontario to see if they plan
to use weigh scales for Convoy uh
trucks correct correct
uh and the MTO has no plans to do so
correct correct and so uh one of the
things that perhaps could have prevented
uh some of that heavy equipment or some
of those Vehicles was to have waste uh
stations opened along the highway
correct but the MTO decided not to do
that
I just wanted to see if that was part of
their plan and I was advised that it was
not
and if I could please ask you um to look
at again this is in your uh it's not in
your notes I apologize it's opp0773
foreign
statement that you prepared I believe
um in March of 2022 correct
and so you prepared that at the time
when the events were pretty clear in
your mind
you just finished dealing with the
Convoy correct correct and you'd read
the Hendon reports back in January
correct I did
and so if we could please look at
um page two of
that dot of the PDF of that
and on the third uh
bullet uh you indicate uh it became
clear on January 29th that many of the
Convoy participants had plans to stay
for a long period of time
and the Convoy had attracted thousands
uh to the downtown Port correct yes and
then if um we also uh look if we could
scroll down to the bottom of the page
uh sorry just uh go up a bit
um I'm sorry go to the uh I'm sorry a
little bit go up to the top again if you
don't mind
foreign
and sorry if you could um go to the
following page as well
yeah
just a little bit higher
thank you very much
um you'll see in the uh bullet that we
have on the screen on February 2nd it
then became clear that this event was no
longer a traffic related event correct
for
um
um
in your notes
um and I again we can turn them up but
if you recall then I you know I don't
need you to but I I know in your notes
February
5th and it's on page 28 of your notes
but
um uh you have a note that the chief is
in charge
and won't change it
I'm sorry you said page 28
um I thought it was I was trying to also
uh give you your but I'll
it is I believe page 28 of your notes
foreign
which is February 5th
and it is on page 28 which is the second
page
and do you see what I'm referring to yes
yeah can you just explain that what did
you mean the chief is in charge and
won't change it
so if we go back this is uh part of a
teleconference I was involved in
um
where um inspector Jason Union is uh
kind of giving us an overview of an
email that was sent by Chief slowly and
um
and and giving uh kind of an overview of
what he saw and
um the context of what Chief Sully's
email had had to say
and um
so these are inspector Union's words to
me saying that there was a major
curriculum Incident Commander
superintendent Dunlop but no major
Incident Commander no one was in charge
the chief is in charge and will not
change that once lockdown so these are
inspector Union's words being related to
me and me making notes and so what he's
saying is this is a problem that Chief
slowly is saying he has to be in charge
of this no one else is is that right
this is inspector Union's interpretation
of what's going on yes
thank you
um
and the following pay on page 29 of your
notes as well
um you also I have a note that uh
inspector uh
commissioner Carrick must become engaged
uh with uh need to display I.E did a
measured approach inspector Carrick
needs to become engaged with slowly
over
[Music]
um
members and risks with his unreasonable
demands
and what were those unreasonable demands
that were being referred to so inspector
Union's briefing to us you spoke about
what she slowly was asking not only of
his members but what appeared to be also
partner agencies which included the opp
so there was talk about wanting all
streets barricaded and contained
um
and these were activities that I was not
comfortable with our members being
involved in and it caused me a great
concern so
um on this call I expressed that we
needed to communicate with commissioner
Creek so you could become aware of this
direction but I teach slowly through
Chief slowly's email
um and then perhaps commissioner Creek
and chief slowly could have a
conversation because I felt that these
were on reasonable demands and I
directed
my inspector first and if there was a
request for OPP to to be a part of any
of this it was not to happen it was to
come through myself before many OPP
members would become engaged in that
types of activity I'd heard about and I
just have um two further questions
um on February 6th in your notes
um and you've actually uh put an Asterix
uh on it
uh and just uh for the benefit of those
who are following it online it is page
28 of 167 of the PDF but I don't need
you to uh call it up
um you talk you uh indicate at the
bottom lack of autonomy to make
decisions
uh who's that a reference to
so
um further up in the notes at 1543 I'm
speaking with inspector Marcel Boden
who's our PLT coordinator who the
commission will hear from
um as a witness and he's describing his
members experiences on the ground in
Ottawa and that inability to make
decisions and um be given autonomy to do
their work that's and sorry go ahead I I
apologize
um
so that was very concerning for him and
for his team because that's that's what
they do their job is to get engaged with
uh protesters in this case it was comedy
protesters established relationships
determine uh what their
goals are how can we facilitate and exit
what does an exit look like all those
activities trying to obtain those a
win-win situations where it's a bit of a
give and take amongst protesters in PLT
to try to establish Rapport and trust
with each other
and they weren't able to do any of that
and I can only imagine if that's your
sole job and you're being preventing
from being able to do that that it can
be frustrating so in my role as
strategic Commander I was asked to see
what I could do to deconflict that or
resolve that because that was their
concern they weren't allowed to be to
make decisions and you understood that
that lack of autonomy was as a result of
Chief slowly's Direction and
that's what I was informed of correct
but in your dealings with deputy chief
Bell and deputy chief Ferguson they
appeared to welcome the assistance of
the opp and they were Cooperative uh
with you and engaged with you is that
fair very much so yes and finally you're
well over time so I kind of have to ask
you to wrap up sure uh last question
um then
um uh you talked about the plts and you
understood that Staff Sergeant John
Ferguson uh was in charge of the plts in
Ottawa is that right for the Ottawa
please correct right and you understood
that he too was frustrated with the lack
of uh involvement of the plts he was
supporting what the opp was wanted I
understood that yes thank you very much
uh those are my questions
thank you next up are the Convoy
organizers
good morning Mr commissioner good
morning superintendent Abrams and good
morning my friends my name is Bathsheba
Vandenberg and I am Council representing
Freedom Corp and protesters
thank you for your service
superintendent and for your fourth with
testimony so far
I have a few questions for you this
morning you mentioned yesterday in your
testimony that the PLT use a snatch and
grab method correct
they do not I use that method
um I Believe In My Testimony yesterday I
indicated that
um
major curriculum Incident Commander
superintendent Patterson wanted to do
stats and grabs and wanted PLT
assistance with that and that actually
was one of my main concerns because our
PLT units are not used in that fashion
ever so actually it's the opposite of
your suggestion so you can confirm that
the method of snatch and grab was not
used between February 6th and 10th of
2002 to 2022 rather oh no I can't
confirm that those operations would have
been done by Ottawa Police Service if
they did them
my purpose in communicating to
superintendent Patterson was if him and
his service wish to do that there would
be no OPP support in doing so they may
have occurred
but if they did occur they would have
been done by the Ottawa Police Service
without OPP member participation
I want to
do you agree that it means police
officers lined up in a horizontal line
and in their right gear right
that's not how I see it snatch and grabs
is not a it's not a policing term to be
honest that I'm familiar with as far as
a technique that we're taught or
instructed on when I heard
um superintendent pouch and explain that
he didn't explain it in great detail I
pictured in my mind it was
um
trying to locate certain individual
persons who may have reasonable grounds
to be arrested and essentially when
they're located
grab them off the street wherever
they're located and arrest them under
those authorities that's how I viewed
what snatch and crab was I did not view
it as a group
activity it was more an individual
activity
you would agree though that it does
involve grabbing protesters is that
correct
I mean the individual person may be a
protester
themselves but I just uh I pictured an
operation where officers are going up
looking for one particular person or
persons on a list but not uh the persons
aren't together in a group
and when if an opportunity arose it
would affect an arrest of that singular
person
thank you
was this method to the best human
knowledge used after the emergencies Act
was invoked
I can't I can't speak to that because I
wasn't connected with the Auto police
operations at that level
you mentioned in your testimony
yesterday that you only found out about
the creation of the Red Zone on February
17th is that correct
I think that's correct through um media
that was posted on Ottawa Police Twitter
and some media releases it were released
by Ottawa Police or they spoke about the
formation of this red so
is it true that you also found out on
the same date of February 17th that
there would be 900 officers reporting at
6 a.m the following morning Friday
morning February 18th
so yeah yes but if I could expand on
that answer a little bit to add some
context to it so the evening
um
so your the date was February 19th or
indicating
in the evening of the February 17th that
you found out that it's again the next
morning on February 18th that would be
900. I believe the 17th was a Thursday
am I correct the 17th was this Thursday
evening that's correct so the next date
was a planned large public order unit
deployment which that was the first time
we would have seen a large number of
public organ members on the street and
on my people's role that people I was in
control of would be to be at traffic
points to help contain and control any
ground that public order units were able
to clear
and late that evening I believe it was
around 10 o'clock uh 50 RCMP members
attended our OPP command post and
indicated that they were reporting to
our location starting the next morning
along with Ottawa Police
and that was concerning to me only
because I was already deploying close to
five to six hundred of my own members
and if we added Ottawa Police and RCMP
that would be 900 members and we would
not physically be able to get that many
members onto the street in time to
support the operation that was planned
for the next day
so was it in your professional opinion
that there was insufficient time to
properly brief these 900 police officers
prior to them being deployed on the
ground
there would not have been sufficient
time to brief them and get them on the
ground so that's why that evening as a
team I gathered my Incident Commander
Ottawa Police Service
um supervisors were on our Command Post
helping us with telecommunications and I
gathered them in a group and we all said
we have to solve this problem
um because we're literally hours away
from a major operation so
collaboratively and together we all
agreed on solution so that we did not
have to deal with that issue the next
morning and we were able to get officers
deployed in a reasonable amount of time
was the name of this major operation
Operation takedown I was never aware of
what the public order unit operation
name was I just knew that there was a
public public order operation happening
next morning but I wasn't familiar with
the name of it
as per the Ontario Police Services act
regulations 926 all police officers
including public order unit members
performing active duty shall have an
up-to-date use of forced qualification
within the last 12 months is that
correct
I believe that a place to all serving
police officers in the project materials
so it would apply to public ordering
members as well
would you be able to confirm that all
officers
including those 900
that have had that qualification before
they were deployed I would not be able
to confirm that because I I don't have
that information and if I could qualify
on my answer there is a provision that
allows so the assessor General's office
to provide an extension to that 12
months whether it be due to an emergency
best example I can give you in this case
when the public order uh
process started we had a large influx of
Opp members come to the city of Ottawa I
had an additional almost over 400
officers come to the city to be able to
get the many members to the city we had
to do some logistical operations within
an organization and one of those was to
cancel block training which is annual
training for members on use of force and
the firearm recallification
so in doing so some of those members may
have gone outside the 12 months we
needed to seek approval to allow them to
maybe be beyond the 12-month period but
that is allowed within the Police
Service Act with proper authorities
was your role after the emergencies Act
was invoked ER Logistics and planning
liaison
I'm sorry after it was invoked what was
my role yeah was it was it um Logistics
and planning
no my role was as a strategic Commander
so I oversaw a team of
um of officers that were led by an
incident commander who their job was to
organize the logistics of finding out
where Ottawa Police needed us because we
were a support agency to the Ottawa
Police and then my assistant commander
and his team would provide other police
with the support that they needed
honor with me with Frontline officers
the public order unit command and what
they needed for public ordering it was
separate for myself and I didn't have
direction or control over our public
union members
and you were reporting to Chief
superintendent Carson party is that
correct
yes you considered him your commander
I did
were you involved in the planning phase
for the operation the major operation
only for I believe I said yesterday only
for about 48 hours just in the initial
stages when the integrated playing team
got started and we had our initial
meetings on the on the 8th and the 9th
and that was the only time I had Direct
contact with the members of that
planning team and I I reverted back to
my role of managing our OPP members and
our deployments in support of the Ottawa
Police with regard to the boots on the
ground were PLT supporting pous
I was not aware of of what plg was doing
I know PLT eventually uh had a seat in
the ncrcc with our critical incident
Commander so there was always I believe
was a PLT sergeant that sat beside our
credit coincident Commander
um but I'm not aware exactly what they
were doing in the field because that
would not have been reported to me
and yesterday you mentioned that OPP and
Ops plts had an integration problem and
Communications issues is that right
that's what was reported to me correct
and also with the pous
um I I can't say that I heard of a lack
of integration within our public order
units that wasn't reported to me
do you agree with me that after the
invocation of the emergencies act that
these integration problems and
Communications problems uh continued and
did not improve
uh within the PLT teams there was still
there were still issues I would have
calls with inspector beauden and he
would say some days they were making
forward progress and other days they
still left an ability to understand what
the plan was because until the
integrated planning team came up with a
plan there was still no plan so they
still struggled to determine what their
purpose was were they truly integrated
team between the Ottawa Police Service
PLT team and the opp PLT team there were
still those issues yes
and that in fact that the problems
worsened after the influx of 900
additional officers on the ground on
Friday morning the 18th of February
I don't know if it's any worsened I
think they may they maintained and
became they were similar but I don't
know that they became any worse
would you agree with me that due to the
lack of integration and communication
problems that that would lead to a
problem ultimately in decision making
throughout the major operations
certainly
um the information that PLT is able to
provide and tell us about conversations
they're having with Convoy organizers
and exit plans or what the intent of the
organizers are is very important in
forming operational plans of how we're
going to approach a protests so being
unable to get that information has an
impact yes in a negative way
and when I imagine major operation I
mean after the invocation of the
emergencies Act
so I consider it one giant operation and
and the lack of communication that
impacts all along
um from invocation period prior to and
during
if it didn't improve after the
invocation of the emergencies act would
you agree that it
got worse
I can't say it got worse it just seemed
to be a similar theme throughout my time
as strategic Commander is I continue to
hear the lack of communication the lack
of integration that was a common theme
it didn't seem to increase through one
day or the other whether prior to
February 14th or after
it seemed to be a similar theme
throughout
and the Final Phase after this major
operation after the invocation of the
emergencies Act was called the
maintenance phase is that correct
I've recall that name being used it just
it was a phrase meant to maintain and
hold ground that public order unit
members were able to clear our streets
intersections those types of things
do you agree that every officer who
draws their firearm in the present of
public and uses weapons or improvised
weapon other than a firearm on another
person or uses physical force on a
person that results in an injury to that
person requiring medical attention shall
complete a use of force report prior to
the end of Duty
um I can only speak to the opp there is
a use of force reporting requirement
um I apologize I'm not certain on the
timelines of when it shall be done
whether it's at the end of their shift
or within a certain number of days I'd
have to review the legislation so
unfortunately I can't give you the exact
answer on that but
um I tried to follow all that you were
speaking about but from whatever
um heard you say it seems to check all
the boxes that are related to our
members when they have to fill out use
of force reports and all the occasions
you mentioned from what I recall hearing
fit those needs to have a user Force
report can let's admitted
timelines aside where any of those use
of force reports completed after the
major operations after the invocation of
the emergencies act I I'm not aware
yesterday you mentioned that you
listened and you watched Chief
superintendent rather superintendent
Morris's testimony yesterday is that
correct you mentioned that yesterday in
your testimony I've seen parts of his
testimony yes yes and do you agree with
it
I I don't disagree with it many of the
things that superintendent Moore said it
was his testimony and was consistent
with
um our organizational values and and his
public um provincial intelligence Bureau
mandates
thank you those are all my questions and
thank you again for your service thank
you
thank you thank you next I'd call on the
government of Canada
thank you superintendent Abrams my name
is Brenton finian heis and I'm one of
the lawyers for the government of Canada
and I just have a few questions for you
about your testimony yesterday morning
uh you described um yesterday at some
length a difference of view or approach
between yourself for members of your
team of the opp
and chief slowly and some of those
working under him at the Ops about the
importance in this scenario of PLT
techniques right correct yeah
uh and in particular you described or
you relayed information upwards
about a significant dispute that had
Arisen about the arrest of those who are
removing gas cans from the Coventry Road
encampment
correct yeah
at those gas cans which were in part
there as a supply of fuel to vehicles in
the red zone
or a serious concern as to safety right
certainly inflammable products sure and
they're used as a supply was also a
concern about it supporting the
continued entrenchment of the trucks in
the downtown core right sure
the opp PLT and some of the Ops BLT
members as well I take it
were concerned that the trust that had
been invested by them and by the
protesters at that Coventry Road Site
had been disrupted or even destroyed by
the arrests that were uh that occurred
right that was their concern yes
and some of the PLT team members felt
extremely demoralized and as though
their work had been set back by days or
even longer correct
some days had already been invested I
take it in building those relationships
with the Coventry Road encampment
participants as I understand it yes
and I think that the flash point for
that disagreement as we saw from the
documents was on or around February the
8th does that Accord with your
recollection
that seems accurate yeah
and so by February the 8th the Convoy uh
had been ongoing in the downtown part of
Ottawa for approximately 11 Days running
from January the 29th
seems accurate yes
and now it would take several more days
in the view of the PLT team to get back
to that point if not longer right
that was that was what they felt the
worst case scenario would look like they
were certainly hoping it wouldn't take
that many days but that was their
concern
in negotiating with the participants in
the fashion that the PLT units do
is it fair to say that some are more
susceptible to being reasoned with than
others
are are people more or some people more
usable to reason with than others is
that what you're saying yes I would say
that's an accurate statement yes sure
and if we if I just want to call up a a
document Ops three zeros10383
foreign
just by way of example a superintendent
this is a report from Ops some PLT uh
members describing
uh uh uh the name is redacted but one of
the organizers from the East Convoy
uh
to give a sense of what certain groups
or factions are looking for do you see
that I do
and he's indicating that this individual
wants meeting with the governor general
and the Prime Minister and the speaker
of the Senate right
so it appears and that was not the sort
of thing that would be readily within
the control of a PLT unit Fair correct
yes that's right and so this would be an
example of someone who's more difficult
at least on the by appearances at least
to come to a deal with so to speak to
resolve situation peacefully is that
fair
yeah certainly harder to resolve and
would involve more time in trying to to
adjust their you know try to measure
their expectations perhaps sure and that
informs the usefulness of a
de-escalation or negotiation approach
with a particular organizer or a group
of organizers right the reasonableness
of their requirements in order to uh
come into compliance with the law
yeah it certainly gives you a very quick
understanding of are we going to be able
to have some type of back and forth a
reasoning or whether we're just never
going to be able to come to a to an
agreement okay
okay just returning to this Coventry
Road Site which was the locus of this um
you know Contra top or dispute and a lot
of you want to call it
uh that site is approximately I think
four and a little more than four
kilometers away from Parliament Taylor
in the center of Wellington Street is
that fair uh that's fair I'm not from
the city of Ottawa so I'll have to take
your word for that but it seems accurate
I'm going from Google Maps so it's um
but but it's several kilometers away
reasonable at least sir sounds
reasonable sure
um and uh
in speaking yesterday
to my friend uh uh commission council
with respect to your the conversation
that you didn't recall I think but that
was recorded by Dana early in her Notes
From The Windsor side of things you're
calling being asked about that yes I
recall okay and you were asked to I
guess really speculate or or or
um about your apparent comment that in
Ottawa unlike when Windsor the blockade
was quote not affecting livelihoods at
least that's what she had noted do you
call that
like I said I I don't recall are the
details of our conversation I think the
notes uh that were presented yesterday
were scribe notes so she had a scribe
attached to her so I was writing down
what we were conversing about I didn't
have a scribe during this event so I'm
trying to use my independent right
collection about the details of that
conversation sure and I just want to be
fair to you to make make it clear what
you what you can recall and what you
can't which is perfectly fair but I just
wanted to return to what you'd said as
you speculated about it you you you
thought that you might have been
speaking from your impression uh
gathered driving around Ottawa outside
of the downtown core in the parliament
Precinct
that it was quite manageable to drive
around town right
yes I believe from my recollection we
were speaking about uh the Ambassador
Bridge being blocked and how it was if
you're fair with Windsor it's the one
way into Windsor and if it's blocked it
makes travel difficult within the whole
city and uh ever called not
conversations just about the economic
impacts of that international bridge
blockade and those kinds of things and
then I would I recall relating back to
her how the blockade hironato was
affecting the city as a whole not just
the downtown court sure sure just
different geography in a different
scenario right you could get back and
forth down the 417 and off to the
Coventry Road Site relatively smoothly
I can't speak to government too real
because it's on I believe it's on the
north side of 417 but I was speaking
more about you know areas south of the
417 and the 417 itself
um and that's quite distinct from what
was going on in the heart of uh downtown
Ottawa and Parliament Hill
oh correct if I could just show you a
photograph of moments it's Ott that this
was from Mr ayat some evidence
ott30 one zero zero zero five
and it'll be page 37.
it doesn't want to come up
quickly well
do you recall at any point if I can't
get the photograph up um there being a a
large industrial crane on Wellington
Street at certain points
I believe it's the one that had the
large Canadian flag
um it was extended with a flag on the
end of it yes I recall seeing visuals of
that yes and that industrial crane for
example presented a potential for
Syria's danger to persons or property if
it were to be misused right
I would I would agree with that
statement yes and there was also the
presence you know again not on Coventry
Road but in the Parliamentary Precinct
and on Wellington Street of an
uncontrolled and unknown quantities of
gas or diesel fuel there as well right
yeah yes which is fuel in that area and
just as in the Coventry Road area those
can explode and cause serious fires in
that downtown sector of Ottawa as well
if they're to be a satellite right
certainly
um
I want to come back now to the
difference of you about plts you told us
yesterday that In fairness to Chief
slowly uh you know in characterizing the
difference of view that he may have been
taking quite a high level perspective
in his preference by February 8th to
enforce through public order operations
in preference to investing in the PLT
engagements right
that seemed to be the case then and yes
and
uh you appreciate that if Chief slowly's
perspective may have been high level
that the perspective at the political
level would probably have been at even
higher level is that fair
I can't speculate on the political
context
okay is it fair to say that the
differences of opinion and the
disagreements or even arguments amongst
the participants in the policing
operations
from Opp Ops and later the RCMP that
these were operational in nature
I would agree yes I would agree
and these kinds of operational
disagreements are not typically brought
to the awareness of the political level
Fair
um
it's not something certainly not at my
level
it would not be appropriate to directly
engage the political level and
operational questions like that is that
fair
it would not be inappropriate it would
not be appropriate appropriate
um I've
at my level it's not something I've ever
been engaged with at a commissioner
level a chief level I can't speculate
I've never held tools ranks so I'm not
sure what is appropriate or not
appropriate for a chief of police or
commissioner to communicate with a
politician at your level it would not be
appropriate or you would perceive it as
concerning if a minister for example
were to try to intrude into or give
direction on the operational questions
you were discussing
it would concern me because of the
operational impacts of somebody who's
unknown to me having impacts on an
operation we're trying to result
when you express the opinion yesterday
that there were ways to enforce that
could have ended the convoys occupation
of downtown Ottawa short of the
emergencies act you were speaking just
from your own visibility right
I'm sorry what do you mean by visibility
uh speaking just from the things that
you can see on the ground in Ottawa and
in the east region of Ontario
I apologize I have to get to repeat the
question again now that I understand the
context yes when you expressed The View
that there were ways to enforce and end
the Convoy occupation in downtown Ottawa
short of the emergencies act you're
speaking from your what you can see on
the ground in Ottawa in the east region
of Ontario yes and from past experience
in resolving blockades and prior to the
emergency Act
you also acknowledged yesterday and
you'll agree with me that this wasn't an
isolated event and that an event
occurring in Ottawa would have an
immediate impact on what was going on in
Coots and what was going on at the
Ambassador Bridge Fair yes I agree all
those activities have linkages and have
impacts to each other
and that may have been part of the
assessment for all you know at the
political level in terms of what was
visible there
perhaps I I can't be sure finally just
with respect to the measures being used
can we turned very briefly to omt500168
uh do you see this is a a forum letter
from commissioner karik to all
identified towing companies do you see
that I do see it and if you just scroll
down the page
you'll see that uh this is um
indicates
sorry maybe not that far down just go
back up
this provides the guidelines for the
requirement of Towing to be provided by
um
towing companies under the emergency
measures regulations right okay it seems
to be that's the topic of the of the
memo yes and that you'll agree with me
was used by the OPP to require towing
companies to supply services
it seems to be that I was not involved
in that part of the operation so okay
fair enough if we could go to opp403660
[Applause]
. direct do you see this is a notice to
demonstration participants from February
the 17th yeah and this was distributed
by
um the teams on the ground including
members of the opp to protesters to warn
them of the legal consequences of
remaining in the red zone right yes
and it refers to
criminal offenses but if you go down the
page it refers as well of course to the
consequences arising under the
emergencies act right that seems to be
what it says yes and by the time the
public order operations began in Earnest
that day the 17th
Communications like this had had an
effect on reducing the footprint of the
crowd is that fair
because I wasn't involved in the
integrated Planning Group or seeing
reports from PLT I can't say whether it
had a positive impact in members or
people protesters choosing to leave or
not leave just because of my role in
that period of time I was insulated and
focused on just deploying my members uh
in support of the auto Police Service so
I wasn't getting reports on you know how
many uh protesters are choosing to leave
or the success or non-success of
items like this
but you appreciate at least from the
perspective of the consequence that it's
attempting to communicate that that's
the purpose of it right is to allow for
a peaceful opportunity to depart yes I
mean this is exactly uh kind of what
have I spoke about this is one of those
communication mediums that PLT uses to
communicate with protesters so that they
understand because some may not
understand that you that they're
committing an offense and this may be
um the consequences if you don't
sometimes there's timelines put on them
sometimes there's not but this is
classic uh PLT communication process yes
and in your experience it's effective
right
in my experience it has been very
effective and because it's it follows
the measured approach it follows the
framework it makes sure that anybody
involved in the protest clearly
understands uh Jeopardy or understands
police timelines in relation to what we
plan to do we're open we're being honest
and so there's no misunderstanding or
miscommunication about what may be
occurring into the future
and this public or order operation so
far as you're aware was able to proceed
in Ottawa without death or serious
bodily injury to any of the participants
there was bodily injury to participants
from from I saw I saw some people excuse
me there was some injuries to people I
understand the SIU became engaged in
some injuries so there was injuries to
participants I'm aware of
and that's just
me seeing the media those weren't things
that were reported to me through China
command or anything like that sure but
you're you're not aware of any death or
serious bodily injuries
um I'm not aware of any deaths um I have
to say that I saw a serious poly injury
because if you look at the definition
and Mandate of the special investigation
student of Ontario they only become
involved when they're serious bodily
injury so because they were engaged in
one incident I'd have to say that
serious poly injury within that
definition occurred in that situation
all right the the the the the the the
encampment was or sorry the occupation
at any rate was resolved
uh after the enforcement operation went
underway with the assistance of the
communications as far as you knew yes
and that was the purpose of the OPP's
assistance throughout the Convoy to
begin with right was to resolve the
situation
along with our partners it wasn't
necessarily OPP's job to resolve this
situation no no but that's the purpose
of OPP's assistance yes to try to help
to resolve yes and when the EA was
revoked the Act was revoked on the 23rd
you directed the employment of common
law powers to prevent further assembly
for approximately another 24 hours
um correct and then you concluded that
that power was no longer necessary or
applicable because the situation had
been resolved
the the situation had been resolved but
more so and there was no police
intelligence to indicate that the common
lawyer participants were going to
reattend and and continue to commit the
offenses that they were committing so
therefore we needed to to fall back
thank you those are my questions
thank you uh next I'd like to call on
the lawyer for former Keith slowly
I'm Tom Curry
uh commissioner just before I begin I
believe I I think
not many of my friends some of my
friends have gone a little bit over I
would be grateful if I could have a bit
of an Indulgence if I need to use some
of the time that I have been allocated
for the witness this afternoon I will
I will cash that time in
um
I've not
seen that type of trading going on and I
don't want to encourage it
I have been a little bit
liberal because it's Friday but and we
don't have as much of a heavy schedule
but I so I will have some Indulgence but
please don't abuse understood thank you
superintendent you first got engaged in
this you've told us when you received an
email
assigning you to this
um
event on the 24th of January yeah yes
sir three days out from the first convoy
truck rolling into the city
um I'm not so that was away from the
workplace prior to so I'm not sure uh
when one truck may have arrived in the
city the majority of the trucks were
planned to arrive at the end of that
week so I can't State what trucks were
in town on the 24th of January no no
sorry three days out from when they
arrived you you you came on on the 24th
right I was going the other way in the
calendar you were right so am I right
that you were given by your command I
think you got it in the afternoon of the
24th so you get it four o'clock or some
such thing on the 24th and you've now
got three days
to CR to
develop your plan
and your strategic command yes correct
okay and what you did was
you looked at the information that was
available to you project Hendon yes yes
and you spoke to your colleague
superintendent
Morris
yeah Morris I was part of conversations
where he would uh inform us of most
current intelligence what was occurring
yes yep just stop after you got the
assignment forgetting that you get the
hand in reports I get that you you
received them all yeah yeah but after
the 24th before you deployed you spoke
to him
and got a briefing from him right it
sounds accurate pardon me I'm assuming I
did yeah sure I've got let's let's help
you with the notes OPP
50774 please you've looked at these
before you came today I assume
my notes did you look at your notes I've
looked at my notes many times yes no I
know but before you came here did you
look at these yes okay good so it's I I
don't want to test your memory but let's
let's look this is Monday you're working
from home at that time do you see yes
and
um
909 48 email to intersect you told us
about that
discuss the Convoy issues impact in all
of our areas uh 1305 tovel I think
that's one of your colleagues doing a
traffic plan for the Convoy arrival
speaking to Ops traffic
1554 intersect email that's you sending
them
Convoy 28 29 January everybody thought
this was a two-day protest correct
yes I'm just when I look at the dates
I'm I'm I think the dates are indicative
of arrival dates as opposed to event
dates okay well let's carry on uh they
were going to get through on prior in
the 28th three convoys above that 29th
of January into Ottawa
we'll slow track this is OPP's plan we
will slow traffic but not block
the intention is to hold a peaceful
demonstration with no hostility
forward to Chief Thomas Specter tovel
and Semple that's your that's your team
right and just uh context
I'm not saying that the opp will slow
down traffic the Convoy organizers have
stated that they will slow traffic but
not block it I understood thank you for
that
and what you were going to do that to
get to this is the traffic plan was to
effectively escort the Convoy to Ottawa
um we didn't want to do any escorting so
there was no OPP Vehicles necessarily
you know in front and back and follow us
it was more monitoring okay so you had
Cruisers did were the crews did the
Cruisers have their their overhead roof
lights on or not
I can't be 100 uh whether they did or
not we would not put emergency lights
activated or not that deep into an
operational plan that would be left to
the officer's discussion how do you feel
they need to do it on the side of the
road so sometimes if protesters
sympathetic were on the side of the
highway supporting the convoys that went
by you might have had a cruiser might
have had to use their emergency lights
in that situation for example
but you had Cruisers in and around
the Convoy as it from the time it
crossed the Manitoba border until you
handed them off to Ottawa correct
correct how many Cruisers
I I can't articulate a number be more
than I mean what from your experience
we've got to train down many kilometers
do you imagine that it is 10 units
yes I'm trying to uh 20 units
trying to recall the operational plan if
it listed the traffic units but
um I would say at least 15 to 20 units
would be a fair okay number yes and then
just carry on 1622 Chief Thomas email
that's your Chief superintendent correct
um
MC
something possible possibly to come over
possibly to come over possibly Aviation
consulted that's your Aviation team yeah
and then it says uh poib is of course
the intelligence Bureau Pat
you spoke with him
no I didn't speak to him that day I just
I knew that his role and what he was
doing was he was engaging with police
Partners outside of Ontario so that we
could have a picture of what was coming
across Canada from from west to east got
it and then finally at 1622 you note
that but in in that conversation or
rather email with your superintendent
your Chief superintendent you were asked
to be the Strategic superintendent for
the event and you went into action
therefore effectively the next day the
20
really into action the next day the 25th
correct correct two days effectively two
days
uh before the what we understand to be
the
you know the arrival of the some of the
first vehicles in Ottawa can I show you
or can I ask you to confirm that what
you then did was you got your colleagues
your team reporting to you to do a
traffic plan an operations plan for this
event right operational plan yes and
that operational plan we have it but
that operational plan
effectively had OPP monitoring the
Convoy through Ontario until there was a
handoff
into Ottawa correct yes many other
regions had similar plans and they were
tracking the movements in a similar
fashion right and so we had to create
our plan obviously just for our
geographic area right east region and
the and the uh there you had a you then
set up some of your own people in your
operations center in Ottawa correct
um it was in our Operation Center I I
put inspector Ferguson in the ncrcc and
staff sergeant Nicholas between kind of
a traffic building that Ops had in the
ncrcc and I had my Emergency Operations
Center at our east region headquarters
in Smith Falls and where were you
located during that time weekend the
weekend of the Convoy were you in
Smith's Falls I was in Smith's Falls
okay good and you had a couple of people
you've described on the ground here in
different places
and
did you have in Smith's Falls
any other people
with you as part of your team managing
the event
I had signed an Incident Commander Scott
Semple okay in Smith's Falls yes okay
got it Smith Falls for Ottawa help us
with the geography
um Southwest
um 40 minutes okay got it and
and then you had am I correct you did
not have
uh resources logistical resources or any
other kind of resources for an event
that was going to be longer than a
weekend protest correct that is correct
and the reason that you didn't is
because your
review of the intelligence available and
the information available to you at OPP
pointed to a two-day protest they come
they protest they leave right I wouldn't
agree with that I I would I would say
that my plan was based on my
conversations through intersect calls
with Ottawa Police who indicated
they they were planning for that level
of event therefore so was I okay well so
we the one thing we don't do or do we
is defer to another Police Service when
we make our own plans at the opp
that's an input but you did not you're
not telling the commissioner that you
didn't plan
for an extended protracted three-week
event in Ottawa because the Ottawa
Police Service didn't correct certainly
not because okay as we saw and as I
explained in my evidence before is we
expected a traffic event that was going
to end downtown in the city of Ottawa so
we did not plan based on intelligence
based on Hendon based on any other
information source that we expected
vehicles or protesters to clog up
provincial highways which we were
responsible for or
um for communities
for more than an evening and we expected
them to be lawful in that one evening so
all of those parts indicated for the
OPP's perspective a very quick event
um essentially a one day trip from
different areas of the city into the
downtown core and that would end the
OPP's involvement in the movement of
those Vehicles yeah and the opp plan we
can look at it if you need it the opp
plan describes
in language the handoff you were going
to hand off after they were finished
traveling over the provincial highways
into the city of Ottawa correct correct
your expectation was that as many as 3
000 Vehicles were going to be in the
city of Ottawa and you were quite
content with what you saw from Ops was
their plan to allow the Convoy operators
to protest correct
the numbers were uncertain
Ottawa Police indicated that they
thought they could handle three thousand
and in other reports as we've seen
didn't specifically exactly say x number
of vehicles but
um I was satisfied based on my calls
with Ottawa Police that they felt they
could handle that number of views yes
and you knew it wasn't 3 000 once they
got there but you knew that indicators
were just the vehicles that crossed from
the West that was in the 800 range and
they may pick up some as they moved got
it but and so you were content
hmm to hand off to Ottawa in the
expectation that the team that you had
put together
as the Strategic operations lead here
would allow you to manage that Convoy as
they left Ottawa as well correct
there was no we didn't know what the
exit plan was so we always had to be
ready and available to write what that
Exit Plan was so that was an unknown to
us as to with the exit on mass with the
exit slowly
that that was uncertain but in
addressing the that uncertainty you were
content that the team that you had in
place was appropriate correct that we
felt we could manage
um because a mass entry there's not much
different than the mass exit and so
therefore right and and therefore you
did not plan you didn't bring any
additional resources for anything longer
than the weekend protest that you
thought was was going to be on correct
correct because as you know in my notes
once it looked like it was going to be
prolonged I had had to have meetings
with my command team to say let's plan
for an extended event 29th of January I
believe
maybe a little later is the first time
that you began to assemble resources for
a different event correct correct and
the Ottawa Police Service
was in the very same position that you
were in correct
position and as in not planned for an
extended event yes it seemed to be
certainly in my conversations with uh
Deputy Bell on the 31st I believe it was
was the first time that he indicated
that he felt this was going to be a
protracted event and they were planning
for what could be a four-week event and
they made a they made a shift
in their planning and operations just
like you did correct
yeah they sent this for sure and you
what you did in advance was send a
public order unit to Ottawa in advance
this was part of your planning
but you sent them to the pr to the PPS
parliamentary Protective Service correct
yes so I can explain the instructions I
don't I don't I mean if you need to make
an explanation go ahead but I just need
to explain because it wasn't my
Direction that's why I need to explain
okay I do not direct those resources I
just a commander
um I did not direct public order unit
um operations I did not direct where
they went they reported to me to tell me
what they were doing but that happened
through our field support Bureau so in
your question I did not direct that fair
enough thank you for that clarification
OPP sent a public order unit but they
didn't send them to the Ops they sent
him to the PPS correct that is that's
correct okay and then you
you set out the calls for resources you
needed to make a new plan and you began
to get resources in the form of
additional personnel correct yes how
many additional personnel
at the very beginning
um I we reached out to say look we have
18 members right now that we could pull
from local detachments and it started
from there and it continued every day it
continued to rise from there it was
obvious to you as a as a person with
experience in this area that the Ottawa
Police Service would not be able with
the its existing resources to manage
this event correct once it changed its
complexion right I didn't know that
until I heard that directly from their
own deputy chief I made assumptions that
I felt that they had come up with a plan
to address many different options that
may have occurred so that so the plot
we'll talk about plans but but just
talking about Personnel you knew from
your experience with intersect
the size of the Ottawa Police Service
did not allow it to manage the event
that this had become correct yes and I
learned that through those calls yes but
you do but did you need to be told that
if if so that's fine or did you know it
from your own experience that they were
overwhelmed
by in numbers
I I had to be told that because I
couldn't assume I knew they have they
have I believe it's 1200 or 1400 they
have many members and at that early
stage it was hard to know whether that
many members could contain what was
happening in those first day or two or
not okay I'm glad to hear that from them
because I wasn't on the ground and so
that's fair so then you needed to be
told that by them and they told you that
yes and what they asked for was help
correct correct they've they asked you
for help as early as what do you say the
31st
um I'd have to check my notes but it was
on a Saturday or Sunday yes okay got it
and when they said they wanted help
they told you they needed help in
particular areas right correct very
specific areas correct correct and am I
correct that you were unable at that
time to give them all the help that they
wanted
I don't recall that when I talked to
Deputy bellies he said his immediate
need was for traffic control
um he needed officers to be able to
relieve his officers downtown uh doing
traffic so we were able to provide those
bodies that we started with uh 30 a day
and I was able to provide those bodies
within my own region in short order I
never there was never a delay it was not
adequate correct
he needed more after that because he
indicated that he would probably come to
60 when the formal letter would come
from Chief slowly the commissioner
karique
deputy chief Bell indicated to me that
he felt it would probably be around the
60 number that they would be asking from
the opp from Front Line and then there
would be public order section requests
and PLT requests as well am I right
though that you were not able to give
them the resources they needed when they
needed them correct I believe I was able
to give them one of the music okay so
what did you do to get resources were
you confined to moving resources within
the east region or did you put in a call
to your
superiors or the other parts of your
command to get additional resources
question in the early days I was able to
contain it within my own region I
believe on my other evidence I described
we have a regional deployment plan for
emergencies such as this we know how
many officers are at each of our 16
detachments we know who's working each
day and in an emergency we know how many
officers we can ask to leave that area
to attend whatever the emergency happens
to be so I relied on that emergency
Regional deployment plan to gather those
resources of 30 a day to assist Ottawa
once
a you know a couple days goes by and I'm
aware that there's going to be an
increase ask of 60. then yes I need to
call our emergency or operations center
which is based at Aurelia at our General
headquarters which falls under our field
support Bureau to then gather provincial
resources to assist because yes
regionally I wouldn't be able to when
did you first when did you first put in
a call to the emergency Resource Center
once again I'd have to refer to my notes
but within probably three days to four
days of the 30 a day when it was clear
when the letter came in from Chief
slowly asking for 60 I had to make the
phone call to our EOC to say okay I need
your help to get the resources to come
to east region and am I correct that you
came to the conclusion that 60 a day was
not enough
I could only rely on what uh Ottawa
Police said they needed from me you were
told 60 a day was not enough that they
needed many more correct as other days
went on that would be communicated to me
say can you give us more and we would be
able to tell them yeah we we can
probably give you this money more or
this many more and on the on the
um you told us about the first let me go
back you had never been through anything
like this before correct
not to this scale but right yeah correct
you've never seen an urban occupation a
protest that that had become an
occupation correct
as it was explained to me this was the
largest unplanned deployment of Opp
resources in our history right got it so
therefore in your history you told us
that you'd been to some other been
through some other
um uh blockade situations but they have
not involved the urban environment like
this and and obviously the sheer scale
of this one was beyond anything you had
experience right not in my experience
and so when we talk about resources you
were participated in a call you told us
on the 6th of February Chief slowly uh
requested his team to make an estimate
of the resources they needed right yes I
recall that was a video call yes yes and
you told us that you thought that that
it was unusual that he told his team to
double the number if they thought they
needed 100 to double it to 200 you made
that comment correct yes it seemed odd
to me yes yes it didn't seem odd enough
to load of record in your notes
right and and I I address this in my
will state is because
um in the meeting they were discussing
Ottawa Police business I didn't feel it
was appropriate for me to make notes on
Ottawa Police Operations so I purposely
did not make you made a lot of notes
superintendent about Ottawa Police
you've made notes about rumors and
innuendo and what people told you some
other guy said all kinds of times
haven't you
I have in that
in that situation I purposely chose not
to take notes because it seemed
inappropriate for me because they were
talking about internal Ottawa Police
operation matters that I didn't my
purpose to be on a call was to talk
about PLT okay so so you didn't so can I
put it this way
that whatever Chief slowly said that you
didn't record in your notes
you didn't think it was important enough
to imagine that the that the number that
they came back with
1800 when they came back 24 hours later
with a number
that there was some lack of validity or
Integrity to that number
did you
I questioned
um where the number could have come from
in that short period of time you didn't
yeah and did you tell Chief slowly or
anyone that you weren't going to take
action in respect of their requests for
resources because you had
heard him make a comment to his team
that you didn't record in your notes but
that you were going to use
to deny them resources that they wanted
I never communicate with you solely on
that and I never would deny resources I
communicated that to my command as we
spoke about in my testimony to the
commissioner to say this is what I'd
heard while you're trying to address
operational requests from the Ottawa
Police Service I thought it was
important for him and the Deputy
Commissioner to know that this statement
was made yesterday so what did you think
that was going to do superintendent did
you think that was going to get them the
help they needed or did you think that
was going to cause people to believe
that there was no actual number that
they needed that had any validity what
did you think you were doing with that
what I was doing was protecting the
members of the opp and that and what
were what were you good to let him
finish I'm sorry go ahead superintendent
how are you protecting the members of
the opp
because of a large request like that it
was important for me to communicate to
my senior command that they perhaps
they're not truly needed based on what I
heard when B since we have no
operational plan yet
to send that number of officers into a
situation with no real plan on what to
do with them was a concern so that's why
I felt it was important to communicate
to my commandable time do you agree with
me that it had the effect of causing
your people
and everybody else to think that what
Chief slowly was asking for to help the
citizens of this city
and to help the government of Canada and
to help his own Police Service
did you think you were helping him or
them
I think it was helping
um everybody have the proper knowledge
before they made decisions to deploy
resources
sure and so of course we now know don't
we that that the 1800 estimate that his
team put together was exactly right
maybe it was a little under actually you
know that don't you yes we've heard
those numbers here yeah so it wasn't a
rabbit pulled from a hat
and it wasn't in a bunch of numbers that
were just randomly doubled was it
it seemed to me as a number pulled from
a hat in that short period of time do
you accept now that it wasn't a number
pulled from a hat that his team worked
very hard to actually get the number
that they needed do you accept that now
no because there was no plan okay and
that's of course what you passed on
again I'm sorry
please let them finish thank you you're
over your time and I'm being generous
thank you so important to be fair to the
witness of course superintendent go
ahead
from my experience as we've talked about
we build a plan first and then we add
numbers to it after
the fact that the numbers fit the
integrated buying teams plan
I don't know that that connects to the
work that his team did within those 24.
did you look at it
the integrated plan no did you look at
the numbers that were on the table that
his team put together
on February 9th when I attended the
meeting downtown with the integrated
planning team that's the first time I
was presented with the three-page
document that showed the numbers that
they were requesting so before you even
looked at it
you made the statement that it was that
it was an overestimate and that it was
not a valid number you didn't even look
at it I never indicated in any of my
communications I felt it was an
overestimate I just wanted our senior
command to know that when Ottawa Police
were trying to determine how many people
they needed this is a direction that
their Chief gave them that's all I I did
not opine on whether I felt it was
adequate or inadequate I never said you
cast doubt on it didn't you
I only said that there was suspicious
that how they could come up with a
number like that and certainly the
suggestion that that never would be
doubled fine and then you pass that on
to the minister
you passed on you passed on an incorrect
number to the minister didn't you I did
not do that no the minister the
solicitor general
did you see The Minister's statement
we're talking about two separate and um
events here sir okay let's move to the
second one then if you want to think
it's the second event did you pass on
the number to the minister
please let's you get to ask questions
don't turn things around please be fair
to this Witness
so the video call when I met with Chief
souley and he talked about having his
team go away that date was February
after it helped me counselor on the date
that video call happened
you just mentioned the date did it or
called it I I I I so I had I had I had
moved on to the statement that the
minister made I'm happy to go back if
you want so February 2nd
I received an email requesting uh we
have in the opp
um our representative uh within uh
um the uh
government buildings in Toronto and
there are liaison between government and
the opp and I received an email from
that unit uh saying that Cisco General
wanted a number of Opp members who have
been in Ottawa since the beginning of
the event
so I asked my team to create a chart
which indicated the numbers from the
beginning of the event until the 2nd of
February and I describe what that chart
looked like yesterday and include
numbers of logistical people EOC numbers
uh Frontline members uh public order
unit members and I emailed that to my
chief superintendent and since we're a
paramilitary organization you follow the
chain of command and then I assume from
that point on those numbers that I
obtained or moved up to this to higher
levels
and the minister on that basis issued a
statement to the public and in the house
in the legislature correct
I became aware of that later I wasn't
aware of that at the time and it was
erroneous
I can't I can't say that
um well there weren't 1500 OPP officers
here were there
in a day the chief slowly and his
concerns to me that when we had our
meeting was he felt that that media
release indicated there was 1500 OPP
officers in his streets in his town that
day yes and that impacted you know now
know this it impacted what the RCMP
considered the
Ottawa Police Service needed it impacted
the way the public in Ottawa thought
that the Ops was handling the matter it
impacted the council and all of the
other things didn't it as I stated to
Chief slowly I presented the daily
numbers with a roll-up of the total
numbers
how those numbers were used or
controlled after that was was beyond my
control
yes and did you tell did what steps did
you take to tell the solicitor general
that the information upon which she was
relying was had been misunderstood
misinterpreted
and he said it was it was not within my
preview to reach out to the social
Channel
your commanding officer
that had happened
no I did not but that meeting was the
first time uh two quick things the
bridge
have you seen Chief slowly's news
conference on February the 4th that you
told the commission about yesterday
I only saw the live portion when I was
sitting in the command post and I saw
him in Deputy Bell uh doing the news so
you're relying on your memory from
February 4th
yes I recall hearing that and then
reacting immediately because it
connected with the deputy immediately
well I don't have the time to play it
for you but he never said that he was
going to close Bridges
what he said in his news conference was
that consideration was being given to
that and that Bridges or accesses access
would be closed if needed or as needed
didn't say he was closing Bridges did he
that's what I heard and so that would
naturally purchase uh precipitate a call
to confirm what I heard maybe I misheard
that's why I needed to reach out to
Deputy Bell to say did I hear this
correctly and you were to understand I'm
sorry to interrupt you and you were told
by Deputy Bell that you you had Miss
heard it that there were no Bridges
being closed right
yeah my concern was more about the
off-ramps the bridges were within the
city of Ottawa so I wasn't concerned
about the bridges my main concern was
about what I heard about off wraps same
same thing though Deputy Bill said the
same thing for me as far as my concern
and my operations because my operations
didn't concern Bridges he gave you the
same answer you you have misunderstood
it no one's closing a bridge no one's
closing an off-ramp relax I heard it
very clearly that there was a plan to
close off ramps and that's what
precipitated my call to Deputy Bill
quick thing about the PLT this PLT team
unfortunately never had any success in
negotiating the departure of Convoy
participants or protesters correct
I would disagree with that I felt that
at the end much of their work allowed
some of the Convoy protesters to leave
voluntarily so prior to the I should
have been clearer thank you prior to the
public order operation going into effect
to clear these streets
PLT had not succeeded in negotiating an
end to this protest had they well
certainly the protest was still ongoing
when public order had to do what they
did yes and so the Coventry Road
issue what PLT had negotiated am I
correct was that protesters could take
their fuel from Coventry Road and place
it in a different Depot
I wasn't aware of the particulars of
that because PLT didn't report to me
what I was engaged in was solely on the
deconfliction end of it to say that this
happened this community this
communication happened within the Iowa
Police Service and could you help us as
my friend Mr van dienheis asked the fuel
in Coventry Road whether it's in
Coventry Road or it's somewhere else was
a significant public safety risk correct
yes and if PLT negotiated that they're
going to move the fuel from Coventry
Road to a different Depot you could
appreciate why
Ottawa Police Service would be very
concerned
because I can't speak to what the idea
was or what the plan was because so you
would not you're not telling the
commissioner that you're second guessing
the operational decision to to seize
fuel if that was a public safety risk
correct yeah correct because our teams
were uh intended to integrate and they
didn't report to me thank you and then
uh Windsor
um the information that was available to
OPP did not uh was not sufficient to
allow it to avoid the blockade at
Windsor
I was not involved in any of the Windsor
I would not have any information on when
there are our plans and resources have
to be allocated among the opp
detachments across the province so that
when we saw the note from your colleague
in Windsor about whether Windsor was a
priority over Ottawa that's a decision
that has to be made at the level of the
of of of of Opp resource allocation
correct right in a province size
material there's various priorities that
have to be decided on how we staff them
and the and the uh as to the emergencies
Act
the opp PLT
notes to protesters included and relied
upon terms under the emergencies act
right I believe that's what we we saw
Yes understood thank you commissioner
okay thank you next uh I'd like to call
on the city of Ottawa
[Music]
foreign
superintendent my name is Anne tardief I
represent the city of Ottawa good
morning
so um I'd like to take you first to your
notes I know you have them in front of
you and and I'll give you the date but
I'm going to give the number so that
everyone else can follow along it's
opp50774
and I'm going to go to the date at
February 3rd superintendent and it's
page 19 of that document Madam Clerk
you see the date there at the top of the
page yes third of February yes correct
and I'd like to go to the before last
entry on that page Madam clerk so just
scrolling down a little bit
perfect so do you see the entry there
superintendent I think it's 1752 it
could be 1952. I'm not sure the time
matters but do you see that entry I do
okay and it says uh superintendent
alakis FSB
um uh in that note and it's it's
actually the last
sentence I suppose it is of that entry
that I want to draw your attention to it
says no real plan for them and no
meaningful dialogue with truckers
occurring so first is this something
that you're reporting to superintendent
Alaska or is he reporting it to you
and I'll correct you quickly
um my grade for uh teacher would still
not be happy with me my penmanship is
not the best this is no real plan
forthcoming forthcoming okay it's the
second that I want to talk about the no
meaningful dialogue with truckers
occurring do you see that yes it's
coming from superintendent alakis okay
and this is with respect to the Ottawa
situation correct so by February 3rd we
don't have any meaningful dialogue with
truckers occurring and
um you described the events of February
6 yesterday and again this morning
correct
yes uh PLT went into commentary to
negotiate the removal of gasoline yes
and superintendent Patterson used the
opportunity to seize the fuel and charge
some of the protesters is that correct
correct and pltl felt they had lost all
the Goodwill they were able to reach
with some of the Convoy organizers
that's what was communicated to me yes
okay
and were you aware that two days later
on February 8th Ottawa Police asked the
city manager city of Ottawa manager to
meet with protesters I was not aware of
that and we've heard that police felt
they didn't have anything to lose by
facilitating a meeting and it would be a
win to gain trust with truckers they
could use it as a bargaining to to move
trucks were you aware of that at the
time I was not aware of that no
we've heard as well that the city
negotiated an agreement to remove trucks
from the residential neighborhoods and
the dates that followed were you aware
of that at the time
not at the time I can indicate that I
received messaging from our PLT members
to indicate that they were frustrated by
the involvement of Municipal leaders and
how was it impacting their work but I
was not aware of the exact times these
were occurring well and I guess that's
what I'm getting at superintendent
because that's reflected in your witness
summary which has been filed into
evidence and so at the time that you
received those concerns from your PLT
officers I take it you would not aware
that the city had spoken with protesters
at the request of police right outside
of what may have been reported in in
public media I wasn't aware what was
happening okay and you were not aware
that a senior Ops officer had been at
the table to negotiate the logistics of
how and where the trucks would move yeah
I would not have been involved in that
or aware of that and just given in your
reference it already but in your witness
summary you indicate that your PLT
officers were frustrated because they
were hearing from protesters that they
had met with the mayor and that they
wanted to continue to meet with the
mayor that's that's what you were
hearing on the 15th of February that's
correct and the evidence this commission
has heard is that the protesters in fact
never met with mayor Watson I take it
you're aware of that now no right now
I'm aware yes okay I want to switch
tracks a little bit
um and and talk about uh superintendent
early's notes now she um it's Dana I'm
assuming Dana early is a she is that
fair that's correct just want to check
thank you and so uh superintendent early
was in Windsor during the Ambassador
Bridge blockade she was she was
essentially performing my role but in
Windsor fair enough and so I take it
that if you did have a conversation with
her it's going to be about resources I
mean that's really the only reason for
you to speak to superintendent early
during the events of February 2022. fair
fair okay
um now when you were asked yesterday
initially you did not believe that you
had spoken to superintendent early at
that time you recall saying that yeah I
didn't have any independent recollection
of that conversation no fair enough into
and and to be fair to you we've seen
that there's no mention of it in your
notes except for the words Dana Dana
early slash uh on February 10th correct
correct and you were then taken to
superintendy's superintendent early's
notes of that call and I will ask that
they be put up on the screen it is
OPP four zeros four five four three
thank you madam Clerk and can we go to
page fifteen one five
okay so this um just to be fair to the
witness oh actually the date's on it
perfect you see at the top there 10th of
February 2022 can you see that
superintendent to do yeah okay so just
before we get into this
um you described it at some length
um in your testimony uh a meeting that
occurred with the planning team and with
the leadership of Ops at Ops
headquarters on Elgin Street and I
believe that was on February 9th is that
correct that's correct okay 12 10 I
believe pardon me I believe it started
at 12 10. okay we've got the same
meeting in mind so that's the day before
February 10th obviously okay so you
explained during that meeting I'm not
going to take you back through all of it
you've explained it in some detail it's
in your witness summary which has now
been filed but it at some point as I
understand it's superintendent Phil Liu
of the RCMP tells then Chief slowly to
pump the brakes on the enforcement plan
is that fair it's fair and he says that
he thinks he can get 400 Pou officers to
Ottawa in a week's time
um and sorry incorrect I believe it was
uh Staff Sergeant or Sergeant Darwin
Tetro was saying that pardon me not to
Phil Lou the statement is what you as
you claim but I believe it was made by
Darwin Tetro not Philip and his staff
Tartan Tetro also with the RCMP he is
and he has a public order component in
his work perfect so we've got an rpmp
officer advising that they think they
can get 400 Pou officers in Ottawa in
about a week's time right that's correct
so if we're at February 9th that means
they think they can get their 400 Pou
officers in Ottawa on or about February
16th Fair
it's fair okay
and I think we've heard at length that a
number greater than that was actually
needed in order to bring the Convoy to
an end right well certainly and I
believe
um staff sergeant Tetra believed that as
well he just indicated let's start there
and then we'll work with our public
order Partners across the country so try
to gather more fair enough so the 400
was a start yes
down here till 10 21 that's the first
indication of the call do you see that
call
I can't know I can't tell if that's two
or from it looks like from not much
turns about not much turns on it Craig
Abrams two confirm resources and that's
consistent what you've told us any call
with uh superintendent early really
would have been to focus on resources
right yes and then Ottawa has been
sending resource sheets
is that sheets sheets two EOC that's the
Emergency Operations Center of the opp
based in Aurelia we use that term a lot
so every region has an Emergency
Operations Center so in this case she's
talking about Aurelia because we were
both using Aurelia to help facilitate
Logistics to obtain resources for both
our operations that's right so you've
gotten exactly where I wanted to get at
this is the same place that you both are
writing to to get resources right
correct okay and then 10 23 and actually
before I get here I think I heard you
say that you believe that superintendent
early had a scribe is that right yes I
yes I thought I would assume she did but
okay and so you believe that these are
notes taken by her scribe and that I
have no confirmation of that okay
assuming it was but I could be mistaken
okay that's fine so at 10 23 advised
Abrams Windsor is priority according to
Deputy do you see that I do and the next
line refers to a gentleman named hargens
is that Harkins pardon me is that Deputy
Commissioner Harkins
yes and he's in charge of the field
services Bureau do I have that right
he's definitely turn to field operations
field operations okay and um so as I'm
reading this the the deputy Harkins
advised uh that Windsor is priority am I
is that the way to read this
um that's what that's that's what that
says
um and Harkins Deputy Harkins told me
being superintendent early to go through
the EOC and you advise that that's what
was happening at that time right yes so
you're both going through the same
Emergency Operations Center to request
resources for your operations correct
we'll have much better idea of numbers
this afternoon after meeting with Pou
commanders and then at 10 24
sorry 10 26 I'm just jumping over the
1024 you can see it there as
superintendent Abrams will call EOC to
confirm Staffing process you are
priority we will take leftovers
do you accept that you made that
statement superintendent Abrams either
that or something to that effect
no I don't I don't recall making that
statement
you don't recall no do you recall any
discussion that Windsor was the priority
for resources to be obtained out of the
EOC at that time no I don't recall
because on that day literally that day
the 10th
um I spoke with a chief party and we
made resource requests and an extra 120
officers were coming to Ottawa uh by the
Monday
so that's why I'm confused by the the uh
just the talk about resource allocations
because I asked and we required another
120 and it was approved and it just
obviously to get people across the
province into Ottawa was going to take
us a couple of days we plan to have an
extra 120 officers in Ottawa by that
Monday okay and at 10 26 again that is
the second 10 26th Abram advised Winder
will need to tell you what you need so
we've got three statements between 10 21
and 10 26
um suggesting that you were made advised
here that Windsor was the priority but
you deny that
I I was never told that so I'm not
denying that statement was was made but
when
um we had discussions she told me that
the deputy told her that Windsor was a
priority so I'm saying okay if you're
telling me that the deputy told you
Windsor is the priority then okay
um but that information from what I'm
seeing is
um the deputy Deputy Harkins I'm
assuming was telling her I didn't tell
her that so we may just be lost in in
languages mountains when I said you were
never told I I was meaning to say bye
superintendent early do you accept that
you were told by superintendent Hurley
early part of me that her understanding
was that Windsor was the priority I'm
not asking you what you were told by
Deputy Harper right I accept based on
the notes I don't have an independent
reaction of her that's fine but you
accept it based on the notes thank you
if we could keep strolling down
okay
so I'm looking at the second 1028 note
um and and you were taken to this In
fairness to to you superintendent
yesterday do you see Ottawa is Just
Trucks on side streets you see that note
there yes and I think you said yesterday
that you also did not have an
independent recollection of this call
correct I really don't I'm trying but so
many calls are for so many weeks I can't
say that I ever call this uh one
specifically but you explained what you
may have meant yesterday you said that
it was easy to drive around if you were
south of Wellington I.E outside of the
the Red Zone I think he said south of
the 401.
417 commissioner oh pardon me did you
say south of the 417 my apologies no
that's fine I had south of that's south
of the 417. yes it would have you know
based on what I'm reading and and trying
to recall we would have had General
conversations about what she was dealing
with and what I was dealing with and
what it looked like in in her area and
what it looked like in my area and we
would have had conversations about the
impacts to the city of Windsor overall
because of the location of Ambassador
Bridge and those types of things so I
believe that's the context of where this
comes from so if I understand it
correctly it was that if you were
outside of the sort of impacted downtown
core you could drive around the city you
could navigate the city outside the
downtown core that was blocked is that
fair that was your my personal
experience and the times I had to be
able to do that drive I'm sure there
were days due to traffic backups that
there was difficulty in some areas of
the city I'm just stating in general
terms for my own experience I didn't see
a massive impact outside of that core
area
traffic wise
okay and you were aware I take it at the
time that some of the bridges between
Quebec or between Gatineau and Ottawa uh
were closed or subject to Lane
reductions
Lane reductions for sure full closures I
believe they were kind of rotating
depending on days because I recall there
was impacts with nursing staff that
we're trying to get from Gatineau to the
hospitals in Ottawa so there had to be
some
give and take to open up some Lanes so
people could get to work that's right so
we had health professionals having
difficulty accessing their place of work
correct that's what I recall and you
recall also I take it that we had
patients having difficulty accessing
their appointments
I don't I only recall that um some
leaders of the hospitals that indicated
that their staff weren't able to get to
work on time which had obviously
operational impacts for their agencies
and there was a request
not controlled by the OPP bit of a
request whoever was controlling the
bridges on either side that they can
make some accommodations for that
in those side streets that the the
trucks were parked on in Ottawa because
as you say they weren't they weren't
parked on a bridge or on the 417 they
were parked on side streets those side
streets you knew were in residential
neighborhoods
um there may have been apartment
buildings on them as
I'm when you say residential IP I'm
picturing Suburban uh but there may be
Urban Apartments that were on those side
streets certainly yeah and so the tracks
were parked at the front door of some of
these apartment and condo buildings I'm
sure they were yes they were idling and
honking
there was lots of honking yes
and we've heard complaints of Resident
harassment in these neighborhoods as
well you heard I take it acting deputy
chief Ferguson saying that they receive
complaints about that I heard it
personally myself in my own visits to to
store owner so if you told me directly
and I appreciate you weren't in Windsor
but my understanding is that there were
roughly about a hundred trucks involved
in the Windsor blockade is that accurate
I I can comment I wasn't involved and I
don't recall you're well over your time
uh so you're gonna have to wrap up
that's fine
um
um do you can you just confirm that the
blog I mean I don't think it's
contentious but that the blockade in
Windsor was significantly smaller than
in Ottawa in terms of number of trucks
it was smaller in number of trucks
certainly yes and I just want to confirm
last Point commissioner under the not
affecting livelihoods I won't go into
details you've explained yesterday that
you were aware that businesses were
affected in Ottawa and I thank you for
that but I think I heard you saying to
respond to my French questions earlier
this morning that you and superintendent
early may have discussed in fact the
economic impact of the Windsor blockade
in particular with respect to
International Trade is that fair I think
we talked about what her blockade was
doing in relation to mine similar to you
know really into my experiences to the
to the rail blockades in titanaga and
the economic impacts railball Kate had
it was very similar in circumstance more
significant than in Ottawa economically
yeah thank you very much superintendent
thank you commissioner for your
Indulgence
okay next is the Ottawa coalition
uh good morning superintendent Abrams
thank you so much for coming to Ottawa
and
answering these questions for all of us
here my name is Paul champ I'm legal
counsel for the Ottawa Coalition of
residents and businesses from downtown
Ottawa and I just have some questions
for you
um superintendent Abrams uh were you
aware did you know about how many uh
residents uh roughly lived in the Red
Zone in downtown Ottawa would not wear
it all no so if I said 15 000
approximately would that that that would
be the first time I heard that number
but based on the time I've spent
downtown and the number of buildings
I've seen it it certainly seems like an
accurate number and so when you were
making decisions or being involved in
the operations the police operations not
a while you you were aware we were
talking about thousands of people who
are being impacted by these Convoy
protests in downtown Ottawa
um certainly and when it came to that I
mean I
um how many people were required are the
impacts I had to rely on my partners at
the Alabama Police Service to indicate
to me what was happening down there what
impacts were happening and what they
needed to address those impacts and uh
you and aware there is there were a
large number of businesses in downtown
Ottawa that were shut down completely
cracked sure I saw them myself
personally as I said in my own visits to
business owners and saw many businesses
were closed and and obviously not only
those business owners experiencing those
losses there had been uh countless
workers who were out of jobs during that
period of time as well you would have
known that certainly I I I live an hour
from the city I have family and friends
who were directly impacted and talked
about having to relocate because of the
honking because of the noise so yes I
was aware right and and on with respect
to the conditions on the streets you're
aware of the obviously the large number
of semi-trucks in some cases right
outside of people's doors honking and so
forth but we also had other conditions
downtown like the the large stacks of
wood the large number of propane tanks
often together the the Jerry cans of
diesel fuel uh the open fires at almost
every other intersection the the
fireworks that were going on at night
you're aware of all those conditions
correct yes
and
um we heard evidence last week
superintendent Abrams about residents
being fearful that uh the their building
perhaps could catch on fire there could
be an explosion uh from this the
dangerous propane and so forth it's
around you agree that that was a
reasonable fear
uh certainly I believe there was an
actual arson type incident not linked to
um the Convoy I guess specifically but
we saw that it clearly could be uh
something that could happen so yeah it
was a valid concern of the residents for
sure and and it was your view that the
police well it was the case was it not
superintendent Abrams that the police
were unable to effectively control or
prevent these inflammatory and explosive
materials for being regularly
transported on a daily basis to the
downtown core correct it certainly uh
was a challenge to prevent the flow of
gasoline well it wasn't a child it
couldn't be done they weren't they
couldn't do it maybe it could have been
done but they weren't stopping it
correct
um I know my officers made attempts at
times but at times they get swarmed by
other members so they'd have to to pull
back so there was attempts made at
certain times to do so but it was a
difficult yeah for sure I'm not saying
that it was they couldn't do it like
effectively they couldn't do it given
the number that were on the ground
police at the time correct it was yeah
it was difficult
well it was it wasn't possible I
wouldn't say it was impossible I
remember his tribe
um and I believe some gas was it was
seized I I can't be for certain about my
membership
um because
um I told my members because my members
were normally in uh two-person units so
it was a highly dangerous to their
safety to try to get involved with
multiple people carrying Jerry cans when
there's just two of them absolutely so
from an opp perspective I can say that
yeah we did not engage in trying to
interdict gasoline simply because we
were outnumbered with our numbers as
they were
and yeah and that's a very good point uh
that you just made their superintendent
Abrams it wasn't simply downtown
residence and business or rescue is
there was dangers to to your officers
downtown because of the circumstances or
conditions correct well certainly my
officers were subjected not only to
threats of physical assault but yelling
I had to get my public order unit teams
um hearing protection because it was
starting to damage their hearing yeah
because they spent so much time downtown
yeah the horns and the diesel fumes no
doubt you were hearing complaints about
that from your officers
um corns yes diesel fumes I can't say
that I heard
and um now we've heard you say uh
superintendent Abrams that on January
29th
uh it was your view in the view of the
AP OPP that the auto Police Service did
not have the capability to bring an end
to this
uh this incident or this event is that
fair to say I have to look at my notes
in that that would have been the day
that I had the conversation with
inspector Ferguson right exactly so I
mean it was clear that they were that
particular day were dysfunctional and
unable to make a plan I don't believe I
would make an opinion that just because
of what she was experiencing or seeing
in that day meant that there was no way
the Ottawa Police Service could resolve
this event eventually
it was just a
an observation that day that there was
no plan and there were dysfunctional
that day but but to be clear
superintendent Abrams even if the Otto
police had a great plan and we've heard
all the evidence about the struggles of
coming up with a plan that was
acceptable to the opp but even if they
had a plan it was very clear to you the
Ottawa Police Services simply did not
have the resources on the ground to
bring that incident to an end correct as
a on January 29th that would be an
accurate statement right and that
remained your your view throughout and
in fact was the reality it wasn't until
significant numbers came that they were
able to bring it to another community
and it's my understanding uh
superintendent Abrams that you had a
conversation on January 31st with deputy
chief Bell where he indicated to the
auto Police Service at that time was
looking at a four-week sustainability
plan do you recall that do you recall
that and you were you were quite
surprised is my understanding about that
I was you were concerned the Ottawa
Police were looking at already that this
could be a prolonged event and they were
just going to try to manage it for four
weeks that was your understanding at the
time correct because I just see um from
my experience
we normally plan kind of in 24 hour
Cycles 48 hour Cycles to hear that there
was a plan that didn't look like it
would have a resolution until at least
four weeks was surprising to me yes to
hear that length of time that they were
planning because and I believe that was
the conversation where he basically
stated we we don't know how to how to
resolve this and I I presume
superintendent that it was a concern to
you because
you could observe yourself about the
significant impact on the residents uh
in in downtown Ottawa is that fair
yes and I believe in my other evidence I
said as in my experiences more time goes
by in these events it only adds more
participants which makes the job of
policing more difficulties each day and
week passes it makes the job even more
difficult so excuse me that's why
there's a desire to try to to end this
type of event as soon as you can for
sure
um and that leads to another Point uh
superintend Abrams is that that you know
we've heard a lot of your testimony
about
closing the off ramps to the the 417 and
the opp did not prefer that option
correct you were you wanted the
you were content with the trucks to
continue to come downtown Ottawa on the
weeks weekends that followed correct
no we were happy in the weeks that
followed after the main arrival we were
happy to work with our partners and most
of it was our own Partners uh within the
province of Ontario saying there's X
number of trucks coming to Ottawa
we're happy to try to work out and
communicate with them first hopefully to
say look there's no more room downtown
you can't try to get downtown you know
go to Castleman or go to these other
areas we would try to do those
Communications with those operators
first to the plts yes if we weren't
successful yes Ottawa Police would say
OBP can you can you close this ramp or
this ramp because there's just no
capability to to accept those Vehicles
it's going to cause traffic chaos so can
we try to get them to go to this ramp so
the only way to get them to that ramp
would be to close other ones so we would
do that
you know off and on but we certainly
weren't supportive of just a total block
24 7 of of off-ramps around well if I
understand what you're telling us
superintendent Abrams is that uh that
the opp worked at the auto police to try
to identify the best routes for the
trucks to get downtown if they were
going to indeed come downtown is that
right that would minimize the traffic
impacts on the rest of the city
certainly once once the the con the
the protest was underway and we're in
the second or third week
our plan was if uh with a truck was to
try to get downtown we would interdict
it stopped it and and make arrests under
uh the Mischief authorities because it
was clear their intent was to
participate in what was going on
downtown that's why they were going
there so the idea and the plan was
um uh probably in the second or third
week is that if we saw a convoy coming
across in the middle of the night and
their attempt was to come to Ottawa we
were going to monitor that Convoy try to
communicate with them to say don't go
downtown this is a risk you take if you
go downtown you're clearly wishing to
participate in what is an illegal event
and if you get off at an off-ramp and
intend to head downtown we will stop you
but that was just the last the last four
or five days when the operation was
being rolled out to bring the the event
to an end correct just prior to that's
correct yeah so I still want to make a
blanket statement that we were allowing
we were going to facilitate the arrival
of trucks through this whole event no at
some point we were not going to
facilitate trucks heading into the
downtown court yeah but that was around
February 16th or 17th you stopped doing
that on the weekends the fifth and 6th
and the 12th there were big signs on the
Highway 417 saying Convoy truckers this
way correct that's correct I just wanted
to make sure your initial statement was
it kind of made it seem that we were
going to allow trucks downtown through
the whole event and superintendent
Abrams I'm not sure if you appreciate
how the effective residents of downtown
uh Ottawa felt when they saw the Ottawa
the Ontario Provincial Police putting up
big signs saying convary truckers this
way apparently rolling out a welcome mat
to them downtown did you appreciate how
the people in downtown Ottawa would have
felt at that time I can certainly can
appreciate that and our perspective is
we had to rely on Ottawa Police to say
this is where we need those trucks to go
this is where we think we can house them
so we were only doing what Ottawa Police
were requesting of us
um to facilitate the movement of trucks
I appreciate and understand the Empire
you're out of time I thought I'd get 15.
no you uh according to my notes you had
10.
uh I believe my notes had 15 I'm gonna
ask one more uh question there
commissioner yes go ahead uh
superintendent hark uh superintendent
primary Abrams um you've told us that
you reported up uh to commissioner kirik
and Deputy Commissioner Harkins about
your observations of your concerns with
uh downtown Ottawa uh or probably with
the Ottawa Police and how they were
effectively doing that you would have
assumed that they would have reported
that up to the solicitor general
um no uh because I I'm not familiar with
what uh type of communication the
commissioner has with sister General
whether he reports those things to them
or not I'm not aware of that okay and
but given your observations of the
challenges the significant challenge the
auto Police Service we're having to
respond to this event both based on uh
the the problems you were seeing at
senior command uh as well as just the
bear resources uh did you consider uh do
you know of anyone in the opp ever
considered reporting this either to the
Ontario civilian police commission or
perhaps the auto Police Services Board
so some type of effective action perhaps
could have been taken by others to uh
direct or guide the Ottawa Police
Service uh towards a more effective
response I was never involved in any
conversations like you was just but did
you was that ever considered were you
aware of that if that was ever I wasn't
aware if that was ever considered no
thank you thank you uh next uh call on
the uh province of Saskatchewan
good morning can I be heard in Ottawa
yes
thank you commissioner my name is Mike
Morris and I'm counsel for the
government of Saskatchewan uh good
morning sir
good morning sir
we have about five minutes give or take
today so it won't be too long I have
some fairly straightforward questions
for you I think
uh sir will you agree with me that OPP
officers have authority to enforce the
criminal code and provincial offenses
including under the highway traffic Act
they do have that Authority yes
and am I correct that OPP officers have
always had this Authority including in
the city of Ottawa
yes they're uh they're sworn in as
officers in the province of Ontario
so it follows that OPP officers have not
required the provincial or federal
emergency act to be invoked to have
those Powers then is that correct
uh correct their their powers under
their criminal code the higher traffic
act and other provincial offenses
were in in Authority in any City in the
province of Ontario
and will you agree with me that
intentionally blocking a public road
with one's vehicle can constitute an
offense under the criminal code
there is a block Highway offense another
criminal code correct
and can it also constitute the offense
of mischief
it can as well yes
and can it also constitute an offense
under the highway traffic Act
yes
there's a block Highway offense
now we've heard some evidence about
what's been called the Coventry Road
incident and I understand that occurred
on February 6th of 2022 correct seems
accurate yes
and I understand that the Ottawa Police
Service arrested a number of people in
relation to fuel that they were
stockpiling at the Coventry Road Site
correct that's that I was advised that
information yes
and are you familiar with the offense
that these people were alleged to be
committing
I was advised that they arrested for the
offensive mischief
and would that be uh aiding and abetting
Mischief which was occurring in downtown
Ottawa by trucks occupying the core
well that's how I understand it yes
assuming these people were committing an
offense with OPP officers have had the
same authority to arrest them as the Ops
uh yeah the criminal code applies to all
law enforcement officers if an opp
officer chose
um and felt they had the reasonable
grounds under the Mischief section to
make an arrest for that offense they
would have had the ability to do that if
they chose to yes
and that's the offense of providing fuel
uh for people participating with their
vehicles in the downtown core and block
hating roads correct
if that particular officer felt that it
fit the criminal code and fit as an
offense then you would have the
authority to do that
so at this point we've heard evidence
quite a bit of evidence about there
being a lot of trucks in the Ottawa
downtown core
my question is were there checkpoints
for vehicles entering the downtown core
before the federal emergencies Act was
invoked on February 14th
um checkpoints leading into the downtown
court
yes sir
you can only go by what my officers were
asked to do my officers lpp officers are
never involved in checkpoints I can't
speak to
Ottawa please there are Partners through
the MTO I recall being involved in a
teleconference with the MTO where they
were considering doing
Vehicle Safety checks within the city of
Ottawa but my members were never
involved in any checkpoints
to your knowledge were there road
closures or traffic diversions before
the federal emergencies Act was invoked
on February 14th and I'm talking
specifically to prevent vehicles from
entering the downtown core in Ottawa
I can say there was because uh on the
early days of this event those were the
areas my officers were asked to attend
and when I attended down there to check
on them they were essentially making
sure that certain streets were closed in
the downtown core so there was cement
barriers that blocked some streets and
some streets were blocked with physical
police officers with Cruisers blocking
streets
and am I correct then the decision on
blocking those streets would have been
uh that would have been the decision of
the Ottawa Police Service
the Ottawa Police Service or the city of
Ottawa under their authorities to do
that with their own streets
and do I understand correct I believe I
heard you say that there were road
closures and blocked streets before
February 14th when the federal
emergencies act came into effect is that
correct there was yes
if I I can I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about a demonstration that
occurred in Ottawa in April known as the
Rolling Thunder demonstration are you
familiar with with that one you're going
to have to do it very quickly you're
already over your time
okay I I will be quick commissioner
thank you
I am aware of it and I was assigned as
the Strategic Commander for that event
as well
and I understand there was no emergency
legislation in place when Rolling
Thunder occurred in April correct
correct
and checkpoints or uh
I guess Road roadblocks or controlled
access was used for Rolling Thunder is
that correct yeah correct my members
were used in the same kind of context to
do traffic points and to restrict flow
of vehicles on certain streets yes
and rolling thunder was successfully
managed and resolved correct well I
would call it a successful event yes
thank you sir those are my questions
thank you uh and now if I could call on
the jccf Democracy fund
uh I believe I believe they're attending
uh good morning superintendent I am Alan
honner I'm a lawyer for the Democracy
fund
good morning sir
earlier today Council for Canada asked
you about Towing guidelines from the opp
commissioner
and you couldn't comment on those if you
can't comment on this question it's fine
but are you aware that on February 13
2022
before the Declaration of the public
order emergency
the opp had confirmed that seven towing
companies were willing to provide
services and a total of 34 heavy duty
trucks were available to the opp in
connection with this protest in Ottawa
I would not have been aware of that
because that was not part of my my under
my command or part of my mandate
thank you we'll ask that question to
another witness later on can we pull up
OPP dot ir
s.701
this is the um OPP institutional report
and can we just go to page 36.
just put this in context what we're
looking at here is uh the opp role in
the police response to the
Ottawa blockade
and do you see that that chart there
just maybe scroll down a little bit
so we have a chart here it's called oopp
Frontline officers provided to Ottawa
Police Services
okay so do you notice that um
well first of all let me ask you these
numbers seem
um
seem accurate to you that they actually
reflect the front line officers provided
to uh the Ops on the dates listed
it does and I think it's important to to
clarify when they speak about Frontline
officers it is strictly this those
officers these aren't these numbers
don't include public order unit officers
they don't include Intelligence Officers
they don't include Aviation Services
there's many other OPP resources that
were used in Ottawa that aren't captured
in these numbers just for clarity
yeah understood and thank you for
clarifying that what I noticed when I
look at this chart is that the front
line officers increase significantly
on February the 16th and then again on
February the 18th
and obviously you would agree with that
it's in the chart yep
and now if if we could go back
um just to you page uh 35
and and you know perhaps um
superintendent I don't need to go back
to page 35 would you agree with me that
one of the reasons these um these
officers were able to be deployed to
Ottawa at that time was because
resources were freed up from Windsor
um I suppose there were more resources
from Windsor but the reason for the
increase in the numbers
would have been to bolster
um increased traffic points that needed
to be bolstered in that period of time
in order to support the public order
unit plans so I can say that the
increase that you see on the chart is
directly connected to the successful
conclusion of Windsor it was more
related to operational issues and plants
here in Ottawa okay can we just scroll
down to to where it says February 15th
a part of me uh so it says here Ottawa
Police Services OPP and RCMP planning
sections were physically integrated
um at the RCMP and
and then later on the next paragraph
uh following the reopening of the
Ambassador Bridge 400 additional OPP
members were rapidly uh
uh deployed from across the province so
some of those went to Ottawa and some
went elsewhere I suppose
if that's correct and if it's in this
period of time when we talk about most
of those 400 additional officers were
front line officers and within the opp
the Frontline officer component in
Windsor was not as strong we had a
larger public order unit component in
Windsor so the 400 additional members
those were front line members that came
from around the province and that's why
we had to defer block training and
cancel discretionary leave to be able to
get that number of officers to all of
them and I'm almost out of time here but
would you agree with me that the reason
for the redeployment of these Frontline
officers to Windsor was not related to
the emergencies act
um and that it would have happened
anyway
I'm sorry I have to repeat your question
again
um yes absolutely would you agree with
me that the deployment of these
Frontline officers
um to Ottawa
uh on on on the and and the increase in
numbers on the 16th and on the 18th uh
was not directly related to the
invocation of the emergencies act it is
something that would have happened in
any event I would agree with that it was
directly related to what we knew now was
an operational plan with public order
that needed extra support
and that was the um that was the
operational plan of February 13 2022
correct I I never saw the plan so I'm
not certain of what the date was but it
was the plan that the integrated
planning team came up with it was it
called the integrated mobilization
operational plan
I can't be certain of the title of it
I'm sorry okay but in any event that
plan was in place prior to the
invocation of the emergencies Act
I know it was being worked on because
the integrated planning team came
February 9th they started their work on
the 10th the 11th the Act was in the
effect on the 14th because I wasn't on
that side and I wasn't part of that team
I can't tell you for sure exactly what
date that that plan was finalized
that's fine I suspect we'll hear that
from uh
uh Chief superintendent party State
thank you very much sir those are my
questions thank you
okay
any uh any uh examination by the OPP
next
okay any uh re-examination
just one series of questions very
briefly superintendent Abrams you you
gave evidence about that the February
9th meeting and you were asked in
cross-examination about uh Darwin Tetro
and in the the commitment for the
commitment saw it for 400 RCMP officers
call that I recall yes um can you tell
us was there a similar commitment sought
or offered on behalf of the OPP at that
meeting
I don't recall us speaking about public
order unit commitments we already had a
large amount of public order sections in
the city already I think it was more the
discussion was more about how we could
get extra certainly OPP could provide a
couple more sections but in that meeting
in
Ottawa Police Headquarters I don't
recall us talking about the opp PLU
component that may be able to assist
Chief Hardy may have talked about that
but I don't recall that okay thank you
okay so that completes your examination
and cross-examination thank you very
much for appearing and for your evidence
uh it's uh complete you're now free to
leave thank you commissioner thank you
okay so we're uh
we're
I think at the time where everybody's
entitled to a break uh so uh we will uh
take a break until uh five after uh 12
and then we'll come back and
to go with our next witness who I
understand is Chief superintendent party
the commission is in races for 15
minutes
foreign
order a lot
um
the commission has reconvened that
commissioner
[Music]
hey good afternoon
hey we have another witness uh Council
thank you commissioner it's Frank L
senior Council for the commission our
next witness is Chief superintendent
party
superintendent well you swear on a
religious document or do you wish to
affirm
Elsewhere for the record please State
your full name and spell it out
it's her name rdpar
do you solemnly affirm that the evidence
to be I think he said he'd swear yes oh
apologies you'd like to swear on a
religious document
sorry would you like to swear in a
religious document or a firm
I swear on a religious document sure the
Bible Bible is good okay
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth will help you God I do
thank you thank you
good afternoon
please have a seat uh Chief
superintendent party
um
you remember attending an interview uh
well actually two interviews uh with me
and my commissioned colleagues in the
summer I do sir and after the interviews
we provided you with an interview
summary you did uh may I call up the
document number WTS
six zeros three three
so Chief party this is uh the summary
that we've sent you for review
it it was the version of it yes right uh
this is the version that you you
approved correct and uh do you adopt
this content in this entirety are there
any changes or Corrections you like to
make I I think like all documents
context is important but I'm sure that
will come out in evidence that's right
that's right okay now um Chief uh
superintendent party I understand that
you recently retired after serving more
than 30 years with the opp 36 and a half
years sir uh I started my policing
career in 86. uh I left active duty in
July July 15th but I'm officially
retired now for three weeks only three
weeks 23 weeks congratulations now you
were a former critical incident
Commander yes sir uh and you have
throughout your career worked uh for
many years in the national capital
region on major events
well I spent 28 years of my OPP career
six or six monthly years with the RCMP
in New Brunswick but my 30-year OPP
career 28 event was spent in eastern
Ontario in various roles uh and uh
the latter part the last 12 years of my
career was as a senior leadership role
as a superintendent and I did a lot of
work in the national capital region with
major events presidential visits North
American leader Summits uh Canada Day
events Etc yes
and in the course of your career have
you collaborated frequently with members
of the Ottawa Police Service yes sir
and what do you know of their reputation
in terms of managing or responding to
large-scale events like protest and
demonstrations first class first class
first class now um are you aware of any
changes within the Ops in recent years
that might affect their ability to
respond to these kinds of events well
certainly upon my arrival in with the
integrated planning team uh I asked the
question what's going on what happened
to you guys and certainly the pandemic
has had an impact retirements people
moved on uh lack of major events to
keeping you keeping those skills home uh
when people move on the murchie
Readiness emergency preparedness is much
like crime prevention nobody wants to
pay for it when nothing's happened
and that's across all sectors but
certainly uh you know there's been a
lull perhaps since about 2016
with the mass of large-scale events that
since that they've had in Ottawa so it's
just been a considerable passage of time
that there hasn't been anything major uh
but yet Ottawa is renowned for almost
daily protests of some
mm-hmm so I'm going to take you back now
to the events back in January February I
understand that uh in January of this
year you were the commander of the opp
north east region right that's correct
sir and then in early February you were
asked to lead the integrated Planning
Group to assist the Ottawa Police
Service that's correct so let's talk
about the specific assignment uh your
lead role with the Planning Group the
integrated Planning Group when were you
asked to take that on
it was the evening of February 7th I
received a
telephone call from my supervisor who is
Deputy Commissioner Chris Hawkins
uh asking uh that we're advising that
they were putting together a team of a
team to go to Ottawa to assist Ottawa
and asked if I would be interested in
leading that team uh he felt that I was
a good fit for it with my background and
uh he gave me you know 10 seconds to say
I didn't want to do it I accepted the
assignment and That very night packed a
bag and added to Aurelia for a briefing
the following morning and the foreign
morning what time was the briefing I
believe uh it was about 9 A.M in the
Commissioner's Office who attended uh
commissioner Creek was there Deputy
Commissioner Harkins uh
superintendent Mike mcdonell was present
superintendent Craig Abrams was on video
link I believe perhaps the the
commissioner's executive officer may
have been president as well but I I
don't particularly recall right and with
just uh this morning heard from
superintendent Abrams
now um could we call up the
uh the witness will say a number OPP
50792 please
now a chief party we have the commission
has received a will say
um is going to be shown on screen uh I
just wanted to ask you do you recall
when this will say was first prepared
um but it was started while I was still
in Ottawa
when in Ottawa during the month of
February uh my my supervisor Deputy
Commissioner arkins had suggested that
you know put start putting my mind to
developing or preparing a will State uh
for the events leading up to and to the
conclusion in Ottawa
I started it with uh with high
intentions of catching up and keeping it
live but uh within within a few hours
but my my schedule was overtaken and so
I had maybe one page done while I was in
Ottawa and I completed it when I went
back to my regular duties in North Bay
and when did you complete it uh first
week of uh
March okay
um now
tell us about uh
the nature of your assignment what was
the mandate
well the Mandate was to provide
Ottawa Police support
uh I was given a broad range to ask for
anything I needed
I received from start of the deployment
to the conclusion of deployment uh that
type of support from not just my
organization because I was I was an opp
officer but leading a team an
integrative team from multiple
organizations so it wasn't just OPP it
wasn't about Copp but I was given uh
incredible support to ensure that we got
what we needed understanding the
complexities of the events in Ottawa and
the evolving events that are happening
both provincially and nationally right
so a moment ago you were starting to
tell us about this 9 A.M briefing yes
involving among others commissioner
karik of the opp tell us about that
briefing what was discussed well uh I've
got an overview from superintendent
Abrams uh as to the the State of the
Union in Ottawa uh that the the concern
was there wasn't a plan uh they were
asking for a lot of resources uh but uh
there was no concrete plan in terms of
how those resources were going to be
utilized uh there was dysfunction there
was a loss of confidence and Faith being
displayed by the public the narrative in
the media was certainly slanted uh you
know there was no in terms of the the
protest and by the protesters uh
generally it was uh it was uh reached it
was a crisis
in Ottawa now you mentioned earlier that
uh the the purpose was to support
um you know one of my my most common
phrases that I uttered throughout my
time is
in
Ottawa with their senior executive their
officers were here to help
and what kind of help
whatever they need but it you know we
were there to help build and complement
uh any plans and direction that they
have there was never an intent and I was
this was explicit in my assignment we
were not going to Ottawa to take over
command and control of the event uh we
were going there to support them uh
certainly there was a goal to inter
integrate or unify commands uh this is
an event that was clearly now beyond the
capability of one signal organization
just by its size and and the need for
resources it stretched well beyond what
Ottawa Police themselves could provide
which uh in my world that's that's
generally the the the the kickoff for
developing the unified or or an
integrated command with others uh
so uh you know that was that was the
focus to get there to to have a team of
dedicated people of which I only knew
one of the people that were assigned to
me uh I was be I was going to be meeting
uh these people uh that evening when I
arrived uh we were given I was given a
contact uh with the Ottawa Police and uh
later that morning I got in my vehicle
and I started making my way and spent
the next four hours on the phone right
so you were in Aurelia at 9 00 am and by
5 35 that afternoon you were in a
meeting with the members of the uh Ops
right that's correct
um who did you meet with uh at that 5 35
PM meeting well I know I had someone
taking minutes for uh for that meeting
uh
uh I know deputy chief Trish Ferguson
who I'd known previously I was at the
meeting uh superintendent Patterson
there was a number of of other uh folks
with them both on conference and video
link uh and all that initially even in
my own minutes it reflected that Chief
slowly was president at the meeting uh
because that was on the invite but he uh
did not make that meeting due to
emergency emergency was delayed right I
don't recall him joining the minutes
don't reflect any comments or in uh
whatsoever from the chief my
recollection is he did not join the
meeting at all all right now we uh we
heard from
uh deputy chief Ferguson from the Ops
yesterday I believe she said that the
chief the former Chief was delayed but
he did join by
um teleconference or some other means of
remote communication and that is very
possible as I said I I reviewed the
minutes from the meeting uh and uh you
know when you look at all the minutes
that we took throughout the event it is
very clear in my humble opinion who's
speaking there was certainly no
indication from those minutes that he
was there but it's very possible that he
was that he did join right now if we
scroll down uh this will say uh to the
next page
right so um
this the first dark bullet planning team
held his first meeting at 17 35 hours
from RCMP headquarter uh with the Ops
all ops were on video or conference call
also note that Council for the Ops
Christian hanod was present do you
recall uh her being present uh on a
video conference yes sorry
uh and um
okay now
um let's talk about uh
what was discussed uh at that meeting
tell us what happened uh you know we we
started the meeting by just doing the
introductions of those that were
available from my team my team are still
not all in Ottawa they were still uh
arriving but we did have uh inspector
Tim Skinner from the York Region Police
one of my planners from our emergency
unit in israelia Brad Taylor was present
uh superintendent uh Phil Liu from the
RCMP and uh
sorry then start Sergeant now style
Sergeant Darwin tetral from the RCP as
well uh was present uh you know we
stated our objective we're there to help
what do you need we need a plan let's
start building on we're there to help
build building on what your objectives
are and uh and they proceeded to give us
a broad overview of their concept of
operations uh for uh for the the
occupation uh and it was just that it
was a concept of operations uh we had
lots of questions uh we we received an
update from uh superintendent uh
Patterson uh about and he was the
incident the event Commander at that
time about things that were on the
horizon with some potential arrests and
some strategic take backs if you will uh
in in the the downtown court
uh listening intently just to find out
our goal I start to finish in the
meeting is learn as much as we possibly
could
you can only help when you have a true
understanding for what the needs are uh
and uh to understand those needs and we
left that meeting with a commitment
from Ottawa Police that they would
provide the plans to us we asked for
e-versions whatever version they could
get to us would be very helpful so that
we could see what they have on paper in
terms of their plan and then what we
would reasonably need to do to
complement that plan uh also it was
critic for us to have access to that The
Honorable place this is there we're
there to work with them uh to to get
through this uh so we wanted an
established liaison who at the authority
to access and provide the information
that we would need
was there any discussion at that meeting
about the nature of integration between
the Ops and the group that you're
bringing it was raised by me at that
meeting if they would consider okay
integration uh or a unified command uh I
could just inherent benefits with it uh
you know from my experience uh I just
about all of my major events that I've
been involved what we ended up having
here in Ottawa with an integrated
command has been my experience right you
know whether it's a presidential visit
uh you still have the police of
jurisdiction you have to leave or the
rctp because of their IPP
responsibilities or internationally
protected persons UH responsibilities
under legislation uh but when you call
on multiple organizations to participate
they bring their command structure you
inject your your advice to them you work
as a team ultimately someone is leading
that and makes the final call but as an
integrated team you're all on the same
page you're not working in silos you're
working
collectively with the same objectives
and goals
let's talk about the members of this
team that you were assembling and
bringing to to Ottawa it's called
integrated planning sell or integrated
Planning Group
they call the the that was the
assignment to create this inter
integrated planning so we quickly
deviated from the word self and just
call it our integrated Planning Group
okay uh but uh yes I was provided with
uh planners from Toronto Police Service
to uh two uh planner Sergeant Arlene
Duffy and and Constable Isabel sea their
background and their credentials were
impressive in terms of emergency
planning
uh I had inspector Tim Skinner who I
already mentioned from York Region
Police his background is in public order
maintenance and command and control
uh again a wealth of knowledge uh I had
Tom Warfield from the peel Regional
Police Service
Tom came to us with a background in in
case management to ensure that we were
capturing to the best that we could in a
very kinetic and dynamic environment as
much of the information versions and
whatnot as we went forward
uh we had Brad Taylor who a planner
extraordinaire from the uh for the opp
Brad is a civilian member uh but his
expertise is in emergency planning uh
lie heavily on uh on Brad for it for his
expertise
um
yeah of course he had the two RCP
officers uh
Phil Liu who became my right arm
throughout the the event Phil's
background was in major instrument
command national standards uh had an
extensive background in training and
developing and mentoring people in the
instant command world and and Darwin
tetral who to this day has impressed to
me incredibly with his leadership uh in
uh public order Command right so he's
renowned nationally and and connected
internationally as it relates to public
order maintenance right so yesterday
when uh we spoke to when uh deputy chief
Ferguson testified and uh she explained
the process of developing a plan uh an
operational plan she referred to subject
matter experts uh so the this group of
people that you're bringing to to Ottawa
are these subject matter experts then in
the various areas yes sir in fact I
would say that I was the only one that
wasn't a subject matter expert
all right I was just brought to bring
this team together and get them working
and and Lead our way through this right
now um we've heard
um from some witnesses about the
importance of operational plans and I
just want to
your view on what are the components the
key components of a good operational
plan
well the key components uh you know have
the line with your objectives and your
your goals and your uh and then that
drives your strategies in terms of what
that operation is meant to
uh to to entail uh certainly you need to
have a clear understanding uh in
creating a mission for uh the event
the mission statement is something that
in every event that I've ever been
involved in whether it was a peaceful
event or or not is something that is
critical that your members your your
employees your officers on the ground
everybody is in line with the mission of
of of of the plan
uh from there Commander's objectives and
then you know what what are we looking
to achieve with this plan and then every
single aspect so if it's a public order
issue you would need the key aspect
there was is is the public order consult
and a good idea okay what what is the
nature and scope of the event and what
kind of public Order Plan would we need
to inject with it you need crime you
need victims you need uh key things like
messaging communication uh Logistics is
key in fact major events from a policing
perspective when we debrief often
are successful or fail on the backs of
of goods solid Logistics support when
you get people there what are you doing
with them where are they staying how are
we feeding them what's their duties how
are they being brief that all has to be
fleshed out uh so that when you have
people arrive you have a seamless
operation right now we've heard
references to an overall overarching
plan and sub plans for specialized uh
areas so what were those what you were
trying to describe to us absolutely and
I was speaking with people that I had
confidence also were on the same page
and understood that right
and in terms of an overall plan or
overarching plan does that refer to
something that takes you from start to
finish yes sir
what about contingencies
well that's always built into your
planning uh you when you look at public
order as an example uh it's filled with
contingency plans if this is the intent
if it doesn't work this is not this is
our main action plan or direct action
plan and then there'll be an alternate
action plan if if they have to deviate
and uh command and control structure
should that be reflected uh absolutely
why is that important again you know you
when you're developing plans for major
events the ultimate goal is to succeed
and in order to succeed there needs to
be or police officers there were
creatures of habits there needs to be
clear lines of communication there needs
to be clear command control who is in
charge who is responsible for this uh
Right Down the Line because there's in
major events you might have a major
event Commander right down to a
commander on the ground all have
distinct roles but roles and
responsibilities are absolutely key to
to get you through the event uh and it's
in a successful way
at the time you arrived on February 8th
uh do you did you know if the Ops had
experienced planners like the ones you
brought to Ottawa to help them develop
this kind of a plan uh I was making an
assumption based on my experience with
Ops that in fact they they did have that
depth uh although some of the ones that
I had worked with in the past were
absent and I learned I'd retired uh and
because as I said the op Ops have always
been renowned we've been there to
support them countless times in major
events we're different organizations we
have different structures uh but make no
mistake about it they they were good at
what they did
right so you told us that on on that
first meeting at that first meeting you
were shown uh this strategic concept of
operations document but you didn't have
a copy right
you didn't you weren't given a copy at
that meeting uh if there was references
to it on that date I I do believe I I
may have been given a copy but
and uh and and you said you asked for
more we asked for more and they
indicated that uh there was a nod from
superintendent passion that any plans
that were approved would be in fact uh
supplied to us okay so we go to the next
day February the 9th uh at 7 A.M there's
a note in your will say that you weren't
getting the plans yet
um and uh we go to page three of the
will say
the second bullet
oops um
that's right uh oats maybe scroll down a
bit
is this page three
oh that's right
um so uh sorry uh scroll up please
okay the second bullet uh discussion uh
after this discussion around injunctions
and then stressed we needed to develop a
plan oh I'm sorry I think I'm looking at
the wrong page
um
okay I found it now so uh go down again
I apologize uh
after February the heading February the
9th do you see the second bullet yes
and the last two sentences
I learned that everything had to go to
the chief before it could be action or
released to our team now I just wanted
to ask you about that what did you mean
by this well we learned very very early
in the uh in our time in Ottawa that the
chief was very much engaged
uh and that ultimately everything that
they intended to do had to be approved
by him
who told you this I heard it from just
about every Ops employee that I dealt
with there in some way shape or form
okay it was very clear to me my dealings
with uh with her senior officers Chris
riem whose name is there uh Rob Drummond
who was at times working with us in
different aspects Trish Ferguson I
didn't deal a whole lot during my
initial days with Chi uh deputy chief
belt but certainly it was very very
clear that that Chief slowly was to be
informed of and approving uh all aspects
of their operation now In fairness to
the former Chief you you did tell us
that there was some departure of senior
officers from the Ops so isn't it quite
understandable that he wanted more
things to go through him to ensure that
uh you know important decisions are made
with the benefit of his input I don't
blame sir I I look at it's this was an
incredible event unfolding in your city
uh that was said that the loss of
confidence that you were seeing uh in
the media in the Police Service uh
undoubtedly brought a lot of stress to
Bear uh that he wanted to be uh looped
in on everything that was going on
I can't fault them
and you also mentioned earlier that um
that the Ops Council Christian anode was
present yes I I did find that to be uh
from my experience to be a little
bizarre
why is that well uh you know needless to
say I've been involved in a lot of major
operations over the years and there's
always consult with legal on our legal
authorities and come authorities in the
different uh tactics where you make sure
that we're sound within uh in the law
however it was a first time experience
to have Council actually sit through
operational discussions
but wouldn't it be helpful to have a
lawyer around in case any legal
questions or eyes
well again as as as it became more
protracted the event uh I suppose it
could be you know where you would have
counsel there immediately to give advice
back uh on on
legal points that were being discussed
uh but as we proceeded it it certainly
came across a little bit more than that
uh that she was a tantamount to a an
approver of of the action of the plan
which was very concerning it's police
operations
okay uh so uh that uh
that was your um that's that's the
morning uh of the ninth uh when you were
still looking for a plan and not getting
it yet
um and then that around noon that day uh
you got to meet with the the Ops team
again right yes uh where did you go well
we we had called for a meeting uh to to
to to discuss things more broadly uh and
uh it was downtown Ottawa at the
Ottawa Police Station 474 Elgin Street
uh he was in an upstairs boardroom uh we
couldn't bring all of our team I would
have liked to but we you know we're
going to be somewhat restricted and we
were still in the pandemic so we were
mindful of all these things still going
on uh so we we brought a smaller part of
the team including uh uh Craig Abrams
who also joined her team initially along
with Mike Francis two old BP officers
who had been in Ottawa working already
assisting the Ottawa one from a Pou
perspective one more from a command
strategic command perspective
uh myself tetral Skinner uh and uh
Phil Loop and there was another RCP
officer I believe his name is Charles
Mason was was present with this meeting
along with the ops command team and
their Council okay well tell us what
happened at that meeting well again we
we discussed two different documents
that they provided us through strategic
con uh stuff of operations uh that was
the same one that you saw yesterday very
similar and uh yes I believe it was the
same uh they're a broader overarching
kind of concept of operations for the
truck demonstration
uh and uh we had discussions about that
uh
we we we we're again we're asking for
numbers we had there was a sergeant or
staff sergeant LeBlanc from the Ottawa
Police Service Who provided us uh the
breakdown of numbers what they needed to
sustain operations and a number if I'm
not mistaken was
516 ftes or police officers to sustained
operations at all the checkpoints that
they needed we had a lot of debate about
that uh ultimately
you know there's some math issues that
we we came to terms with uh but but
again uh our goal is there to completely
understand we didn't just screw in blank
say what do you need here you go
uh so we had discussions about about
that and then we had discussions about
uh well an overview provided to us by
superintendent Patterson uh of an
operation reader and Sussex that they
were contemplating
uh it was my notes reflect that it was
scheduled for four with the possibility
of being moved up
to 11 pm
and that night uh
as I noted I I brought those that I did
to this meeting for a specific purpose
and you know we had discussed it prior
to like we're going there as a team you
have input to give give it you know we
have a lot to get done here in a short
period of time let's not pull the older
thing back here so uh Darwin tetral asks
if he could speak when he was being
presented this thing uh and I do
appreciate when I heard of telling the
superintendent of abrams's evidence that
he mentioned the number 400 the number
in my mind and in my notes was 800 he
said based on his knowledge appeal you
when you look at the Dynamics of this
event the number of areas that were
blockaded uh and the work that had to be
done we would need approximately 800 uh
PLU officers to effectively dismantle
this protest
uh but furthermore and the key thing for
me hearing from a subject matter expert
with is his level of experience is that
once you start this operation you should
not stop
and their intention uh as it was
presented to us was to kind of do it
chunk to use the the words that were
used chunk by chunk
and there was recognition that it would
be very resource intensive a significant
demand and resources to do it that way
but we didn't have significant number of
resources and the the best advice and
evidence or sorry best advice I was
receiving right at that meeting from our
rsme is that strategically if you're
going to do this appropriately when you
start your plou action you should not
stop you need to start moving
systematically through all the points to
shut it down
and he suggested that we put pump the
brakes let's let's stop this let's not
proceed with this operation
and uh ultimately that is what happened
uh although I did have conversations
with the instant commander who was
assigned to the operation just by
happenstance is that baronette uh Paul
Bernard yes
and uh ultimately that operation did not
happen but that was back to the meeting
that was is inject into it
um there was a lot of discussion about
resources because when he he erased that
number and again the number sticks out
to me because it ultimately was the
number of Pou proximately that we needed
to successfully dismantle so Darwin
Tetro is from the national capital
region he lives in this area he runs
these programs nationally for public
order maintenance he is a public order
man first himself
and uh he had given a lot of thought to
understanding the zones which had been
presented to the day before in terms of
of all the the checkpoints and the key
areas of concern in the red zone so uh
you know I I thought you know very
clearly he's already put some
significant Insight in terms of what
needs to be done to successfully shut
this down so Chief slowly very
passionately and very concerned about
the reliability of getting resources he
was very concerned that we would come
through he wanted guarantees with no
caveats that if you're going to say
you're going to give us X you're going
to give us X period no questions asked
we just stressed that we're building the
plan we have the support of our
organizations to get it what is needed
to develop a plan to successfully shut
this down
all right so you've uh you've covered a
lot of grounds there's let's try to
unpack that a little bit
um first with respect to the the numbers
uh as it relates to the Rito Sussex
operation I just want to be clear uh
because we heard some evidence about
doubling the number but here it's quite
the opposite isn't it like they were
preparing for an action uh planning for
using 400 and you're telling us that
according to the subject matter experts
in your group you're going to need 800.
no they didn't suggest a 400 I think
that was Craig Abram's evidence that he
thought that petrol suggested that you
would need Foreigner to do it oh in my
view and my notes reflect that tetral
said you need 802 effectively because
when you start see this plou action when
you start kinetic action in this way you
can't stop all right which means when
you look at the number of areas that
needed to be right control need to be
taken back that was his immediate
assessment and that proved to be very
accurate as our planning Assumption of
that day and as we then engaged all the
smes to develop that plan it was exactly
what was needed does that go back to
something we talked about earlier uh
planning from beginning to end and
anticipate the different it absolutely
does because we we did have a number of
times throughout my time in Ottawa where
there was deviations sudden deviations
from the plan that would impact the
broader plan if we were to do it uh but
yes planning from end to end is is
always your goal uh you always like to
have lots of time to plan
uh we were planning in crisis mode uh
and doing it uh as quickly as possible
uh and trying to consider everything
that needed to be considered from the
residents to victims to the cold weather
the conditions in the city of Ottawa
everything needed to be factored into
the plan right now
um you also said something about uh the
former Chief being very passionate now I
want to take you to uh to your will say
uh at page
page three
sorry yeah page three at the very bottom
so here
uh
Chief slowly was very passionate about
the impact
the demonstration was having on the city
and he was looking to break the
occupations however they had limited
ability to affect this due to Baseline
levels of Staffing
uh I offered that we were there to
ensure that he had what was needed to
sustain operations but needed a plan he
advised they were working on last minute
plans does that reflect what happened at
that meeting it does sir so let me ask
you this uh as I understand it then you
were offering to help and then you said
you needed a plan but
putting this in context
um because this happened on February the
9th right so we're already more than a
week into the protest and the commission
has heard evidence how
that has caused significant social
impact on residents and so on and if the
suggestion is that you need a plan
before we can send resources isn't that
problematic because they may not at that
stage have even the resources to do the
planning
so how do they get more resources
well
that's a very loaded loaded question uh
essentially you need a plan to be able
to communicate with police leaders when
you're asking for resources from around
the province and in this case around the
country
you need to be able to articulate uh
what that need is and why that need
exists uh and in in doing that it's
always about you know what's my officers
going to be doing when they get there
how what are the logistics what are the
the plan the briefings everything is
something that you always provide
we're in a state right now uh that you
know I I learned really quickly that
Staffing was an issue for Ops that is an
issue with just about every policing
organization out there for a myriad of
reasons so as a regional Commander
coming into this from another region
where you're going to be called upon
to provide resources to supplement a an
operational plan
you're pulling from resources that you
have available to at least your
communities
and oftentimes in a lot of my
detachments were already at our base
level
so when you're still because of a crisis
there you're going to pull you're going
to pull them only when they're needed
not to sit around waiting to know what
they're going to do when they get there
plan is absolutely critical and it can
be a concept
because we developed the concept of
operations within 48 Hours of being an
auto a concept of operations that we
ultimately use throughout the event so
you can have that and know that you're
building this this this and we're going
to need to staff those up so let's start
preparing that
but it can't just be I need this number
you need to know what these people are
going to be doing when they get there
right down to where they staying who's
feeding them
you just we're human beings you need
those basics in place none of that was
in place right so let's take a look at
this plan that they did show you
um on the ninth at this meeting
um could we call up please uh OPP 50774
so if we go to page 91 please
sorry counselor can you repeat the page
uh page 91 91 thank you
so looking at the cover does this
resemble the document that you saw at
that meeting on February the 9th yes sir
it does and uh if we go to the mission
statement at page 96
uh so the the mission statement simply
reads to end the the unlawful elements
of the Ottawa truck demonstration and
restore save and open neighborhoods and
businesses what do you think of this
mission statement well it's a mission
statement it wasn't broad enough for for
my liking uh you know it was uh it was
just really really uh refocused and not
encompassing the broader event uh my
experience with mission statements
safety needs to be factored in officer
sugar officers need to know uh because
if every officer needs to know it's
drilled into them every every briefing
the mission for the operation is drilled
into them so safety for the residents
safety for officer safety for the
protesters Charter rights often are
embedded so you have all those
considerations in a more broader mission
statement right now we heard from Deputy
uh Ferguson yesterday that by February
the 13th your group has collaborated
with superintendent Bernier of the Ops
to come up with another plan
so can we call up that other plan and
the number is
um
foreign
OPP
four zeros one eight five one
sorry can you repeat that OPP four zeros
one eight five one
can we see the the entire front page
please
or maybe the next page has the date
there we have it do recall this as being
the plan that was developed by the 13th
uh yes sir that uh and that is my
signature on it okay
um can we go to the mission statement at
page eight please
so this mission statement reads
using an integrated response the Ottawa
Police and policing Partners will keep
the peace enforce legislation and
maintain Public Safety for the duration
of the Ottawa truck demonstration with
the utmost respect to the individual's
Charter chart of right Charter of Rights
and Freedoms with priority on community
and Emergency Services Personnel safety
and well-being
um
how does this one compare with the one
we saw before what is a mission the
other one's more an objective
uh this is the the broader mission of
the entire integrated response when when
it's all done we'll have accomplished
this to ensure safety for all
uh involve uh maintain Public Safety for
the duration Etc so it the mission is is
your very high level your strategic
Direction you want to go in now you just
had a moment earlier that the other one
the shorter one wasn't so much to your
liking but is it a matter of subjective
preference or is it something more
objective uh I would say no it's it's
it's it's more objective I mean I go
back to my training and instant command
my involvement in multiple uh North
American leader Summits uh uh
presidential visits uh G8 G20 uh First
Nations issues blockades uh no we've
always been taught very earlier missing
needs to encompass
that broader range to ensure how you're
going to accomplish your goals and what
you're open to accomplish okay so uh
yogurt came and four days later after
the February 9th meeting you have this
plan uh in collaborate developed
collaboratively with the Ops
um so I guess my question is if this can
be done within a number of days after
your group arrived
why didn't you come earlier
well that's not uh
a question that I can really answer I
went the day that I was asked to ago uh
before then I was a commander for the
Northeast region uh I I was alive to
what was going on with the Convoy
because it came through my region we had
an ops plan for that uh but uh that's a
question that perhaps should be posed to
somebody else yes I I'm sorry it is not
a fair question to you
um you were chosen to lead the project
you weren't the one who came up with the
idea but looking back knowing what we
know now about the Ops capacity to
develop something like this would you
agree that it would have been very
helpful for a group of experts like
yours
to offer assistance to the Ops let's say
the Monday after the first weekend
instead of on February 9th yeah that's
that's a fair fair statement sure
all right uh let's talk about
um
now you you said the uh the February 9th
plan that would present was presented to
your group uh missed a lot of the key
elements of a good plan
um in your view the February 13th plan
uh was that good enough it was it was
getting there I mean we realized as I
mentioned when you when you're building
a planet in crisis uh you're ensuring
that you are encompassing all key
elements to that plan knowing that there
is literally things are going to be
continuing to be built into that plan
once the event is even finished yeah you
know because it's based on your concept
you know what you're going to do and how
you need to Resource it but you're still
continuing the plan will continue to
evolve through the duration of the event
right now one of the things that you
also told us that arose during this
February 9th meeting is the the former
Chiefs request or he was seeking some
assurances he was asking for some kind
of a guarantee that the resources would
arrive right and um I take it that you
you disagree that that kind of
guarantees could be given
I I it wasn't that I disagree that the
guarantees uh could be given I think we
need the context of the conversation
uh you know there's debate about some
misrepresentation of numbers in the
media uh that that he had with
superintendent Abrams uh there is
discussion because he made a very clear
uh from my view to in conversation with
my ad that there were people in the
ministry that wanted them to fail and he
had sources in the ministry that was
letting them know that you know people
wanted him to fail
and I just assured him that well we're
not those we're here to help well what
about the um the argument that to plan
properly one needs to know a little more
about what kind of resources you can
count on so for example if the Ops were
to develop a plan based on having 1800
officers available that plan wouldn't
have been very helpful if those people
are not actually coming right
yeah
well I'm going to suggest the opposite
if they had a plan that an operational
plan that encompassed 1800 officers uh
with with duties assigned in a rotating
cycle than we would have been refined
likely that plan to ensure that it was
sound and we could we could have done
that fairly quickly and started our
deployment because we actually started
deploying officers in our team
pretty much on day one
as needs were arriving all right now if
we go back to the website please
um
document number
is OPP
50792
page four
go down please
I'm looking for the center okay yeah do
you see the sentence the overall tone
yes the overall tone of this meeting was
somewhat unprofessional and
disrespectful
Chief slowly was very clearly under
tremendous pressure to act and was very
suspicious of levels of commitments from
police agencies
um
tell us more why you said that well uh
as I said when we attended this meeting
we fully anticipated to
you know and I'm not looking I don't
look for thanks but expected that there
we're going to be welcomed there that
they was going to be happy that we were
there uh you know the meeting I'm well
the the meeting overall the tone I would
say was very uh antagonistic uh it was
disrespectful uh uh you know in terms of
where they're we're there to help
and uh he's just not trusted if it was
very clear he had confidence issues uh
in what we were there to do
it wasn't what you expected certainly
not what we uh expected I think just but
everyone on my team at some point in
time within the minutes of leaving the
meeting received apologies from other
members of his command for his behavior
right now if we scroll down at this on
the same page a little further
um or we may go into the next page then
I'm looking for a sentence that starts
with after the chief and his team left
right thank you after the chief and his
team left the room inspector Debbie
Palmer remained with our team and we
again press for copies of their plans
e-versions and she stressed the chief's
comments that some aspects of their plan
had not yet been approved
tell us well I want to stress as well
notwithstanding the tone of the meeting
it did not change our result
you know we went Debbie Palmer was the
person that was initially uh the name
that was initially provided to me as as
our go-to person
uh she was replaced the following
morning by Chris realm uh uh but uh
that's what like the chief had meant
there still was some last minute
planning going on uh and she said she
would do her best to get it for us you
know in the end we really never did
receive a plan
from UPS right
so at the end of this meeting on
February 9th was there any agreement
between the Ops in the integrated
Planning Group
on any operational plans going forward
well we just committed to continue to
build and work with this team uh and to
build a plan to complement what their
objectives were from their cutoffs that
they provided us and was there any
agreement about the degree of
integration no
now um
we expect that we may hear evidence from
Mr slowly that to the extent the his
approval is required
um he gave all the approval necessary on
February 9th what would you say to that
I obviously wasn't there
because I I received no such information
of approvals uh I think it's reflective
in in the follow-up meetings where they
have when I would call them to say
what's your status well we need a
meeting before we can
we need we need another meeting before
we for me to understand that before we
can move forward so there was no implied
uh
certainly no implied or explicit
approvals for it for anything
commissioner I saw you looking at me is
that a sign it's uh it's it's if it's a
good time it will take an hour for lunch
and come back after thank you thank you
very perspicacious on you
okay so they're gonna break for lunch
and we'll come back in in an hour
the commission is in recess for one hour
foreign
order a lot
the commission has reconvene the
commission on a plan good afternoon
commissioner good afternoon
okay I'm ready to go I am
okay
go ahead Chief party uh just before the
lunch break I was uh asking you
questions about the meeting uh on
February the 9th yes sir and I just want
to finish that off
as taking you to
um one more document uh of that meeting
that this is not your notes but someone
at the Ops was also taking notes so uh
if I could call up uh document number
Ops
three zeros one four four five four
please
page 138 please
so if we
right
um
so if we go to the bottom of the page
please
do you see a reference
from the chief that starts with there
there we there we go we can so the chief
uh the former Chief of the Ops Mr slowly
apparently asked the question we can add
the info
that was provided by the RCMP
um
but we haven't agreed not to proceed
with our plan for tonight
and then he asked are we still separate
entities
or
are you folding into our incident
command system
there's a notation that the opp
said yes we should I think it's prop
probably probably yes we should probably
fold into the ops command structure do
you recall having that kind of exchange
I do recall an exchange by working under
their command yes in the integrated
command structure that's kind of how it
does work but there was some clear
uh differences of opinion I think in
terms of what integration would look
like which I which I'm sure we'll get to
as we go through uh but I I had no
issues we we had some very uh loose talk
around where we would work the location
that we were situated at as significant
capacity to expand
uh and that also became a contentious
issue because uh it took some time to
even get us to work in the same area
which which proved to add layers of
difficulty uh to eventually it did
happen and it became quite seamless
right and this is also consistent with
what you you've been telling us all
along that you were there to offer help
but not to take over
we were at like explicitly I was I was
directed from my commissioner that we
are not going to Ottawa to take over uh
the chief and the police jurisdiction
still have Primacy over this event we're
there to assist them hopefully in an
integrated and unified fashion
um and this may be a question that's
unrelated to the February 9th meeting
but since we've heard so much about the
Hendon reports I'm just curious how were
you one of the recipients of the handing
report that around January February uh
of this year as a regional Commander I
was receiving the Hendon reports uh were
you reading them reading them and uh
just oftentimes there's aspects so we're
just repeat going through the changes
and the change because I and it was
internally produced by the OPP uh
intelligence Bureau and attended uh
briefings as required on significant
changes that would occur okay so uh with
that if I could now take you to the
event in the subsequent days following
these the February 9th meeting did work
continue on February the 10th in terms
of
um working on this plan a new plan from
the integrated Planning Group or making
Improvement to the ops plan that that
you were shown on the 9th I I appreciate
that when you look at from an appearance
perspective they look like very
different plans at its core however the
plan that we developed was a build on in
support of to complement the plan that
the concept that they had in place right
which was all strategically directed in
the same way about ending the protests
and bringing Ottawa back to a state of
normalcy and that makes sense because
you came to offer support and you asked
what they had so that you could build on
it correct sir so
um
if I could take you to the next document
opp404283
so if we could uh strength uh the page
so we can see the entire page please
so this is a document that we received
from the opp it looks like a draft
document of some sort
at the bottom it says it's prepared by
the integrated planning cell RCMP OPP
you know those probably services that
you've talked about earlier
um and I want to take you to
section 3.1 of this document
so now if we can enlarge it
so this part of the document appears to
be an assessment of the current
situation as you found it uh on February
the 10th which is the the date of this
drop document you see that under current
the first bullet says not intelligence
LED
do you agree with the assessment that
the the Ops operation at that time was
not intelligence-led
not in the way strictly that I would
have anticipated no I do not believe uh
you know when you look at
intelligence-led policing you're looking
at your threat assessments your risk
assessments uh and how you can affect
some positive change using that
intelligence uh they were in crisis mode
and in crisis both they I did not feel
that they were using the intelligence to
look at the broader event to see about
how they could dismantle this event
peacefully and when your group uh was
trying to build on whatever plan that
you saw on the ninth uh what was your
objective like in terms of incorporating
any available intelligence that was
available to the group well two of the
key things that we did as a team as I
arranged uh intelligence and PLT
briefings for my team at the highest
level so superintendo Morris and his
entire team joined us uh inspector
Marcel Bode and a number number of both
I believe OPP and Ops PLT joined us we
wanted their perspective on the lay of
land the current intelligence what we
know what we don't know what are the
gaps
and uh and and likewise with the PLT in
terms of how are things going uh what
can be improved upon uh what is what
levels of authority that they have to
engage uh what is the plan moving
forward is there opportunities uh that
we can capitalize on to uh to persuade
some of the protesters to leave on their
own accord
et cetera so we receive those briefing I
wanted my planners and my team all the
tacticians I wanted them to be fully
aware
uh in that point in time what we were
dealing with we did have subsequent uh
an additional and additional briefings
throughout from those entities just to
make sure that there's if there's any
change that we might need to Pivot to
adjust to those changes right and I I
think I saw some references in your
notes that on the 10th you got some
input from Marcel bodang was he the
person from the opp in charge of the pot
group Marcel is he's got a background
inspector with our uh indigenous
policing Bureau and uh he has a
background yes in provincial liaison
right so on the same document that's on
the screen if we go down further
we see a section with the PLT
so there we go and
Chief party you see there's some there's
not complete I assume because it's a
drop document but there's there's some
information Incorporated uh under this
section and if we scroll down slowly so
that the witness can have a quick look
now does this capture in Broad terms the
kind of information you were looking for
in order to inform the the
the new approach it does you know you
need to know the sentiment of the
community what the desired outcomes are
PLT do amazing work at ensuring that
they understand all sides and that's
what good negotiators do and they are
just that they are negotiators uh
they're trained to do what they do uh to
to understand the perspective of all
sides to ensure that uh information uh
have run expectations around the law are
properly communicated to uh all sides
and uh and to do their best to to
improve and gain a build those
relationships build that trust with with
people so that what they say they know
that they can take what they say to the
bank that they're going to be following
through with what they say now if I
could take you back to your will say uh
Madam clerk OPP four five zeros 792
I believe it was on this day February
10th Chief party that the one of the uh
subject matter experts from the RCMP
Darwin tetrode prepared a concept of
operations that was based on the
information that you were gathering so
if we go to page five of this document
foreign
I want to go down to the bullet that
starts with on February on the on the
10th of February
there we go
um
do you see
um
this bullet that tells us
that uh Sergeant Tetra Was preparing
this concept of operations based on the
totality of the information that we're
getting from the Ops but more
importantly intelligence that would
support a systematic and save action
plan to dismantle the entire protest
zone so does this also refer to
something you told us earlier about not
doing things block by block correct but
to have start to finish of the entire
protest so that's that's correct sir
um
if I could take you to the next document
I believe this is your notes OPP four
zeros1792
so this is uh still February the 10th
and if we go to page 28
the time I'm looking for is
1925. there we go you have a telephone
call with uh looks like Deputy Harkins
and um
there's a ref can we make the look at
more of the page oh there there we go I
think uh go down a little bit please
obstacles with Ops still
can you read this these are your notes
right hops goes with Ops still exists at
the chief level however we're uh working
effectively with his Rank and file
so first of all why are you saying that
there are still obstacles at the chief
level well we're at this point we still
don't have have their plan
uh it's it's was a frequently uh
frequent made request to get what they
had uh to get access to their people
and the replies were all were waiting
for the chief
and the second part where it says we're
working effectively with the rank and
file yes
um who are these Rank and file everyone
from uh uh their their command team
their uh strategic command Deputy Fergus
uh uh Ferguson uh Chris rayom of those
that were sent to our our unit uh to
assist with uh with the planning we
didn't have their planners embedded with
us until some days later but we were
back and forth with them as well mm-hmm
if we go to the next day now so uh on
same these are your notes but we go to
page 32 please
and the time I'm looking for is 12 30.
so there are two points being made here
um
you maybe perhaps you can read those
better yeah so the first point says we
don't know what resources are deployed
here before and Beyond any request that
we have made we have been coordinating
and this was uh this this this dot
bullet is in the essence in reference to
silos you know others are doing
something we all need to be out of those
silos if we're asking for something
you're asking for something are we
asking for the same thing we need to
break those down uh it was a constant
pressure we were asking for a lot of
resources here so we needed to ensure
that we were effective in our requests
right the second bullet says anything
sent to the oppoc from the Chiefs
executive office can we get that please
and and those were some requests that
the chief had made so can we just please
get access to what requests have been
made what replies have been received uh
he just said E2 is very frustrated I
asked if if the chief's executive
officer was look looking after resources
he advised that he was working on
getting that information for me okay
now on that day February the 11th you
also attended a meeting with the with a
group the integrated Planning Group
that might have happened actually
earlier that day
and I want to take you to the document
the minutes of that meeting is a
document provided by the OPP so
opp40s 1837.
and I want to take you to page five
near the top
oh no this is not enough memory
maybe while
oh there we go okay so if we can go to
page five please
[Music]
um
right so there's a reference to
something you said at that meeting uh
we're here to build a plan to support
our partners but we have no information
can deploy when we don't know what we're
deploying to we have an ops plan but it
does not give us enough information to
deploy 500 officers without a more
comprehensive plan intelligence picture
will inform this and so on there's a
reference to 500 officers tell us more
about that
uh
back on our February 9th meeting I think
it was Sergeant or staff sergeant
LeBlanc from the Ops did provide us a
bit of a breakdown in terms of their
plan and intersections what the numbers
they needed and that number was
516 if I'm not mistaken from the
February 9th meeting we were trying to
understand that we later learned that it
was based on a three-shift rotation most
organizations work on a two shift
rotation so the needs again I mentioned
earlier we corrected some of the math
but I it's around that number at that
time and that was based on their concept
without duties aside but based on their
concept of operations we would need
approximately not approximately they
would need 516 officers to main this on
a 24 7 cycle
see
now
let me take you to
your will say
at page six please
you notice that I'm taking you to lots
of documents sometimes these
contemporaneous records help to tell the
story
so if we go to page six at 16 45 so
scroll down a little bit please
so 1645 that's 4 45 pm and our team
presented our proposed plan to senior
command in the RCMP and the opp with
significant support this plan was a
detailed concept of operations for which
our team would build the entire Pou plan
however it still relied heavily on
inject from the Ops planning team now uh
I suppose that goes back to something
you told us earlier that you were
building on what was given you that you
saw you thought was inadequate for the
purposes of resolving the the protest
situation
and by this time at 4 45 you had
something to present to the senior
command what was that proposed plan
well it was it was the plan that we
actually executed uh in the end uh that
concept of operations was developed uh
at that stage and uh with a PLU plan
that was going to be very detailed uh in
terms of the number of resources that
were going to be needed uh which came to
fruition that same 800 number I
mentioned earlier
and we talked about everything from
communication
to
restoring trust and confidence in the
Ottawa Police to responding to the
narrative to change the narrative
because the narrative certainly was not
reflective of what was actually going on
the ground
what we could see on the ground uh so it
was it was that all-encompassing concept
of operation and plan to dismantle the
protests effectively uh start to finish
okay if we go further down uh on this
okay uh so you see the bullet that
starts with superintendent Lou and I
presented the plan at a high level to
her uh her referring to the the person
in the bullet before which is Deputy
Chief Ferguson
um you presented it to her and she
immediately voiced her full support she
preferred however that she be permitted
time to present it to the Chief and we
agreed to prepare and forward a slide
deck for her use which was completed and
that we could be available we would be
available uh regardless of time to
answer questions so you're making
yourself available to answer questions
uh but you're waiting for her to get an
answer from the chief is that your
understanding yeah so we presented it
and and and and and her response was
very very favorable which we felt good
about uh and uh I was prepared to go to
the chief myself if necessary uh but
based on the dynamic that we've been
seeing and the feedback you know we
trusted our judgment
and she felt that it would be get best
for her to present it it was you know it
was late into the evening uh about 9
30ish when we finally got a deck to her
uh hoping that we would get a response
probably not that night but certainly by
first thing in the morning now you you
may or may not know this but we heard
from deputy chief Ferguson yesterday
that she was actually off that day uh I
didn't know that you didn't know that I
I think I found out during the process
that she was but uh right but she still
spoke to you
always yeah
um so um so that was February the 11th
uh late at night and and then the next
day so we're going into February the
12th now
um
at 11 45 a.m on the 12th
um you place a phone call to Chief
slowly uh so the two had the two of you
had a conversation tell us about that
conversation please well if I could just
prior to that uh I mean I I put in the
sailing into points here but earlier in
the day I made an Outreach to see if
we've gotten any response back from
Chief slowly on the plan and uh and
whether or not be a good time for me to
call them and I was told it was an
ill-advised time to call because he was
in a meeting with I believe he was in a
meeting at the time with Bernier Rob
Bernier so I said well fine I left it
till a little later and yes then I did
make a phone call so it was a short
conversation right uh but I made that
call to him uh and uh you know when I
reflect on my notes uh and how quickly I
was writing I was it was contemporaneous
and that I was writing the note as I was
speaking with them
and uh yeah that was the context of the
conversation you know Trish got the the
slide deck have you had an opportunity
uh to take a look at it your thoughts on
it uh his concern was around what does
integration look like uh where do we fit
how does it fit in other theaters of
operation uh and whatnot and he really
felt that a follow-up meeting
uh would be beneficial
to answer some of those questions right
so uh once again we're at 12 o'clock on
that date uh open that we would be green
lighted to move ahead with it you know
kind of implementing uh the plan that we
were working on uh and uh we then
started preparing for uh this meeting
that we ultimately had later in that
date right but staying on this call for
the moment
um
so if we look at what is said in the in
the will say on the fourth line uh I
advise we were looking to work in a more
integrated fashion that ensured
resources were strategically placed
where needed that I had provided uh uh
deputy chief Ferguson with that plan
he advised he wasn't sure what was
agreed to yet as to how that integration
was to happen
so he suggested the call I want to ask
you um
if you have specific recollection about
what he said to you that day well I I
certainly have it from my notes and at
that time I was using the Scribe I mean
my notes are
can't get Beyond in your notes with an
event like this I had over 400 pages of
notes you would never catch up if you
weren't doing them live I wrote my notes
at the time has been my best tool my 36
year career to ensure that I capture the
essence of what was said uh and I'm
going to suggest that that is the tone
of the conversation
so this accurately captures yes it does
the nature of the conversation
um
so um if we go further down oh but by
the way uh So at around the time that
you are having this conversation with
the former Chief uh I suppose your other
members of your team uh were having a
conversation with superintendent Bernie
yes uh and uh what did you find out from
other members of your team about what
they spoke to Bernie about it's just
that we're good to go okay so they got
the message that they would get to go
while you were speaking to Chief who
asked for a further meeting or briefing
right so I I felt that maybe there's
well not me there was some obvious
obvious uh miscommunication going on uh
you know that we did actually require
that meeting with the chief I I'm going
to lean to the response that I got
directly from Chief slowly that a
follow-up meeting was required and that
follow-up meeting did occur with a
detailed overview of the plan
so uh uh I I just felt that maybe
superintendent Bernie Bernie
misunderstood or
it was obviously inaccurate right so if
we go further down uh that meeting that
that finally happened uh took place in
the afternoon so first of all at 1400 so
2 P.M
you plays a call to deputy chief Bell uh
upon learning that the former Chief
would like a briefing on the plan yes
and so you suggested a chief party you
suggested a 3 30 right yes and then at
304
you got a call from Deputy Bell who
apologized but said that the main the
meeting was has already started and
Achieve was insisting that it happened
now is that still your recollection yes
sir uh and then a few minutes later at 3
10
um you and I guess you joined when you
say we I assume it's you and the member
yeah members of your team the key
members of of our Planning Group uh
specifically I wanted the subject matter
expert to present the plan yeah I
introduced it and then at the subject
matter expert uh present the plan uh
Phil Lewis on the call I can't remember
exactly you without looking at the
meeting invites uh
so I like to ask you uh what you wrote
here at 1510 about the
third line down
um the end of the second line the tone
of the chief's comments during this
meeting was very troubling to the point
that I asked if the chief wanted my team
to leave the call to allow him to speak
privately with his team first he was
blunt and saying no he would get to us
momentarily what was this about
he was having discussions that were
separate and apart from our purpose to
be uh at that meeting
and it was really direct uh Edward
Edward down uh you could sense you could
feel the tension over the video link in
in the room
and we just felt that I mean Phil Liu
also spoke up we just felt that perhaps
it's not our time to be in this meeting
if you needed some privacy to deal with
his people and he said no I'll get to
you next he just so I'm getting to you
text and then eventually uh they got to
you and your will say tells us
that
there was a presentation of the slides
right yes and uh
so if we scroll down a little bit
the last sentence of this bullet
um
do you see key in the plan yep key in
the plan was reducing the protesters
footprint through compliance and that
ensuring safety above everything was
factored in at all stages so it looks
like when you set key some emphasis was
put on that point can you elaborate it
was I mean this obviously was a
significant event in our nation's
capital it was having a significant
impact on its residence on the policing
but we also uh were working hard to
ensure that uh what our actions do help
rebuild that trust and confidence in the
police
uh it goes back to our mission of
ensuring that safety is built into your
mission uh and that was a key component
for us we wanted to reduce the component
uh to the footprint of the of of the
protest Zone to the uh to the utmost
extent possible uh you know
when you talk to planners in major
events like this they'll say we're not
going to arrest our way out of this
we're not going to it's going to be
impossible so you have to look to
compliance and appeal to uh the better
census of people that are involved to
get them to want to voluntary exit the
zone and that was a key component of our
plan because we knew that from a
capacity perspective if we had to start
putting a bracelets on everybody there
we'd need 10 000 officers to do that so
we had to we had to put a plan in place
that was scalable but one that we could
accomplish with the resources that we
intended to bring
now um so this is a meeting between your
team and the ops command team Chief
slowly was obviously there who else do
you remember was present from the Ops
side uh I guess this event is a video
right we're on video I I do believe uh
his command team is Council was there
was Bernie there uh yes because Bernie
uh was very vocal and spoke up in
support of our plan okay so he was
supportive uh what about the former
Chief
oh he was he was there he was no no but
but sorry in terms of how receptive well
a few things happened during the uh the
presentation uh and and it speaks to
what I think integration and or UNIF
unified command brings to the table
about bring taking this off the
shoulders of one individual and
spreading it around and bringing the
collective expertise to bear on the
problem
uh but during the presentation uh Darwin
uttered a statement about single point
of failure
and I admittedly it kind of came out
that the chief was a single point of
failure it was not the intent it was
meant to show that you know because he
was darable very passionate about the
fact that all eyes are on you chief
what you do what you say Etc you are the
face of this for the Iowa Police Service
we're open to bring a plan to you so
that you said to you not you're not
going to be seen as a single point of
failure
uh the the chief responded and
understandably he responded very uh very
quickly that he was not the single point
of failure in this and he unless he had
confidence in what his team could do
he's not going to to support it or prove
it uh he went on a bit of a
a a talk in in that regard just to
explain I actually on behalf of our team
apologize because it was not the intent
of our being there that day our attempt
was to go there and walk away with uh
kind of uh support that we were unified
and let's get this done
so at the end of that afternoon meeting
um was anything agreed on
we still did not have a have an approved
plan we did not there was no uh implicit
explicit approval of the plan that day
that did not come until I'm sorry was
this the this was the 11th uh this was
the 12th that did not come until the
13th okay now
um if we go down on your will say to
page eight
um
there was a bullet that starts with we
that's right we had discussion
uh about integrating the command
location of CP or CP yeah command post
or even a command center right so this
is uh in reference to discussion about
where to set up uh the command post if
there is to be an integrated Command
right yes and uh and you said there's
some apparent momentum being gained with
a new IC what's the IC instant Commander
uh Rob Bernie okay so nothing was agreed
as of yet on the 12th but you were
sensing
apparent momentum from the new commander
who was Rob Bernie that's correct sir
um
and then
if we go down further I reviewed and
look yeah I reviewed
I reviewed and signed off of our detail
ops plan
by the end of the state and did so as
did the RCMP all that was required was
approval by Ops what do you mean by that
well we we had given them the plan
and we had hoped that they would approve
it uh again as supporters of the Ops uh
we were in a position to start action
you to plan without their approval okay
uh so let's go to the 13s
um the first bullet we still did not
have approval from Chief slowly yet in
Con in consult with OPP senior command
forger ahead with developing roles of
senior and strategic command and the
absolute importance of these roles in
support of the instant commanders could
you explain that to us and that's that's
one of the significant benefits of
Integrative commitment so the way that
we set it up we had a seniors table
which is Deputy Commissioners uh and
Deputy Chiefs uh with the Ottawa Police
Service we had our strategic command
which I then be after we went to kinetic
became a member of the Strategic command
uh with again with the RCP and the Ops
and then we add our our incident
commanders to three guys so the whole
goal there is to give them objectives uh
be a sounding board we're uh
we're able to effectively keep anything
and everything political out of it they
are able to strictly focus on operations
uh we're able to give them feedback we
pour it up Port down they're never
reporting jumping over a rank they're
reporting to us and we're updating the
seniors table to ensure that they're
aware of everything that's going on and
the progress that we're making with
their daily objectives mm-hmm so you
were forging ahead at this time even
though there wasn't a final approval yet
but we our team remained incredibly
optimistic throughout this and in spite
of the adversity that we faced at times
and I mean I'd like to say this because
I think it's important to be said uh
there was still amazing collaboration
and support to get things done uh
everybody in Ottawa from the chief dial
wanted this to be over
and we wanted we were with them in that
right so there was a lot of tremendous
work and we at no time did we just do a
full stop and say well until we get
approval there's nothing else we can do
there was tons more that we could do so
we never stop from day one until I left
there on the 27th or 28th whatever it
was of February so by 350 that day it
appears as though your optimism was
justified because
you receive a call from Incident
Commander Bernier
um
who was accompanied by
uh
by the major critical instant Commander
Springer and then if we go down to
bullets sub bullets you see that yes the
plan is approved right yes so he
approved it as the instant Commander was
entitled to do and then at 605 PM that
day if we go down further
uh you discussed the above with uh
deputy chief Ferguson she advised that
she fully agreed with Bernie's authority
to sign off that we were good to go was
that accurate it's accurate I made that
call because of concerns and all partner
organizations that
we don't have approved from the chief
yet which is what we have been expecting
all along uh so that call got made to
deputy chief Ferguson and following that
call I-40 was completely confident we're
going in we're moving in so with both
Bernier and Ferguson
confirming uh the authority to sign off
was that sufficient for you on the 13th
I accepted it moved on and I remember
telling my boss uh are we certain the
chief is on board I'm good with that I'm
moving that I've got someone I've got to
sign document my hands uh I'm moving
forward right so there was optimism as
of the 13th but as we read on uh in your
will say
um it appears that on the 14th the next
day there were still a few more issues
to to iron out so I want to take you
first to um
so page nine
um
February 14th the bullet that starts
with key issues do you see so scroll up
yeah that's right key issues dealt with
through the day related to Ops need to
have their lawyer approve the plan which
was understood based on everything they
had been going through however was
unusual in the context of a lawyer
approving an operational plan now we
spoke about this a little bit and during
our interview you clarify that perhaps
approval was not the best term and you
said maybe review was a better word
could you explain that please well I I
challenge this a couple of times with
some other people can you help me out
here can you intervene can you you know
give me some better context
and I know that Chris ryom made a call
to the lawyer and and that's what came
back well no I'm not approving the plan
I I've been asked to review it before
it's actioned uh
in my view however as much as approval
may not be the right word to use if a
plan cannot be action before it's
reviewed
then it's not approved
okay so that's the first issue on the
14th yes another issue uh that you spoke
about is if we go down the page please
the bullet that starts with furthermore
furthermore it was determined throughout
the state that Incident Commander
Bernier was being pulled away
continuously to brief his chief and this
was creating trustration within our
Planning Group especially as it related
to the POU component I tactfully
addressed this concern with the Ops how
did you tactfully addressed it I just
told them we needed we he is critical
absolutely critical to this operation he
is the key decision maker a key instant
commander and he needs his his input is
absolutely unequivocally required
especially as we were looking at the PLU
plan which was the Crux of our plan to
dismantle the protests he was absolutely
vital to his success and and needed uh
so obviously I I was the person that
often went to Ops to have discussions
but throughout my time there I would get
the feedback from the different planning
components that we need access to this
we need access to this can we make this
up so I was a guy trying to work her way
around any barriers that we were we were
facing and I know that the lead planners
who had a tremendous trust and
confidence in just said we need him and
he's being pulled away again
we need them back here as ASAP if we're
going to put this together
his input is critical we can't spend
hours and hours developing a tactical
solution that the instant Commander
can't support
so those are the first two issues there
was a third issue if we go up the page
I want to take you to the bullet that
starts with while it was established
there we have it while it was
established that all key commanders
would be kept in the loop it was learned
that the mayor of Ottawa had engaged
with the protesters and negotiated them
to all move to Wellington Street and
that Ops made some decision on action
so um and then the next bullet says that
Incident Commander Bernier briefed you
at around six uh just after six o'clock
uh that due to the mayor's decision it
was a good time to take positive action
uh on those who stayed outside of
Wellington now in your interview with us
uh to describe uh this action plan as
uncharacteristic of Bernie why did you
say that it's just that we
he was well aware of the overarch he
planned that we had created for them
that would systematically dismantle the
protest Zone
and to go back to the chunk by chunk
dismantling would require additional
resources and you knew that
we challenge Bernie on the plan uh but
we brought key members of the team into
a PLT Intel uh Pou they actually
supported it so it wasn't like
we don't want to do this okay now now we
have a plan and we're going to pivots we
need to adjust
so are we all on the same page as where
we're going and we ultimately it did not
happen what did not happen the the
action the action right and I I'm
wrestling my brain I do believe it it
relates to a resource reliability from a
Pou perspective so this is the Tactical
portion of our our of our operations
plan the PLU so ultimately it did not
occur either
uh because it was again it was contrary
to the plan the systematic plan that had
been proposed
but again when we put the team together
pou said yep we think it's doable uh if
it can resource PLT felt that they had
exhausted all that they could do with
this particular group uh and Intel gave
us nothing that would suggest that it
would be ill-advised to do so so it's
like okay we're good to go now now we
have to start resourcing and I do
believe it ultimately came down to
a resourcing issue why it did not occur
right so it would appear that all of
these issues on the 14th the first day
of the supposed integration caused you
sufficient concern that the early the
next morning
um you spoke to the opp commissioner
karik am I right
um sure which date sorry the next date
you said the next day yeah February the
15th 15th let me show you a document
that may help refresh your memory OPP
four zeros1785
at page 28 please
so this appears to be a phone call that
you made to commissioner karik where you
raise
some of these concerns
and about the unified command and you
ask for his intervention so if we go
down the page
I'm looking for
where it says is this page 28
I'm looking for the reference where it
says uh the elephant in the room so I I
reviewed those notes uh unfortunately uh
after retiring my notes all went back to
archives and I just got them back
yesterday so you you remember reading
that right I remember reading this but
this is not in reference to a
conversation with the commissioner it
might have been from an earlier
conversation but at that time I was in a
meeting with our broader group I was
called out for a conversation with the
commissioner in relation to uh
providing an update to the Ottawa Police
Services Board
it was a brief call out from from that
meeting I do re however recall talking
about my challenges right uh you know I
I have made statements through this that
publicly were integrated
but in reality we're still missing a lot
so we're truly not integrated until we
we reach all of these points uh we are
still at times working in silos so if
some if an accident is going to happen
if the broader group who's planning for
resources to support it is not aware of
it it just makes it difficult to action
any type of plan so you might have just
anticipated my question because I was
going to ask you for the contacts where
this conversation took place and to
explain uh this statement that you
apparently made to uh commission
commissioner karik the elephant in the
room
is
can you read that to us it's not my
writing so I oh yeah my scribe broke
around here uh
the elephant in the room is everything
we have been
we have done they have done so far have
been blocked by the Ops Chief so these
are notes
um that attribute uh things that to you
things that you apparently said have you
did you say this conversations yes that
you know we we were in a an intense
planning meeting that morning because we
got our approval the day before like
we're we're good to go uh we were in a
significant meeting when I got called my
phone started ringing and I did not
answer it uh after multiple times and
finally I got the nod that you know
the commissioner needs to speak with you
ASAP can you so I let exit me and I left
my scribe out the meeting and I went and
had a separate meeting with the
commissioner and two deputies
and it's in different notes so when my
scribe was with me I took another
notebook and I took my own notes so
there's other notes right that overlap
the exact same time here
so in that context you asked for his
intervention
I you know recall like because I knew
that they had a relationship certainly
much more significant than mine I I only
I met Chief slowly at a swearing Inn uh
for the uh for this job uh and at a
conference once I believe but I really
did know him like the commissioner did
and I just thought if you have any
influence that you can talk with it so
we can move things along please please
do so uh and again it's based in
fairness to Chief slowly it is now based
on how things have gone and and what I
mean told that it's you know we're
waiting for the chief on this we're
waiting for the chief on that we have to
wait for the chief on this so I'm just
asking you know there's something we can
do to intervene please let's do it so we
can move this thing along
everybody on the team at a goal you get
out of out of Ottawa as quickly as we
could but doing so safely and
efficiently with a plan that would end
these protests right
so um so that was the the morning of the
15th uh as we know later that day
um the former Chief was signed uh and in
your interview uh with us you said that
the implementation of the February 13th
plan moved more quickly after chief
slowly's resonation uh what did you mean
by that moving more slowly I'm moving
more moving more quickly it's
it was just
that you know it resigned uh and it was
like let's go
everybody from Ops we're ready to go and
we just fully implemented everything
that was in the plot
okay and
there were still barriers I mean we
still had our issues I I don't want to
think that that I don't want anybody to
think that it was just Chief slowly we
had issues right throughout the
deployment uh in Ottawa that we we
wrestled to the ground but you know once
that happened for example the meeting
that I was called to go to with the
board also got canceled so that freed up
my time
to put Focus where it needed to be
now uh in my remaining time uh I hope I
have another I believe I have another 15
minutes
so in my roommate remaining time I want
to ask Focus your your attention a
little over 17 minutes oh that's it's
very good news indeed
um
so um
now the we've been speaking about the
February 13th plan
um
and that was the one that you and Lou
and Bernie approved
um and then as I understand it the
integrated Planning Group continue to
work with the Ops to develop that plan
until it was finalized on or around the
17th is that right correct and between
those dates the 13th and the 17th
something happened on the 14th which was
the invocation of the emergencies act
correct so I want to ask you now about
um like can you confirm whether the
final plan of February the 17th
contemplate the use of any powers or any
measures made available under the
emergencies act yes it did
sorry it did it did incorporate and tell
me about that well like every plan one
of the things that every operational
plan considers is your people our people
are our absolute most valuable asset
that we have in the operational plan
it's important that we have information
and inform them of of everything so we
ensured that our officers were aware of
the the piece of legislation that
Parliament had given us and to use it to
the back of our ability
now uh during your interview with us uh
in the summer uh and I guess uh in
September as well
um you said the the group had a lot of
debate uh about these the the
authorities that the the ACT provided
um and so on but
um did the police in Ottawa ended up
uh needing uh the emergencies act to tow
vehicles
no explain to us why not well you know
if we didn't have the emergency staff
that would imply that we couldn't tow
vehicles we told Vehicles every day for
for different things we have laws under
the highway traffic act we have common
law authorities that we use on a regular
basis so uh we you know if if a vehicle
is used in the commission of the defense
it's evidence or whatever the case may
be we have a various authorities to
seize and or remove or tow that vehicle
so we did not need the emergency stock
we also we had legislation another
province that also assisted us when it
comes to Towing and removing removing
permits and cvors and impounding
vehicles but again
we did not explicitly need those
authorities to tow a vehicle
and you also said that the police would
have managed to put an end to the
protest without the emergencies act they
would have done so within the timeline
that the cell was contemplating before
the federal government declared an
emergency could you elaborate on that
please well I think it just says what it
says uh our Opera operational plan when
we put it in place we did not have those
authorities uh it did not suddenly turn
us on a reels that we had to change a
lot we just added it to the plan it
helped I'm not going to say that it was
not useful it it certainly uh it
provided us with some authorities
relating to toll relating to perimeters
relating to preventing people from going
into the Red Zone Etc
but we could have done that anyway
so in your view was the emergencies act
necessary
to end the protest in Ottawa
well I I I that's a lot of question I'm
a police officer uh Parliament gives us
legislation we don't make legislation
they provide it to us and we use it to
the best of our abilities they gave us a
piece of legislation to use we were
thankful for it and we use it to the
best of our abilities to to uh to
incorporate in our plan
and in your view was there a police
solution to the demonstrations a police
solution yeah policing Solutions there
was a solution and we we reached that
solution we we had some help with the
emcpa the Emergency Management civil
protection act regulations that we have
at the Province and the emergencies act
but uh in my humble opinion we would
have reached the same solution with the
plan that we had without either of those
pieces of legislation
in within around the same timeline yes
okay is there anything else that you
want to tell the commissioner that I
haven't yet asked you
I don't think so sir thank you very much
okay thank you
so uh
Council for uh
former Chief slowly please
I'm Tom Curry
please thank you
um
Chief party the the events that you
became involved in
the first week of February I think I
think the eight yes sir
um
unprecedented in your experience
absolutely one of a kind sir and
unforeseen
um by anyone in your command in the
Northeast region at the time that the
Convoy protesters who came through the
Northeast
traveled
through there is that fair no I I would
say that in my role and my operations
superintendent who prepared an ops plan
which was largely traffic based but in
partnership with our the municipal
Municipal Police Services that the
Convoy went through uh to end in the
reports what we were hearing
we kind of felt that Ottawa was kind of
in for it right and in your
in your command at that time
um
did the opp have
um
an opportunity for you to share your
conclusions or
what was going on in the Northeast as
the Convoy came along well all of that
was reported up there was a major
Incident Commander overseeing it as it
went through North West Region into my
region PLT was engaged heavily uh in in
with with the protesters they were
traveling in vehicles uh
you know for example they split at
Highway 11 and 17. the weather in the
North was terrible uh the heavy trucks
came down 17 the smaller Vehicles were
we felt was safer the weather was less
severe because of the lake effect was
Superior uh they went via Highway 11. so
the Convoy split there uh
everything I I mean I was not deeply
involved in fact I was in Sault Ste
Marie Ontario uh arrived there 7 38 pm
at night
for business the next day because at
that stage I had a team that looked
after him and I trusted that I had a
plan that ops plan that the op
superintendent has signed off on Intel
LED I'm good to go just keep me informed
if there's any difficulties I was doing
my regular business
I remember distinctly because it took me
15 to 20 minutes to turn into my hotel
because the Convoy was coming through
and
okay with the steady stream of tractor
trailers so I couldn't get turned
and so that if I follow that you you
were in the Sioux your team is running
the Convoy
observing the Convoy presumably you had
you had squad cars marked Vehicles
unmarked vehicles in the presence of the
Convoy as they came into and exited your
region yes sir and and passed along
whatever intelligence
could be gathered about the scale of the
protest and those PLT interactions we
did but it didn't work that way sir I
mean this is a major event for the opp
so there's an instant commander in
irelia everything is being fed up
through Logs with PLT we're seeing it
but we're not having to report it
because really is actually getting it
understood so does Aurelia well two
things thank you for that two things
Northeast region would never have on
that basis been in contact with anybody
at Ops at that stage no sir
what what north east region does is
feeds that intelligence into Aurelia a
Central Command
is that true yes sir and then and then
would it be in your experience would it
be expected that if there was something
to be gained
um from that intelligence that should be
shared with a partner Police Service
here Ottawa that it would be passed
along to say something Troublesome your
way is coming
yes but I I mean I didn't learn
something to trouble if someone's coming
based on them coming through my region I
learned that from the briefings that we
had okay got it and is the are the
briefings that you had
what we understand the same information
that you had if we read the hinden
reports generally yes I mean and
occasionally we participate in the calls
just to get and largely it was my office
superintendents that would be engaged in
those uh meetings briefing me
um you know we widely it was widely felt
that you know they're going to Ottawa
for the long hauler they're going into
just because of what they're looking to
accomplish
we knew nobody was going to give in to
those sorts of Demands like ending the
ending the uh the the man Health
mandates for the country and and
shutting down government or having
people from government removed
but that was just not going to be
accomplished so
it made the uh uh in your in in your
view
um the PLT effort to engage protesters
with that agenda
um well first of all it it was
unsuccessful wasn't it
uh in my way sir well the PLT didn't
negotiate the departure of protesters
until the moments before the
uh the public Order Plan your plan
that's correct okay got it
and
the uh at the time that they came
through the north east region your team
would have been in touch presumably with
the next region over which I guess is is
this region the east region east region
uh yes
I mean in touch again we're one
organization so it's it's it's not like
we're separate organizations here it's
pretty seamless right the PLT there'll
be and offs these are people that work
together the Intel all again greets are
people that work together so my my point
is my region wouldn't continue on to
here it'd just be a handoff
kind of uh to the next team and on my
team go back to their regular business
understood and you yourself personally
had no contact with anyone in the Ottawa
Police Service until the moment that you
got a call from from your Deputy
Commissioner that is correct sir okay
now uh Ops for a minute it's obvious
isn't it that they would not have had
on their own
with their own resources a policing
solution they needed help that's fair
and they have you've told us that you've
been part of providing help to the Ops
over the years as has the RCMP yes sir
and as have other Municipal Police
Services that's correct and you've
worked with that group you told us on
other occasions and that would be the
universe of resource pools of resources
would that be right that's fair yes
assuming that we're not going to go
another step into into military aid to
civil power through the military just
sticking with Police Services it's OPP
RCMP Municipal Police Services and I
suppose I should add the Parliamentary
Protective Service yes sir
and the the resources that they
um
needed
were the subject of estimates provided
by the Ops through Communications from
Chief slowly to commissioner karik and
to uh uh commissioner lucky among others
did you ever see the
the spreadsheet of of the resource
request that had been made to
commissioner karique for example
I don't think I saw it before my arrival
there I know we discussed it because I
know I distinctly recalled being broken
down right even down to civilian members
and analysts right and uh he crime
analysts a whole Myriad of of resources
so I do recall seeing the list maybe we
may have discussed it uh on that
February 9th meeting we suggest a lot of
things in a short period of time but uh
yes I was aware and the objective when a
police serve and I appreciate it it's
unprecedented so you you have not seen
previously a municipal police force that
has been overwhelmed by protesters as
this one was
uh no that's fair and so uh the the main
the main objective from the from the
um perspective now of an Ottawa Police
Service would be to get the help it
needs
to restore order in the community
yes
and I think you learned probably from
your briefings and you observed
firsthand that the situation was uh
quite grave here in Ottawa during the
time of the of that protest that's a
fair statement um there obviously
residents were in distress and and the
the city was quite in its core uh quite
paralyzed it was I mean I I have friends
in the downtown core that live in the
downtown core and reported to me the
devastating impact that it had on their
ability to sit and think in their own
living room right and that's to the
police service that when we speak about
a service that is overwhelmed uh the
best they could do with their own
resources was I think I saw in one of
your notes was that they could maintain
control of the perimeter yes and they
were not possessed of this of sufficient
resources to mobilize any kind of
operation correct now when the
circumstances
uh are those circumstances
um would you would you agree with me
that the top priority
for that Police Service is to get help
yes
and uh to to try to reach out to the
policing Partners OPP RCMP the ones that
we talked about yes yes and that
um and to Define try the your the best
you can to define the resources that you
need yes and uh you are in the uh
understandably from the perspective of
the Ottawa Police Service they need to
know what resources are available from
other Municipal Services OPP or RCMP
correct yes
now the
the resource uh demand at uh here in
Ottawa was matched by demands in other
communities we know including Windsor
that's correct sir and I I don't know uh
it probably doesn't matter but the
Windsor blockade of the Ambassador
Bridge took a rose following the Convoy
protest here in Ottawa it did was the
what to your knowledge was were was the
opp able to prevent that blockade or did
it try to prevent that blockade
I I mean I was briefed obviously that
because it was going to impact our
request here in Ottawa uh I I can't
speak to the specifics of uh what was
attempted prior to sorry okay that's all
that no that's fine uh but it but once
the blockade in Windsor was
was established uh OPP resources were
required there as well yes and at an
overlapping period here with the best
perspective Ottawa okay now
um
a couple of things if I if I can the the
just as to resources and operations you
told us about a plan that was reviewed
it didn't go ahead but a plan that was
reviewed here in Ottawa by the Ops to go
block by block uh through the through
the uh the protest and you favored a
one-time one operation start to finish
right correct
um am I right that that as it was
defined at the time it was defined that
the Ops team had devised a block by
block strategy at because that reflected
the resources that they had at that time
does that make sense uh yes because
that's that's that's exactly how it was
portrayed in that uh February 9th you
take a jump by chunk understanding it
will be resource intensive but right one
kind of one one section at a time that's
fair and resource demands
um resource requests I think you told us
that you uh took action when you against
a you made a resource request against
what you said I think was a a concept of
plan or a concept of strategy concept of
operations concept of operations that's
a little less than a plan is that that's
you know you know all components of what
you're bringing into your plan
and you've got your smes now off
building those components but now we
know where we're going with that concept
with that with that with that skeleton
our concept was much more detailed than
the one that they provided us right
because it did break it down in terms of
the teams that we're going to need to to
fulfill these Concepts
understood they had a concept of plan
yes you had a more detailed one correct
they had a plan you the integrated team
brought a more detailed one correct now
a couple of quick things if I can then
just about the turn to the plan for a
second could I please show you a
document it's a man registrar Ops
uh three zeros one zero four seven zero
please
I think you've seen this
uh Chief party
um
this is I hope I've got it could you
scroll down
please
ah there it is uh so you're copied on
this so did you see the first email it's
from
um Bill Luke philu and I'm afraid I
don't know his rank I'm superintendent
superintendent Lou thank you he writes
to you and mainly to deputy chief acting
Ferguson
and
do you see this he says
um
find attached PowerPoint deck that
outlines the plan we have been working
on
obviously this plan originated with your
plan which We examined bolstered and
strengthened
Fair very fair sir okay and that was
your approach and this email is just to
put proper contacts I in my evidence in
Chief I mentioned we've reached out to
Trish Ferguson on that evening
and we follow up with the deck this was
the email attaching the slide deck to
help her explain the plan to the chief
got it thank you
um and I just want to show you one other
document just to see if please could I
better register a switch out to Ops I
think this one has four zeros nine six
three nine
uh so this is 10 10th of February
uh to the long list there mostly it's uh
this is your own your own service and it
looks like uh
other services other Municipal services
do you see that yes sir and the reline
if we could just scroll down please
as a follow-up to our earlier call many
police agencies have expressed an
ability to support Ottawa Police Service
with Frontline boots on the ground
our integrated planning cell composed of
or mobilizing resources and support
could I please ask any agency
which has officers you can deploy to
support the plan to please respond
to that OPP email address with the
number you have available
when available and for how long you sent
that
yesterday and this email was what we
call the big 12 the Big 12 police
agencies in Ontario with a couple
additional ones that had stepped up
small agencies that actually stepped up
and were routinely supplying Ops with
resources and you were able to send out
that call for help
um
for Resource Assistance on the 10th of
February prior to the finalization of
your plan after you had your concept
absolutely you know from a planning
perspective when you start thinking
about your concept of operations and
where you're needing to take it you need
to be needless need need to be thinking
about how you're going to Resource that
plan and we knew that no one
organization in the province had the
capacity to Resource that plan so it's
like kind of putting the bug in
everybody's here as early as possible
that we're coming we need
indeed and that when you looked back at
what or looked at what you were dealing
with when you got to Ottawa am I right
that that's the kind of thing Chief
slowly had been trying to do up until
that time
it's fair I mean I I hadn't watched
closely I know he I I saw some of the
media repeated uh asked for a resource
absolutely got it thank you could I show
the witness please uh OPP
I think four zeros one three eight nine
just get your help if I could uh Chief
party with a couple of other things
this is a situation report
um
[Music]
maybe can I see page eight I'm certain
that I I might have the wrong number if
that's the case I'll take this down but
could I see page eight please counselor
there are only five pages I got the
wrong one all right I'll I'm going to
come back to it I I if I unless I'm
whisked off the stage can I speak for a
minute about what you told us about to
Chief slowly there no no doubt is there
uh Chief party that
uh Chief slowly had the hardest job in
the country during the time he was the
chief during this time I would agree sir
the city was under siege and the service
was under siege yes sir
did you know anything at all when you
got there about the circumstances of
Chief slowly's tenure as the as the
chief of police
no sir
thank you
um and any difficulties that he he faced
here in Ottawa either with the with
issues that arose
because of his race or issues that arose
because of his inability to to to
[Music]
um
to to lead the change that he had been
asked to lead no sir
um
clearly he had at the time that you
observed it a very difficult
relationship with his command team
it's fair and I and others but the low
the the senior command
um he you agree he you observed during
the time that you were here or maybe
even before you got here there were
political issues that were raised about
Ottawa Police Services handling of this
crisis yes sir uh both at the ministry
of the solicitor general with with some
controversies about what resources were
here or not right yes and and at the
level of the federal government uh with
uh with uh political uh leaders making
statements about what was going on in
their City that's correct all of which
added to the complexity and challenge
here for him absolutely
um did you also I take it towards the
end of your time here you became aware
that the Police Services Board and the
municipal Council had expectations of
Chief slowly and the service that they
would tell them that there was a plan
and in indeed be briefed upon it yes and
that's how you were you were asked to go
and you checked in with your
commissioner to see if you should uh no
I actually just flooded denied it's uh
not going and then I was asked and the
follow-up from the commissioner uh in
light of the Morton report from G20
right uh you know the board has certain
roles responsibilities and he felt it
would be appropriate for me
to make a presentation to the board in
light of those key responsibilities the
board has which I understood uh and that
uh but again
that plan that could only be done with
Chief Floyd's approval understood and
it's unusual in your experience to to be
to to brief political actors on
operations plans to to the detail that
we were seeing absolutely very unusual
and so
um
a couple of other quick things if I can
were you aware that a member of Chief
slowly's uh servants the Ops contacted
superintendent Morris
um about
the his attendance at the briefing
no sir
um without without
telling Chief slowly that he was going
to do that you didn't know anything
about that yes sir
uh were you aware as to how the senior
command had divided uh the its
responsibilities here for the for this
event and particularly did you know the
chief deputy chief rather Ferguson was
responsible for the plan
uh yes I I knew I mean she was the
person that I dealt with pretty much
exclusively
uh after I arrived in Ottawa in terms of
any when I had contentious issues or
things to deal with or questions about
getting the plan approval it was it was
the deputy chief Ferguson and that
deputy chief Bell was responsible for
the intelligence lead uh I don't know if
I was aware I've certainly learned that
he was uh but certainly not aware I mean
I I had met Chief Deputy Chief Bell uh
at that initial meeting and until he
became interim Chief I don't think I had
two words with him
got it thank you I think I've I've now
help from my colleague commissioner I've
got the number I was trying to show the
witness I think it's three zeros uh
Madden reserve one eight three nine
please
bear with me uh Chief party I hope
if this is not it I
I'll
okay here we go February 10th just to
orient you this is uh these are minutes
of an integrated planning cell meeting
um you talked talked about it I think
earlier just uh the attendees am I
correct just stopping there all of the
attendees are from
um OPP RCMP or other non-ops police
services correct
and it was just scroll down if we if we
could
um
to page
two
um
and
in a little bit further if we could
please
okay just uh uh stop there for a second
one of the things that you were asked by
by my friend Mr always whether thought
had been given to taking over the
leading this and and taking over the
um from the police of jurisdiction and
and I think you indicated that no that
was not that was not the plan
well I think for that to happen there'd
have to be a request from the chief and
the chief made it very clear that that
wasn't going to happen understood there
was some suggestion within the group on
the 10th you'll see from
um from the RCMP
um
create to support the uh just up the uh
just as just read you'll read just stop
there thank you
um
um
we need to slowly come back there was
suggestion from the RCMP that
that maybe you should take over and
you'll see it says in a forgotten his
rank Tetro is
so we're are we the bottom here yeah Ops
saves face on this the Ops in its own
words is on its knees we remove Ops from
this slowly over the course of four to
six or eight shift Cycles they're
exhausted they go back to work and
police the rest of the city we're going
to build a police detachment
incident policed by another police
service within your city same as a
terrorist plane crash and so on just uh
they then scroll down you said the Ops
is listening to their tactical advisors
this is brainstorming
RCMP I'll use instead of the word Tetra
but presents a viable plan is that the
only plan no is it an option that should
be given consideration absolutely I
won't go through the rest of it but at
this meeting consideration was given to
thinking about replacing Ops so I think
context is very important here sure and
the context is here it starts with
they're on their knees
we witness officers burnout and just
just walking out of getting up walking
there to meetings saying I'm done I
can't take this anymore
they were burning out daily we saw their
senior executive Chief slowly the stress
was very evident on all of them that
perhaps they focused their efforts on
policing the city
we'll build a plan for the event they're
still going to be involved but just
remove them from the equation to allow
them to build some strength because
quite frankly they were we saw the
burnout we saw the stress we saw the
anxiety right
one of the it is it fair to say that one
of the things that may have eroded trust
between the integrated planning cell
team and and chief slowly and maybe
others was the idea that there that
maybe there was a plan to replace LPS
there was never certain plan to replace
so yes and we we never talked we had
lots of brainstorming sessions you know
we'd start every meeting by saying
listen we need everything on the table
you have an idea let's consider it uh we
we there was nothing often
thank you page eight of this document
please
um this is it just uh just shifting
gears for one second
Chief party help us if you could with
the issue of uh Windsor there's some
references here to to the demands on uh
just scroll down I think please
there we go uh RCMP Pou will get to
Windsor tomorrow
OPP has to Pivot if Windsor is a
priority
they have to Pivot translation or the
point being made that
Windsor is going to take resources away
from
of course from Ottawa well I think in
context is everything
the support that I and my team receive
never change in terms of we'll get what
we need
but going back to my very first meeting
with Ottawa Police
we were very clear that we're looking at
this not just at the local level we're
both provincial in the National level
and we have to keep our eyes on all that
what's happening in Coots could have an
impact here what's happening in Manitoba
could have an impact here so we as a
team wanted to be alive to that when I
the word pivot became very instrumental
throughout the deployment it was used a
lot we had to Pivot daily on things
because our plan needs to be able to
Pivot and adjust to uh to impact to it
so in Windsor app and we needlessly knew
that okay
we're not going to get all that
is available because Windsor is going to
need some
kind of at Windsor it became not the
priority it became a priority understand
in my view Ottawa never change in mind I
did not say okay I'm going to put my
folks on Windsor thank you very much for
letting me know about Windsor now let's
get back to what our problem is here our
Focus still remain solely I don't
understood scroll down a little bit
um last last bullet point on this uh the
words attributed to you there's a uh
last last Point uh RCMP advises 60 hotel
rooms are available in Vanier
and that's going to counter the fact
that 60 uh Pou members had to go to
Windsor you had the rooms but you didn't
have the Personnel uh because of because
of course for the reasons you've given
Windsor required them
um one thing I I forgot to to ask you
when I talked for a moment about Chi
slowly and his circumstances I think you
told us that he was unable to attend one
of the meetings he had a different
commitment am I right that that
commitment was a risk threat assessment
against him personally yes he and his
family is I I understood it to be not
just and his family as well I mean
uncalled for but there were threats
against them right and that was a a
death threat yes sir there were other
death threats that came to your
attention Municipal politicians
presumably yes many others
um it then could I just ask then finally
uh the PLT
um
PLT
in in your experience with PLT there
have had uh success
and they have had and they have been
unable sometimes to bring protests to an
end on their own without further police
action
well we have seen PLT use in a myriad of
situations over the years I'm a big fan
of the mandalas I think it's obvious uh
we've seen them have complete success
but depends we use PLT and the opp and
our daily operations now right in my
region for example I had a PLT officer
in every one of my detachments
plus I had a full-time component in
addition to the designated PLT in every
one of my detachments they handle
contentious issues right down to a
protest as a neighbors between two
people and resolve Lots
you know resolution if you're saying
complete resolution there's a massive
process and PLT alone was able to
resolve it that's a fair statement that
doesn't happen often but they are an
instrumental part of the solution to get
a protest to a workable size
that allows us to effectively dismantle
it understood thank you thank you thank
you commissioner
thank you uh this may be a good time for
an afternoon break I think it's since
we're going to go uh for a
certainly uh an hour better uh so I'll
take a 15-minute break and uh we'll come
back if that's okay sure thank you
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
the commission is reconvened the
commission on April
okay
um we're back are you prepared to
proceed okay next I'd like to call on
the Ottawa Police Service
foreign
my name is Jessica Barrow and I'm
representing the Ottawa Police Service
we heard earlier in the evidence that
the reason the integrated planning cell
was created was to assist Ops is that
correct that's correct
and you listed a few reasons that that
was the case but one of the ones that
you listed was to restore the Public's
confidence in the police is that fair
yes
and would you agree with me that the
loss of public confidence in Ops was
related at least in part to the Public's
perception of inaction by Ops yes
and that perhaps residents felt like the
unlawful behavior of protesters was
going unchecked by Ops yes
in response to that however you are not
a proponent of leading with enforcement
is that fair
no it's not fair it's not fair okay I'm
opponent to Leading a measured approach
if enforcement is a part of that
then absolutely uh however I think
you're attributing that maybe to my
comment that you're not going to arrest
your way out of this
uh I could find 100 police leaders that
would say the exact same thing right so
I guess my point was was that it's not
the place you start
is that fair it can be a part of
strategic arrest or always a critical
part of a lot of these types of
operational plans
but we that alone is not going to solve
this problem right and your goal I think
you explained this earlier the goal is
to try to negotiate your way out prior
to engaging in enforcement and less
necessary the the negotiation is a part
of the plan if you look at our plan in
detail there's a time when negotiations
no and it calls for the next
has always graduated steps of
enforcement right in parallel to not
after parallel to the negotiations and
and whatnot that are going on fair
enough
um but because you are a proponent of
that integrated model of of negotiation
and perhaps enforcement where necessary
you are a huge promo proponent and I
think you've mentioned this earlier of
the value of PLT is that fair
yes they have proven their value uh over
and over in major events over the years
and uh I would see no reason why we
would not incorporate them in any type
of operational plan of this nature and
you are of the view at the time of your
arrival in Ottawa that Ops was not
providing a supportive environment for
PLT that's correct
I mean I I should point out I have
knowledge about obviously Ops background
they wrote the book on this stuff
they do it well
it just wasn't happening
fair enough and you uh
earlier in the commission hearings we've
heard about the national framework I
take it you're you're familiar with that
yeah
in the National framework favors the use
of PLT wherever possible to negotiate
correct absolutely
and so is it fair to say that the answer
in response to the loss of public
confidence wasn't necessarily to go in
right away and start enforcing is that
fair
it it could again be part of that
measured response it absolutely still
could be part of the measured response
where there's blatant offenses occurring
to deal with them absolutely but it
there's no one solution to this uh Gwen
and the force your way out of it I'm not
going to negotiate down the size of the
footprint absolutely a viable option
along with a measured approach on
enforcement fair enough so you would say
that at the very least any level of
enforcement that was that was happening
or ought to happen needed to happen in
tandem with PLT yes
and and for that reason obviously the
operational plan that ultimately was
agreed upon with superintendent Bernier
as the event Commander did involve the
Strategic uh deployment of PLT as part
of that correct yes
and in fact I believe you indicated in
your witness statement that the
integrated plan involved a vital PLT
communication and negotiation plan is
that correct that's correct
and that when you presented the cell's
proposed plan to Ops the key role of PLT
was actually specifically stressed
because the cell was concerned about the
lack of buy-in at Ops in relation to the
role of PLT is that fair uh it certainly
wasn't being used we were getting
information that PLT were in a tent
drinking coffee
and not out engaging with protesters
trying to have an understanding their
intentions uh whether or not there was
any room to negotiate to maybe move or
leave the area they were going to tent
freaking coffee
so they weren't being deployed in a way
that you felt was appropriate is that
fair uh I think the standard that the
standard would be I mean because you're
putting this that I felt this uh this is
a program that was in the opp that was
born out of the upper Washington Quarry
for example and and they have proven
their weight in goal over the years in
terms of the connection that they can
make with and trust that they can build
with protesters or or otherwise you know
so you can reach some common ground on
some issues if they can fix the issue or
resolve the issue that's a huge plus but
they have become a vital part I
mentioned in my my cross with Mr
slowey's Council we even used them now
with neighbor disputes
instead of taking the hard end of law
enforcement playing charges on both
sides maybe we can negotiate a
settlement here so that people can live
in a little bit of Harmony and it works
it brings about
Better Community safety all right so I
think part of what you're saying
um but you can correct me if I'm wrong
obviously is that in order for PLT to be
effective they have have to have the
autonomy to actually negotiate
effectively is that fair they have to
have the autonomy and but at the same
time they had to throw the commander's
intent they had them to understand
what that autonomy means what they're
being given right and uh in in this case
early on it is my view based on
everything that I heard
uh all the information that was provided
to me that they really did not have that
direction nor autonomy fair enough and
and you were of the view obviously again
correct me if I'm wrong but that the
reason PLT wasn't engaged in the way
that you're describing in terms of its
Effectiveness uh was because that Chief
slowly didn't believe in the PLT program
I I think it went beyond maybe Chief
slowly uh that that others felt that
it's time to get in there there's a lot
of pressure on them to take
action that is seen to be taken Fair PLT
is action taken that nobody sees right
in terms of you're talking about the
Optics of it the Optics of it and uh so
I I don't think it was just Chief slowly
I know that in my meetings with the
conversations with him uh there was uh
he had mentioned for example that they
didn't have this type of concept uh with
the Trump Police Service when he was
there uh and that it's totally he was
not overly as overly familiar with it as
we were we were told that negotiations
had simply failed right so it perhaps is
not that he didn't believe in it it may
be that he didn't understand
he certainly still talked about it and
understood where we're going with it
absolutely uh but but you know it was
our belief because he was they were
challenged by superintendent Abrams in
my being with them on the 9th of
February about PLT because we already
had it directly from PLT that they don't
have authorities they're not they don't
have autonomy they're not doing what
they do
and we were told simply that oh they're
used but it's failed and sorry who were
uh they told that I think that was uh
superintendent Patterson that said that
at that
and so ultimately when the integrated
plan was agreed upon with superintendent
Bernier and obviously with buy-in from
others at Ops
um there was an agreement that plta
played an important role uh in the
dismantling of of of the Convoy is that
fair well that I want to be careful
because that makes it sound like we
negotiated what goes into a plan no no
yes sir what we're talking about what we
built is is what I would consider in our
policing world right now for major
events and protests standard practice
to play practice in terms of the
engagement so there was agreement
because it's what we do
and it works it they they do provide
that layer of assistance
to get us to where we need to be when we
take kinetic action
okay
I want to talk very briefly about the
chain of command uh and have you assist
those of us that don't work in policing
to understand how the chain of command
Works
um so you would agree with me that
police services are paramilitary
organizations is that correct
I wish
you wish you agreed with me no I wish
they were they there was a time that we
absolutely did say that we were but we
we I think we lease Services have
largely moved away from being able to
characterize himself when I joined the
job we were paramilitary
would you agree with me there is a chain
of command but there is a chain of
commands Okay so however you describe it
that's the only only similarity that I
probably would agree with that's a chain
of command there is a chain of command
that one expects to follow correct
within a police service so however
that's described there is a chain of
command yes uh and that chain of command
requires that where an officer is
directed or ordered by a senior officer
to do something they're required to
follow the command that's correct and in
fact it is a misconduct offense under
the police services act not to follow a
command a lawful order correct yes
and in addition to that would you agree
with me that it would be considered
unprofessional to directly question the
directions of one's Superior in front of
partner agencies
that that's a that's a relationship
thing
uh I mentioned earlier about my team I
had Constable civilians up to chief of
my team
and they were given you know I need I
need your voice so yeah you have an
opinion I need you to tell me I'm wrong
so it depends on the environment and the
expectations of the leader fair enough
I want to talk a little bit about uh the
integrated command
so when the integrated planning cell
arrived in Ottawa its first activities
and we've heard about this already
involved meetings with Ops to get a
sense of where their plan stood is that
fair yes
and the integrated planning cell brought
with it a fairly significant amount of
planning expertise it's it
and you indicated with the exception of
you that these were experts in their
field is that correct that's correct
okay
and the goal of the integrated planning
cell was to work with Ops to work
towards a more robust overall plan yes
and we've heard throughout your
testimony and I'll use the word
criticism but perhaps you would
described otherwise but would it be fair
to say that there's some level of
criticism of the level of integration
Ops was allowing with your team at this
point in time when you arrived I think
criticism is probably fair I I ran
interference a lot on that very topic
to to actually you know as I mentioned
at one point in time publicly it was
announced we have integrated behind the
scenes I'm telling my folks but we're
not there yet you know integration means
they're actually working with us we're
no longer in silence we're actually
talking about where the direction that
we're going in and we had obstacles but
those obstacles were not just human
fair enough and uh we do know though
however that superintendent Bernier was
appointed as event commander on February
11th yes and although perhaps not the
integration level that you would have
liked there was an integrated command
Table after he came in correct it it
started it started the pausing work
started and yes and and that was born
out of uh you know I think the
commission is a reference to the uh
ncrcc uh down in Orleans uh Ottawa
Police Headquarters were at the knock we
have command posts various different
places that add to the complexities of
integration
ideally you want your seat your your key
key uh uh command positions to be
integrated and also have access to one
another and ultimately that does happen
Right Moves his group over and as our
team worked towards securing the right
position look right location at the RCP
headquarters that could house the type
of integrated uh team but we're talking
well into the whole 100 plus that would
need it on operations day for every
component of the plan we had to have a
rep there right and that takes time
obviously to assemble that number of
people
um and one of the things that
superintendent Bernier did when he was
appointed as event Commander was appoint
a deputy event Commander is that right
and that Deputy event Commander was
inspector Springer yes and he's from the
opp yes you I think I think he's retired
a retired member of the opp then perhaps
um
and and part of that integrated team
that was assembled and and evolved I
guess is what you're saying it was
Specialties from all different specialty
units as well as members from a variety
of different agencies is that right
correct
and you felt at this time I think you
indicated that even with superintendent
Bernier and the integrated table uh in
place at this time that there was at
least a perceived need for achieve
slowly to approve any kind of planning
is that fair it was still the that that
that perception amongst everyone right
down to my bosses call and asked me but
as he approved it I they understood that
Bernie had proved it but they asked if
he had and that was that follow-up call
I had with Trish Ferguson
and I trusted her and when she said
you're good to go
we went right and you know we talked a
little bit uh throughout this commission
hearing with various Witnesses about
this incident command system uh we know
that there's multiple iterations of it
but would you agree with me that
irrespective of which version we're
talking about that the chief's
requirement to sign off on an
operational plan is inconsistent with
that model is that fair
knowledge of but inconsistent with
approval yes correct
you indicated that your team met with
deputy chief Ferguson on the 11th uh to
present the plan that your team had
created is that right we did that over
phone I believe okay so there was a
meeting of some kind right
um and am I correct in saying that the
plan involves the creation of a unified
command yes
yes and you indicated I think earlier in
your testimony that Deputy T Ferguson
was was very supportive of that plan
very very supportive yes and you also
indicated that Ferguson was your primary
contact with the Ops at this time yes
and so would you agree with me that that
support that she indicated on February
11th was generally consistent with the
level of collaboration you saw from her
during your interactions with her yes
in fact in your witness statement you
referred to Deputy T Ferguson uh as a
voice of reason is that right
it's fair okay
and you also indicated in your testimony
earlier that by this time all of the
rank and file of Ops was working well
with your team is that right yes
and on the same day of Chief slowly's
resignation you would agree with me that
interim Chief Bell agreed with RCMP and
OPP to implement a unified command is
that correct that's correct those are my
questions thank you very much
okay thank you uh next uh call upon the
government of Canada
good afternoon check my time
um
you indicated in your oh yeah introduce
myself I'm sorry my name is donnaigard
I'm Council for uh Canada uh you
indicated in your evidence in Chief that
um
you police services including the opp
tow vehicles all the time you have the
authority to do that and I just want to
make sure that I'm understanding what
you're saying you're talking about the
authority to tow vehicles that's
something you have and you didn't need
the EA for that
but you don't or you didn't absent the
EA have the ability to compel tow truck
drivers to assist with that is that
correct that's correct
and that the use of uh tow trucks in
particular heavy tow trucks
was instrumental to the plan to clear
out the protest in Ottawa correct
unequivocally
and
the integrated
operation was not actually able to
obtain the services of such tow trucks
without the use of the EA the
emergencies act in this situation
correct uh that's not entirely correct
no so very early on in fact day one we
engage with our OPP uh
traffic services and Operational Support
command Deputy DeMarco her team that run
all of our traffic programs
uh we had a gentleman by the name of
Kurt Richardson I believe he's a
sergeant with the opp uh
everything told is expertise and he had
the relationships with MTO so they had
been working tirelessly behind the
scenes to build a plan and I do know
they had some 34 rigs lined up
there were ever some I I'm aware that
we're reluctant because of some
liability issues and the ACT gave that
support
um could I have a document number
o-n-t-50179 please
now you uh mentioned Kirk Richardson
that he's yes who was doing this and he
was made doing the organization with the
he was working with directly with uh MTO
right uh if we can just scroll down to
the first
email in the chain
so yeah uh just so we can see the
beginning so this is an email on
February 16th uh from the MTO
and uh
there's a number of recipients including
Mr Richardson you can see there
and if you can see
um in the first bullet point there it
says there were 13 heavy tow trucks
requested and support equipment 11 tow
trucks concerned confirmed so far from
three towing companies and they were
working on securing more so that was the
situation that I think if we scroll back
up at 119 on February 16th and then if
we continue to scroll up to the next
email
in the chain
I think at the bottom of the first page
we'll see the time of if you just so now
we're at five in the evening that same
day and uh there's a follow-up email
and if we can just
see there that it says in that first
line good afternoon estimate below per
day based on discussions with two towing
companies third towing company has
dropped out
we have total 10 trucks at this time
and then you'll see uh
that he says we need a letter from the
opp requesting these companies to
provide services and stating that the
federal act cover any damage to their
equipment and indemnify them from damage
or other claims resulting from vehicle
towed upon a police Direction
and then if we go up to the final email
in the chain
uh you'll see
that it says
um hi Veronica I've told them that the
letter will come tomorrow they will be
moving tonight based on my and Steve's
commitment credibility so would you
agree with me that at the end of the day
mot was actually only able to obtain two
towing companies and that those were
only obtained if they were compelled
under the federal emergencies act
certainly reading this uh I would say
that was by understanding going through
all that we I mean when I say toes
there's companies with multiple
equipment was my understanding we had a
significant number available but there
were holdouts that the emergencies acts
absolutely supported their engagement
and to bring this to a successful
conclusion but you'll agree with me that
uh as far as heavy toes are concerned
this email chain makes pretty clear that
they were only able to obtain these two
yes I'm fully Alive to the fact that
there was significant issue with toes
our friends from Ottawa Police and one
of their preliminary plans we're going
to use police officers because they
could not get access to toes they were
going to use police officers that had
the ability to drive those types of
vehicles to remove them so I would agree
it was a significant issue yes and and
that the solution to that issue when it
came to the heavy tow trucks was using
the emergencies act regulations
certainly assisted yes
you've talked uh in a fair amount of
detail this afternoon about the the
importance and the role of the plts in
yes and the the work they do
particularly to to shrink the the
footprint of a protest before
enforcement action is taken and I take
it based on what you've you've said
you'll agree with me that that was a
very important part of your plan here
yes
and in fact I think you said that uh if
you had had to go in without shrinking
the the footprint you would have needed
10 000 officers to deal with everyone
who was there just be
just me inside everybody that's in there
and two officers per just to do the math
it wouldn't need you'd need a lot more
officers yes
and
if you can't shrink the the footprint
not only do you need a lot more officers
but it takes more time to control the
situation very yes and also that there's
more risk of of violence or injuries
when you've got a bigger crowd to
control
there's always risks I mean we assess
those risks on a day by day then
operations hour by hour minute by minute
you know when PLT is engaged they're
really good at reporting back to us
whether or not they believe they've
reached their limit
and and in our plan our measured
approach it's it's PLT that gives us
that
uh final now what's the status do you
have any more room to move no okay
they're out
we we go in with with positive action
but but the bigger the bigger the the
activity that you're trying to deal with
the more possibility there is for
volatility yeah
and therefore the greater chance of of
violence and injuries yes
although I I I think it's important when
I hear the word violence and injuries
that was a key aspect of our plan of
this integrated plan yes I'm sure that
we from start to finish the systematic
expanding the process is done
with everything in our power to minimize
injury to anybody and we succeeded
absolutely and and uh you did succeed at
a big an important part of that was the
ability of the plts to shrink the
footprint significantly before it was
yes it was a good part of it
and the blt's ability to do that job is
dependent on how persuasive they can be
in convincing people to leave they're
negotiators you know they're their role
is to ensure that the the protesters or
those that are inside that perimeter are
aware of the the law the expectations
you know around lawful protests and then
when they go to the point that's no
longer lawful now you're committing from
offenses to inform them negotiate uh
it's about building trust sometimes they
they make concessions and people are
willing to do things we have to give
them the leeway to make some concessions
if necessary but this all happens with
the commanders being fully aware of of
what's going on with PLT with their
mandate what autonomy they've been given
what authorities have been given yes and
and one of the tools that the PLT has to
convince protesters to leave is
educating them on the consequences if
they don't leave absolutely
and presumably the the more significant
those consequences uh the more
persuasive the PLT can be in convincing
people to leave yes
and in this case uh when this plan was
actioned and the plts went in to do
their work to try and shrink the
footprints one of the tools that was
used was a pamphlet that was handed out
correct I believe so yes and and perhaps
I can just uh if I can pull up
opp401852 this is the integrated phased
approached plan
from February this particular version is
dated February 18th but I understand
this is just an update of the plan that
was in place for at least the third
since the 13th amendment was going
through various iterations and if we can
go to page five please
probably actually page six of the
uh
document it's page five on the page
numbers
yes down towards the bottom of the page
up a little bit uh just under the
Bolding there uh this talks about the
pamphlet uh that was being or it was a
meteor release provided because I
understand that there was also pamphlets
handed out that stated the same thing is
that your understanding as well yes and
so uh there's various information that
was being provided to the protesters to
try and convince them to leave by the
plts and it's listed here uh first it
mentions criminal code offenses and if
we can go to the next page
uh it then names a couple of
consequences that as I understand it uh
come out of the Ontario emergency
legislation is that correct yes uh and
those uh consequences in particular the
driver's license suspension and the
commercial commercial vehicle operators
registration suspension those would only
be applicable against uh people from
Ontario correct
so the Ontario legislation allowed you
to cancel the suspend the driver's
license we we based sees if that was a
vehicle from out of Province a plates
were removed the stickers were removed
and we would seize uh and and then we
had those agreements with other problems
but yes it was my understanding
enforcement day that's exactly how it
was used so your understanding is that
the Ontario legislation allowed they're
in the province just let me finish the
question allowed you to suspend the
driver's license of someone from British
Columbia who was sitting here in British
Columbia yes that is my understanding
if we go down the following uh
bullets are all
um except for the last one
um measures under the federal emergency
legislation correct correct so the uh
the personal business accounts personal
or business accounts uh they're bringing
the minor
into the fines for bringing miners into
the area and uh traveling to an unlawful
protest site
or delivering Fuel and other supplies
those were all under the federal
legislation correct and you'll agree
with me that the addition of those
bullet points provided more
persuasive fodder for the plts to
convince individuals to leave any piece
of legislation that we were given we
used to the extent that we could
possibly use it absolutely did support
it and and as a result of those
additional tools the PLT would have been
able to convince more people to leave
than they otherwise may have been able
to do well I don't have any metrics for
their success but I you know the more
that you can give them absolutely and
and so that allowed you to have a
smaller footprint that you were dealing
with and perhaps allowed you to get to
that smaller footprint faster
possibly
those are all my questions thank you
thank you
next is the
jccf Democracy fund
good afternoon Mr commissioner
good afternoon good afternoon sir good
afternoon
I'm Mr commissioner the um can you speak
up or turn up the sound of it but or
yeah
I guess Mr commissioner can you hear me
better now yes
thank you Council for the government of
Canada just brought up a document and
and uh showed it to the witness and it
was about tow trucks
um it's against the rules but I'm
wondering if you would grant me leave to
show this document this witness a single
document which we haven't provided
notice for but which may assist him and
which may assist the Commission in
understanding how many tow trucks may
have been available
well I'm not sure mechanically how we
can do this
a few questions arising of that one is
it is a document that exists in the
party database yes it is okay and is it
a are you able to provide the document
ID number
yes I am
um and Mr commissioner uh obviously
within your discretion but no uh the
parties nor commission Council haven't
had an opportunity to review the
document and see what it is I'm not I'm
not sure what it is but one of the
things that we can do is once we know
the numbers have an opportunity to look
and see what it is
for and for what it's worth commissioner
I was going to ask for relieved injuries
probably the very same document
okay
um well is there any objection obviously
if the opp seems to
have no problem with it uh
I think it should just go ahead if you
can give the number so that we can then
uh
get it before the commission
commissioner can I just uh
yeah
my only comment would be if it's in
relation to the questions I was asking
um and because I wasn't given notice
that it was going to be put to the
witness it may raise an additional
question for me I suspect I know what
document it is but I'm not entirely sure
until I see it obviously well if you
want to follow up on it you can ask at
the time and obviously I have discretion
to allow that thank you
foreign
thank you Mr commissioner the document
is OPP four Zero's one five eight five
can we just go down to the third page
the top of the third page please
so here you can see at email and can you
just actually scroll up a little bit so
we can see who the email is from
so this is an email from Rose DeMarco do
you know her yes she is a Deputy
Commissioner of traffic services and
Operational Support with the opp
yeah and it looks like this um
this email is being sent to somebody at
the solicitor General's office as well
as the opp commissioner yes
and if we just scroll down a little bit
she says there are a total of 64
um heavy tow companies in the province
of Ontario do you see that yes
and I think this is what you were um
referring to before she says companies
who would provide service
seven with 34 total heavy tow units yes
and if we just look down uh two lines
she says
10 companies waiting for callback uh
from the 57 in total yes
now the document that we just saw from
the government of Canada was I believe
dated February 17th 2022 so that's some
four days after this document
right
and it looks like uh perhaps in that
time
the the number of uh tow companies who
are willing to provide trucks or the
number of trucks that they can provide
uh decreases
it appears yes
and it could be the case could it not
that the invocation of the emergencies
act which happened in between these two
events
actually caused tow truck drivers or tow
truck companies to become more reluctant
to provide their services
or to put conditions upon their services
such as
indemnification for damages
it is possible but I I personally don't
believe that sir there was a reluctance
very very early uh with Phil companies
to to be engaged as I mentioned the Ops
on February 9th were unable to get any
tow companies to engage to the point
that they were going to use their own
people and I do believe there's even a
reference to getting the military to
come in a Tulsa vehicles for them if
needed so
while it may have had an impact I I
think it was an issue uh and I think
that issue was uh was connected broadly
to the broader issue that we were
dealing with
in the public domain namely the pandemic
this massive protests and the
unwillingness of some agencies to simply
be engaged
well it was an issue on February the 9th
as you say
um and it was still an issue on February
the 13th but there were some trucks
there there were some 34 trucks
can you think of anything material that
changed between the 13th and the 17th
other than the invocation of the
emergencies act which would cause
fewer companies to
um
to agree to you the opp using their
trucks or to provide them services to
the opt I think the key comment that I
that I think is appropriate for me on
the toll issue is that it we knew it was
a contentious our team knew it to be a
contentious issue from the very start of
our deployment I was fortunate to have a
team that I could just say can you deal
with this uh and and uh Kurt Richardson
MTO and the folks in that email right
after Deputy Commissioner DeMarco took
that off on play uh so they might be
better in a better position to answer
that question I simply asked for a toll
plan
and can you give me people that have the
capability to develop that plan and I
got a plan
and it worked
thank you very much
um let me change topics here for just a
moment
um we heard from your opt colleague
superintendent Patrick Morris not Longo
that he thought some of what the media
was reporting was problematic did you
hear that evidence
I did not here is evidence uh I I think
I listened in about 10 minutes of it as
I was doing arrived in Ontario looking
to do some of my own prep so I didn't
spend a lot of time
are you aware that he testified that he
read accounts of for example Russia
being involved in the protests and he
found that to be problematic I think I
may have read that somewhere yes
in your evidence today you adopted um a
will say
um and in that we'll say uh you stated
the media was not portraying what was on
the ground can you tell us what your
concerns were well just the things were
happening and they this this protest
group were incredibly well organized in
my opinion and the narrative about what
was happening in Ottawa was
be in control was one-sided
and now
sorry go ahead no and and that's That's
the basis for that that comment because
there was a lot of good things happening
you know we
there's there's things that were going
on within the protest group you know
that you know we heard about the bouncy
castles and the prayer meetings in the
morning
but we didn't hear publicly about
threats to people inside the perimeter
who wanted to leave and they didn't want
them to leave we didn't hear about that
publicly things of that nature as it
just but one small example of of you
know the narrative that was out there
about you know this is a family event
bring your kids there's a bouncy castle
we can have fun
uh yet there were people within that Red
Zone that wanted to leave and felt
threatened and couldn't leave
and you didn't think that was being
accurately
um conveyed by the media it was not
being conveyed at all in my opinion
what about um something like what
Patrick Morris um testified to that the
protesters were being portrayed as
extremists and he found that to be
problematic did you find that to be
problematic as well I I do because I've
been involved in the events in the past
from Hawaii Summits to some of the G
events where we had a lot of extremist
views there was fringes of it with the
two groups I believe that were around
Nicholas and Waller and uh Rito Sussex
baby
were out of concern but they were not a
a major concern but there's always that
risk of escalation uh that you that you
see from from those extremist groups
uh it was the profile of the protester
for this event was none like I've ever
seen in my 36-year career
uh we had everything from grandparents
uh you know my first day in this
assignment I was showing a picture of
two officers that had worked for me in
the past who had retired who were in the
crowd with the protesters we saw
children we saw a lot of crestfallen
police officers uh in the crowd military
nurses so it wasn't your normal group of
people that you're dealing with
so it
I guess that's the point is was there
still concerns from our perspective uh
on extremism absolutely but we relied on
and trusted the intelligence as it came
in on that regard
uh thank you very much sir those are my
questions
thank you uh next uh call on the city of
Ottawa please
good afternoon Chief superintendent my
name is Ann tardief and I'm one of the
lawyers representing the city of Ottawa
afternoon if I could turn up um or ask
to be turned up
opp401792 and Sir these are your notes I
don't know if you have a hard copy there
that you'd prefer to refer to but
otherwise it'll go up on the screen I'll
wait for the screen
and could I ask that you turn to page uh
three please of the document
now this is just to show you the date uh
at the tops or the 8th of February 2022
and if we could school down to about the
middle of page four
a little a little bit lower there we go
um
now do you see there's an arrow there
that has the word from federal
government at the end of it and I'm
going to ask you if you could help me
out with your handwriting for the first
part of it
yeah to help you my hand I am sorry
do you see it there there's an arrow
about just below the middle line what
did you write there daily Siege from
federal government daily C age from
federal government what did you mean by
that pressure pressure and was this
pressure
um that was being uh placed upon the
Ottawa Police Service
I
please service the community to get this
result on Ottawa as a whole to get this
results basically and was this Siege
being applied just you know privately in
calls to the chief or or to City
officials or was this occurring publicly
well I mean this is notes that I took
I'm being briefed on my assignment okay
it might be better from from those who
gave me that but that was my sense from
The Briefing that there's pressure
around like this we got to get this
fixed and can you just help us out who
Who provided this briefing I was jointly
provided by
Mr Creek
Deputy Commissioner Harkins uh Mike
mcnamelle at injects as related to PLU
and Craig Abrams
who was on video link and gave me gave
us the overview of the state that was in
up to that point
thank you so we can ask them about this
and I take it they were relaying this to
you in your briefing because that meant
that the or that was impacting the
response in Ottawa making things more
difficult if I can put it that way
yes
um if we could turn a now to page
12 of the document please
okay and
if you could scroll to the bottom of the
page Madam clerk now we can go back if
you need me to sir we're on February 9th
at this point
if you could stop there Madam clerk do
you want me to go backwards to see the
date or you're all right okay let me
know if you do want me to do you see the
entry there 10 34 on February 9th and it
says a TC which I take it as telephone
call yes from uh Deputy Harkins is that
right yes and he's the Deputy
Commissioner for field operations
it says need to be looking at this more
broadly and there's an Asterix
Ambassador Bridge shut down yes we could
scroll to next page please 402 that's
the highway right yes shut down both
directions 40 kilometers from the border
by farm tractors yes uh economic impact
equals
350 million dollars per day right
correct correct and then it says big
Auto and there's an arrow 24 hours and
they shut down at factories is that
right the shutdown factories shut down
factories okay and this is being
reported to you by uh Deputy
Commissioner Harkins right
um and then the next I'll skip over the
next aspects only because I think that
may relate to Toronto is that right
that's regarding the GTA dump for Waste
would be impacted of where it could go
because of the closure of the 402 yes
okay so this is an impact on the Toronto
garbage dump arising from the blockade
and at The Ambassador Bridge in Windsor
well not the Ambassador because it's
Lampton County and I portrayed by
geography for Western Ontario is a
little off okay it may have been uh as a
result of 402 I see which is separate
from understood
um and then it says uh planning to block
access to impact Toronto that's what you
just told us and then at the final
little note here it says request to
determine what the
and what's that next word current
resource deployment is to the city of
Ottawa okay perfect
um and then if we turn over the page to
page
20
24.
and so now we're at February 10th and
I'm actually if you could just go up to
page 23 Madam clerk we'll just see the
beginning of this do you see at night oh
down a bit do you see it 9 21 that yes
so this is again a telephone call with
Deputy Harkins and it says you were I
guess you and the deputy were joined
later by commissioner Creek is that
correct right and this is on on February
10th
um and before we get into this I just
want to back up a little bit so we
talked about the call just the day prior
on February 9th where you're alerted to
the situation in Windsor Windsor pardon
me and asked about the current uh
resource deployment to the city of
Ottawa and February 9th is the same day
that you had the
I'm going to call it the the meeting at
Elgin Head Street headquarters of the
integrated Planning Group with ops
command is that right that's correct
okay and coming out of that you
mentioned earlier in your testimony
there was a an ask for stopping and I
think you said the number was 516. 516.
correct right and that was a maintenance
ask
so in other words that's the number of
officers Ops needed from Opp just to
maintain the current posture and traffic
points right
uh yes as I said the earlier though
there was some math problem with It
ultimately that number you divide uh 516
by three I think it's one seven sorry
174 or 178 or something like that uh
because they were admin employing a
three shift model
uh and as we we talked it through it it
was like oh I forgot to tell you we
actually with the support of the Ottawa
Police Association they had reverted
back to the two shift model which would
allow you to spread sure are inherent
benefits with the three shift model uh
but with my organization coming in uh it
certainly would be a benefit beyond the
same type of rotation I wish they did
the RCP however remained on the free
ship month okay so I don't think we need
to get quite to the level of specificity
of numbers but if I understand that the
maintenance ask on three shifts was five
sixteen five one six that's correct
three shifts on three shifts and if you
drop it to two ships which you said you
were able to do then it's probably
closer to 300. is that about right I
would put it in the range of 3
. okay well 350.
in other words it's about a third less
yeah it's a third lesson okay whatever
that number amounts to fair enough
um so that's the the number that comes
out for maintenance of the February 9th
planning meeting but of course the Ops
was also looking for additional Pou
supports for their enforcement action
correct absolutely and the decision of
the opp coming out of that planning
meeting was we will meet your
maintenance task we'll Supply what
turned out to be approximately 350
officers to maintain the current posture
but at this time we're not going to move
forward with the PO you ask for the
reasons you've already explained
relating to the planned Etc yeah
that's not accurate No we continue to
deploy plou to make plans for PLU uh we
had uh there was obviously a plan in in
uh in Windsor at The Ambassador Ridge
for Action down there but that did not
slow us down we knew that it was good of
course it was going to impact because
we're drawing the same pool sure but it
did not stop we just realized at that
stage that uh because I'm not mistaken
Darwin Petrol in that same meeting said
we need that 800 that's about all that
we have in the province of Ontario
suddenly we have the pivot we're not
going to get all we have in the province
of Ontario because they're going to be
used and they're going to be needed then
in Windsor then we started our Outreach
to Edmonton Calgary Vancouver uh another
and the province of Quebec okay well In
fairness do you let me show you where I
I thought I saw that information and you
can perhaps correct me if I'm wrong can
we go to page 19 please of this document
okay and
actually just scroll up a little bit
please Madam clerk the following page so
there's that 516 number right three
shifts as documented by Ops 516 that's
the maintenance number and we've
explained that they went down to two
ships so it ends up being more like 350.
correct and now let's scroll down Madam
clerk now I see a number of Pou requests
here and if we keep scrolling down
okay stop there you'll see the lowest
peo you get Pou by this stage 55 plus
600. so that was their pous coming out
of the planning meeting on the ninth
right
uh I believe so yes okay
and
can we scroll down a little bit more
Madam clerk please
and then it's up there and then you'll
see where it says 1635 do you see that
yes it's his briefed team these are your
notes right sir yes and then it says
will staff to the maintenance plan which
has roles and responsibilities built in
continue to build our plan right so
that's what I was referring to yeah and
that's accurate but okay but when we
talk about that uh in our plan and we
continue to build we're asking as we
need
you know we we had people we weren't
also we were not taking action we were
not in a position we needed 800. and
that's what I meant earlier for the
reasons you've discussed the plan's not
there right now you're Staffing to the
maintenance because that's what you
think is needed in Ottawa right then and
our ass still immediately go out for
others now we want others to join in we
need we need the SQ we need Vancouver we
need Calgary in Edmonton to join the
team because we need this number and
then the logistics around arranging all
that getting the approvals the supports
for them to be deployed or occurred and
I understand that but at this point the
immediate decision is to staff to the
maintenance plan can we agree to that
yes okay
um now back to page 24 please Madam
clerk we're going to move ahead to
February 10th
and we'll scroll up to just up to the
following page sorry 9 21 this is where
we were telephone call with Deputy
Harkins joined later by commissioner
Greek we'll scroll down to page 24 and
if I could stop you madam clerk at the
CC do you see that there uh that's
commissioner karik I'm assuming since he
joined the call later I think so okay
and it says um provincial priority has
changed due to ongoing now you'll have
to help me with the next word
issue issue thank you due to ongoing
issue in Windsor both from I think
that's Intel and impact assessment yes
okay
is uh it is now our priority it mean
Windsor while continuing to support the
RCMP slash Ops in Ottawa we may not be
in position to supply Ottawa with all
they need at this juncture
right and that's what commissioner Creek
told you on the morning of February 10th
correct yes just to put us in time
that's the Thursday right before the
weekend correct yes okay and
um
it's my understanding that the
maintenance ask
the approximately 350 officers was
actually only fulfilled on the morning
of Saturday February 12th is that
accurate
uh you know what I I need a lot of
information in front of me to be very
specific in terms of when we finally did
it uh we certainly made the ask and yeah
and I no one's suggesting otherwise so I
can pull up a document it's not a
problem with my no if you say it it was
reported that it took the L then to do
it I believe that okay it was a struggle
a lot of people did not want to be
deployed to Ottawa a lot of people did I
missed the last part did not want to be
deployed there to Ottawa yes okay we you
want people to want to be there
uh but uh it was a struggle right so
there and and the circumstances you're
describing Windsor and the the reasons
you've just described that explains why
the ask being made took you know from
February 9th to February 12th to be
fulfilled by the open key right and when
you say OPP and oppm partner agencies of
course wasn't just I just happened to be
OPP
were there with an integration with
multiple agencies we're all in it
together I understand let me be fair to
you it took three days for opt together
with all of its partner agencies to
fulfill that okay
thank you uh next uh the Convoy
organizers
good afternoon Mr commissioner good
afternoon Chief party my name is
Bathsheba Vandenberg and I'm Council
representing Freedom Corp and protesters
I have a few questions for you this
afternoon
I'd like to ask you about the February
9th plan I referred to earlier today a
contemplated building a public order
unit plan is that right yes
oh sorry
the February 9th plan that the Ottawa
Police presented to us that's right yes
okay yes
was the first operation of that February
9th plan to clear Vito Sussex on
Thursday February the 10th at 6 A.M
it was going to be 4 AM with a
possibility of being moved up to 11 p.m
on that date that they were telling us
okay
and was it event can Commander Patterson
who wanted to deploy pous as part of
executing that plan well we we didn't
get into the weeds in terms of numbers
but PLU was part of uh the plan that
they were going uh to execute and an
Incident Commander had been assigned
on that plan okay thank you and
yesterday superintendent Abrams
testified that the police the Amazon
teams plts were not involved in the
planning process
and he suspected that event Commander
Patterson did not communicate this plan
to the plts is that right
uh uh yes that's fair
were you aware that at the same time as
the integrated cell planning what you
call the the group uh that the plts were
negotiating a plan with some of the
protesters to start moving trucks on
February 10th from the Rito Sussex
intersection
I I don't have independent recollection
right now and there's so much that was
going on uh
as possible yes
was the February 9th plan abandoned
because there were not enough pous
well what happened myself and Phil Liu
prior to leaving the Ottawa headquarters
met with uh
Acting Superintendent Burnett we both
knew him and Phil had worked closely
with him in in the Years prior
we stopped by to say hello as as we were
leaving the building we're aware of the
view was being assigned the task
we did not uh
I didn't get into the details of it
other than he told us that he had some
legal concerns that he was seeking
advice on
and that from there he was going to be
Consulting with his uh
PLU experts he consulted and that's 18
20 that day we learned that they did
consult with the broader group
and uh and uh
they didn't find it to be tactically
sound and
decided to defer and that was on
February 10th
I learned that on February 10th yes
because notwithstanding what was nope
sorry I learned that on February 9th
that it was night that it was shut down
just discussed now uh on February 10th
uh
we learned that the commissioner Carrick
mentioned to you that there was a lack
of availability of Pou resources and
also did RCMP Sergeant deathrow also
tell you this that there was a lack of
Pou resources well we we knew that you
know PLU was going to be uh be stretched
in the province
the capacity that we had
are you aware that the RCMP put a freeze
for 70 72 hours from February 10 to 13th
on any Pou intervention
I I need to know some greater contacts
I'm not sure where that's from
I don't recall it but I'm not saying it
didn't happen okay thank you
uh earlier today the mission statement
of the February 13th plan was put to you
and it included a reference to the
utmost respect to the individual Charter
rights and freedoms is that right yes
and part of that February 13 plan to
contain a main action plan is that
correct yes
another mission statement provides
strategic direction to operations is
that correct
and that the objective of the main
action plan was to de-escalate and
negotiate a peaceful resolution and even
demobilization of the Ottawa truck
demonstration
on February 14th you continue to work on
developing the February 13th plan with a
group of Pou smes is that correct
correct the February 17th plan referred
to in your testimony of officially
titled integrated public order unit
concept of operations is also referred
to as Pou technical plan or action plan
correct
yes it's a subplan of the master plan
right and the objective of that February
17th action plan was to systematically
clear and take down the protests right
I put it to you that the mission of the
February 17th action plan was to ensure
the removal of the protesters in the
area of the blockades in relation to the
freedom Convoy 2022 this will be
achieved by securing isolating and
evacuating persons within the designated
blockade zones to ensure the safe
detention and arrests of any participant
taking into custody ensure public and
police safety
you agree that there is no reference to
the Charter of Rights and Freedoms in
the February 17th action plan
that's that's normally words contained
but what you read there no
thank you those are all my questions and
thank you for your 36 years of service
thank you
thank you if I could now uh call on the
government of Saskatchewan
go ahead good afternoon sir can you hear
me yes
thank you
sir my name is Mike Morris and I'm
counsel for the government of
Saskatchewan I'm just going to have a
few questions for you today
would you agree with me that the opp the
RCMP and the Ops did not need the
federal emergencies act to be invoked to
set up an integrated command structure
for the purposes of setting up a new
degree to command structure no
we've done that in every major event
that we that we've had with Ops in in
the past
and I gather your degree that those same
police forces didn't need the federal
emergencies act to be invoked to come up
with an operational plan for removing
the occupation in Ottawa correct I would
agree with that
and you signed off on the operational
plan that was ultimately used on
February 12th on behalf of the opp
correct
that was a version there were multiple
versions but that was a version yes
okay and I understand the RCMP approved
that same version of the plan on
February 12th as well is that correct
yes sir
and I think we've heard that the Ops
approved that same version of the plan
on February 13th correct correct
and when you signed off on that plan
you were confident that it could be
implemented to end the occupation
correct yes
and the February 13th plan did not
contemplate any powers under the federal
emergencies act correct
not at that time no
and as commander of the integrated
planning cell if you had thought that
such Powers were needed you would have
told someone correct
well we certainly felt that we had what
we needed to develop a plan to to
dismantle the protests with what we had
thank you sir those are my questions
thank you
thank you
next I could call on the government of
Alberta
good afternoon
my name is Mandy England and I'm asking
some questions today on behalf of the
government of Alberta
sir you mentioned in your response to
council for the government of Canada
that some tow truck operators were
reluctant due to liability issues
um to engage in in the towing and so the
emergencies Act was helpful in that
respect was that correct that's correct
and so would it be fair to say that
there were tow truck drivers who were
willing to do it they would not have
needed to be compelled to do it but they
just wanted that additional reassurance
about liability
yes that's fair
okay
isn't it true that there are also
Provisions under the Ontario emergency
management and civil protection act that
protect individuals who are acting in
good faith and performing an order under
that act from an action against them for
liability and Performing that Duty I do
believe so yes
and um is it true that there's
Provisions under that act that provide a
way for anyone whose property is damaged
where an order under the ACT is being
carried out to seek compensation from
The Province itself rather than from an
individual like a tow truck operator
who's carrying out the order
well I'll be honest now you're giving
you the weeds of it that uh I'd have to
say I need to look at it to see when to
provide it but I I was looking at it and
I focused mostly on the enforcement
powers that it gave us
if if what I had just said was true that
there was a mechanism for that
individual um to have sought
compensation
would you agree um that between those
two items uh that if there was an order
under the Ontario act authorizing the
tow truck drivers to provide those
tolling services that those operators
would be protected in the same way by
the Ontario Act
I'm not sure because I know we we had
some difficulties with our earlier
planning where we had a robust toll plan
in place and it all fell apart because
of of the indemnity issue and the the
length of time for that Indemnity uh
that the operators just felt that given
the nature of the protests the fear of
reprisal uh that they needed an extended
period of an Indemnity that we just
couldn't provide
so uh I I again I I I I left the tow
issue to our total experts uh but uh uh
I I I'd have to look at the legislation
and maybe even consult a lawyer looking
at the legislation as to I'll fire and
how deep the indemnity of other the
emcpa or the EA provided
that's fair uh if the provisions were
the same or substantially similar though
would would you agree that the Ontario
legislation would have been equally
helpful then in uh providing the
assurances to tow truck operators if
you're telling me that then I would say
it it would be
thank you very much those are my
questions for you today thank you thank
you okay thank you uh if I uh does the
opp have any uh re-examination excuse me
or any examination sorry excuse me Mr
excuse me Mr commissioner I believe
before we get to the party for the
witnesses the Ottawa Coalition did have
five minutes and the party for the
witness usually gets to go last
I am sorry I must have skipped them I
apologize
Mr champ you have five minutes and I'll
even give you six if you need it given
my error
uh good afternoon uh Chief
superintendent thank you for joining us
my name is Paul champ I'm a lawyer for
the Ottawa Coalition for residents and
businesses yes just a few questions for
you uh Chief superintendent
um
I've represented police officers for
many years for about 20 years and it's
been my experience that there's a lot of
very strong personalities and policing
is that fair to say very fair strong
characters strong leaders uh and
sometimes those personalities can
conflict yes and similarly when you have
uh these strong personalities and
Leadership positions it can be kind of
difficult for them to to give up uh
leadership or maybe admit they're wrong
or or seek assistance is that fair to
say
thank you
yes no sometimes it's a failure of
leadership for not doing it not asking
for help that's fair
where I was going to go at uh wanted to
ask you about Chief superintendent is
that you told us before about how a
chief of police in Ontario can ask the
Ontario uh Provincial Police to to take
over their service or assist their
service in cases of emergency correct
yes and
um uh Chiefs Foley didn't do that in
these circumstances no
um but it's also the case that uh the um
under the police services act the board
could ask
the opp to take over correct the Police
Services Board
yes or the Ontario civilian police
commission yes so if they have the
relevant or proper information they
could have considered that and weighed
that option
yes they could and you would agree with
me that giving the the prevailing
conditions in Ottawa at that time
the Ottawa Police simply couldn't
provide adequate and effective policing
services to their community
I'd say they were stretched uh as a
related
specifically to the protests
to say that they were not otherwise
providing because Ottawa is not just the
downtown courser that's fair absolutely
no because we we talk regularly with
them about their ability to respond to
their day-to-day business right
but we've heard lots of evidence and I
don't think it's really in dispute that
the Auto police services simply did not
have the capacity to bring this event to
an end on their own the numbers were
such the scale was such it was it was
recognized generally the Auto police
couldn't end this on their own correct
that's correct and uh it took an
enormous amount more of police uh
resources from elsewhere to bring an end
to this correct and
um I'm just wondering like I I was
taking a look and reviewing the the
national framework on police
preparedness for demonstration
assemblies and there's nothing in there
about what happens if the pl if the if
the demonstration is of such a scale
that the police force of jurisdiction
can't manage it and then how or in what
way uh there could be a trigger for them
to ask for another service to maybe even
take over if they're having a real
problem would you agree with me Chief
certain tenant that that more policy or
protocol around that for how pleased
Services can feel comfortable reaching
out to get assistance would be helpful
it absolutely would yeah if Chief slowly
had had some more guidance on that or he
his strong personality maybe he felt he
was kind of getting it from all sides I
think we've heard a lot of evidence from
that uh felt embattled
um but if there was a policy there
saying hey at this point that's a
trigger you should actually seed
responsibilities to another service that
that perhaps could have helped this
crisis would you agree
whether or not it's seeding
responsibility to another organization
you know uh I'll just back up and
qualify this answer with another
statement
the opp policy for example when uh an
incident uh
exhausts the ability of the local
Detachment to respond we will stand up
in EOC so we have a more coordinated
responses now we're going to be needing
resources for up from other so it's kind
of embred in our nature that when a an
event overwhelms one jurisdiction
OPP jurisdiction and others are needed
we stand up a broader group to support
to ensure that the response so that the
locals can still focus and we can bring
in supports so I I don't believe it's
about policy that he would have to cede
responsibility but certainly that when
you are overwhelmed that uh it's time to
ask and integrate with our organizations
to seek the resistance to collectively
uh
bring it into the unlawful activity I
hear you Chief superintendent but I
guess just what I'm what I'm suggesting
is that it's a little bit ad hoc
right it is no real good guidance for a
chief about when might be the right time
to press the emergency button I would
say there probably is no guidance or
written guidance in that regard okay
thank you very much
thank you now I will uh call on the opp
okay good afternoon good afternoon sir
it's Christopher Diana Council of the
opp as you know
I'd like to maybe take a step back a
little bit you've answered a lot of
questions about you know the details of
what happened in Ottawa part of the
Mandate of this commission and part of
what I think the commissioner may be
interested in hearing about as well is
taking a look at the bigger picture
Lessons Learned is part of the Mandate
of this commission and you're in a
unique position as a recent retiree with
36 years of experience doing this kind
of public order policing and incident
command to maybe give some thoughts that
maybe of assistance to the commissioner
and the question I wanted to ask you in
particular is about
an integrated or unified command do you
believe in the value of that concept
absolutely it's absolutely critical to
our success in any event where it's it's
beyond the scope of one organization
right and what are some of the
impediments so if we're looking at
Lessons Learned what are some of the
impediments going forward that the
commissioner may want to consider while
contemplating the evidence that he hears
well we've already heard about you know
the personalities that exist in a lot of
police leadership roles oftentimes that
that can be the impediment they simply
don't want to they want to do this on
their own
they they don't need help or I need your
help but I want command and control of
your resources there's an organization
out there that I know of that would ever
say okay we'll send you 500 officers and
just use them gently it doesn't work
that way you know when you send when you
deploy five six hundred officers to
another organization they come with a
command and control if you don't
integrate you're going to be working in
silos uh if you don't integrate you're
not going to be communicating
about the ultimate strategic objectives
and goals of what you're trying to
accomplish so it's absolutely critical
that leaders Buy in leadership is
actually absolutely key at all levels in
my humble opinion if you don't have the
leaders a leadership team buying in then
it's not going to work and I think just
to maybe kind of drill down a little bit
into the why why isn't as a unified
command a useful tool even if there's an
event in a larger city that has a large
Police Service Ottawa has a fairly large
Police Service Toronto or other you know
large Police Services May benefit from
this concept but maybe you can explain
why this is useful Toronto police
service for example may have a lot of
resources but why is a unified team
useful for a large event
well it's beautiful because of you know
the power of the human brain the more
people that you have the more expertise
do you bring to bear on a problem the
more communication that you have you
know your your solution is going to be
that much more refined
and appropriate
it takes as I mentioned earlier in my
evidence it takes the weight off the one
one pair of shoulders who is feeling the
burden of this event and I I feel for
chief slowly the the burden that he was
under uh uh for this event but bringing
in an integrated command and all that it
brings to bear with the resources the
subject matter expertise can only
produce a win
ultimately though it comes down to
whether the Police Service of
jurisdiction kind of buys into the
concept correct yes
thank you commissioner
okay can I just check with the
government of Canada are you content
there's nothing further you'd like
no okay I I just have a couple of
questions uh uh Chief uh party uh about
there have been words about what the uh
the operation and it's
it's been referred to as I understand it
as ending the occupation but also some
people have said ending the protest is
there a difference in your mind between
the approach of saying I the plan is to
end the protest or end the occupation I
I certainly have have used them
synonymous today as one of the same it
was it was absolutely in my view in
occupation
uh but it's often referred to as a
protest a protest can be an occupation
so they're one of the same for my view
okay and and in that I just want to ask
you if you could have a look at your
mission statement and we've had it uh
referred to and I think it's uh OPP
uh one eight five one
and I think we might be at page eight I
think if I could I'm correct
for the go down a bit I or yeah it's up
a bit it's the mission statement I'm
looking for
no that's not the right document then
it would be in that document sir okay
and where would it maybe it's doubt
okay it may be further down I think it
was I believe it's page eight deck page
eight if we had just gone down a little
bit from where we were
ah there it is okay and I'm wondering
here
you you've put in with the utmost
respect to the individual's Charter of
Rights and Freedoms
uh and I was wondering was there any
thought about there are protesters there
that may wish to protest
appropriately if I can call it without
breaking law I I.E continue a protest
legally in some manner in some place yes
was that taken into account absolutely
it was taken into consideration in our
message and through PLT that you know
you want to protest where you are now is
deemed illegal you need to leave you
want to protesters other venues and this
is why we put in this Mission about the
charter race because there is there are
lawful protests that you can do
I guess that's why I was wondering about
your answer of saying ending the protest
and ending the occupation you took as
being the same the same but I I guess I
should qualify within that Red Zone
that's now deemed to be an illegal
occupation if you're in there you're
breaking the law if you're in there you
uh you need to leave because it has been
deemed illegal what you're doing an
illegal occupation so that meant because
we had a lot of people that are PLT uh
interacted with that
continually uh pleaded that well we're
all doing everything lawful they have
this plot a lot of them felt they had
that denied plausible deniability until
they so PLT had to educate them okay
here it's a lawful protest to a point
now you've reached a point there's
injunctions there's criminal mischief
going on there's all these things that
are happening this protest this
demonstration this occupation is now
deemed unlawful and you need to leave
uh if they chose and we gave people an
exit strategy and they told Well we'd
like to uh a protest location where our
voice can be heard that would have been
facility but facilitated by PLT
okay so so the PLT was seeking to reduce
shrink the footprint but are you saying
they also would facilitate A continuing
legal protest in some location or in
some manner if someone said to them but
we have a right to protest they would
have said not here
there's other ways that you could
protest but now you're in an illegal
Zone to protest
and they were they they on a state
facilitated and they're not going to you
know stop what they're doing so we can
now now set up a place for you to
protest but they would certainly and
we've done that I'll I'll use the
example of of G8 we set up the protested
stages everything you want to protest
here you go here and protest BLT fail to
help facilitate this because you're not
getting to there
was there any part of the plan that that
provided for this aspect that you've
just described that you could continue
your protest legally just not here I
think by that time we had exhausted all
negotiation
uh and uh without reading the final plan
I would say no because our negotiations
with the protesters had reached the
point that they were proving to be
futile so now enforcement action was
next
now that measured approach
are you aware of of people after or
members of the public in Media or
otherwise
criticizing after the fact the operation
saying they simply wish to peacefully
protest
uh I I don't doubt that I don't
independently recall those like I I
didn't actually I avoided the media in
the news was fair enough so I could
focus uh but I I don't particularly
recall it but I don't doubt it
um we have to looked at that with with
you know very very carefully I I'm
certain there's a lot of people in that
protest Zone they realize like oh
they're actually telling us the truth
this is an illegal occupation now we
have to move basically Scandal out of
there because they're as I mentioned
earlier about the profile of of the
protesters unlike anything we'd ever
seen there was a lot of good people in
them that simply wanted their voice to
be heard we knew that
but they were mixed with a lot of danger
as well inside in terms of the potential
and threats of violence that were that
existed in there uh so um we gave the
opportunities that was all part of the
negotiations
they even looked at having alternate
locations for the trucks to go
so that they could stage there and we'll
bust you for a protest
and that did not work out
and so just to close that Loop you so
are you do you feel the plan was
adequate in terms of allowing continued
protests for those who may wish it at in
retrospect at the stage where we
executed this plan and went kinetic I.E
we we went uh Hands-On with the
operation uh that was the option that
was left available to us with all other
aspects of the plan exhausted I do
believe that we acted appropriately
professionally and accomplished not only
our mission but all of our goals and
objectives in terms of a assisting and
restoring the confidence uh and faith in
the city of Ottawa and Ottawa Police uh
returning Ottawa to a relative state of
normalcy for business to be able to open
uh and uh and doing so without injuring
people
and having to arrest too many people we
know our our you know a lot of people
put a lot of stock into rest arrests we
also know our justice system uh just
doesn't have the ability
for us to rest and charge 3 000 people
we all know what would happen there so I
believe that we accomplish those goals
and did so and and returned because very
shortly thereafter there were protests
against the city of Ottawa that were
permitted and and were peaceful
okay thank you one other thing I just
want to explore briefly uh you spoke
about plts and uh
I don't know how to put it it was not
necessarily embraced uh as it maybe
should have been
uh by Ops in in this operation is that
fair in in their initial yes the initial
you know within a day of our arrival
there we engage with uh Marcel bodan who
I believe you're going to be hearing
from uh and uh we got things back on we
they ever collectively when I say we got
it back on track with with a PLT Focus
now a lot of the work of PLT involves as
you've talked about negotiating
de-escalating yes and
uh for those who wish to bring a quick
end to a protest
plts maybe are not are not viewed in the
same way or they're viewed as delaying
what they wish as a result uh I I my my
personal opinion is if we took an
enforcement action directly every time
just to end it uh we'd be sitting for
another commission of inquiry in the
road about about a lack of a measured
approach so in my humble opinion I would
use PLT in every circumstances they may
last 10 minutes and and be rendered and
effect of what we we've tried we've
given we've we've tried a negotiation
route we've tried the de-escalation
route it did not work before we go
kinetic yeah you you may be going the
wrong direction you're thinking I'm
going the wrong direction I I'm not
disagreeing with that okay what I'm
trying to get at is
the public often is not aware of the
role and importance of plts because they
want results would that be fair in some
cases I would I would say that's the
fair statement sir and I guess all I'm
asking is do you think an important
component in a protest such as this is
educating the public on the need for the
process to be worked through negotiation
Etc in other words
because we heard a lot about public
pressure to close this down and and I'm
just asking whether there is a role for
public education there's a significant
role in fact when you look I'm sure
you'll get this from inspector about
that a lot of what PLT does because it's
not with just with the protesters that
they deal with a lot of what they do is
education as well
you know they because our plts are
active not just in the middle of a
crisis
they're active so education is
absolutely critical the public needs to
know when we engage PLT in these vets we
have PLT members who are dealing with
the Business Association we have PLT
members dealing with the residents so
that we know collectively all of the
issues that we're facing so they're not
just negotiating with the protesters
necessarily they're looking at everybody
that is impacted by education I would
love for every member of the public to
become a BLT one of our goals in our
communication strategy was to make every
uniform officer with their messaging
from the gospel on the street up to the
prime minister of Canada if we can get
everybody saying the same message we're
educating the public we will succeed
that was a stated goal right within our
mission okay well thank you very much
sir and thank you for your testimony
very we appreciate even though you're in
retirement yes I'm sorry my apologies um
I have just a few questions this is uh
for the record Brian Miller Council for
the freedom Corp arising from your
questions I had none uh until some
answers came out there's just uh
probably about two minutes of questions
I would like to ask if I may serve with
respect to uh the evidence from uh the
witness regarding there being no more
ability uh to negotiate et cetera given
that I understand that that wasn't the
case sir I'm I'm uh there is no
provision for re-examination we're not
going to reopen it there will be plenty
of witnesses you can question about the
process as they come through but I'm I'm
not going to reopen because you wouldn't
be the only one very well sir thank you
okay so with that uh thank you for your
uh your testimony and especially since
you're retired uh appreciated we're
going to rise until uh Monday morning at
9 30. thank you
the commission is a journal Commission
on their Journey